So, damit konstatieren wir, der Juli erfordert Aufklärung in wichtigen Fragen.
Die erste möchte ich lösen. Taylor Swift natürlich. Sie ist die Größere.
Manche würden jetzt sagen Celine Dion.
Ja, jetzt gerade. Aber es scheint ein Strohfeuer zu sein.
Naja, also Celine Dion ist schon eine Weile im Geschäft und hat jetzt nach schwerer
Krankheit ein großes Comeback erlebt.
Da will ich gar nichts gegen sagen. Ich habe allerdings noch nichts von Olympia
gesehen. Also ein paar Skateboarder.
Trotzdem finden einige Menschen Kamala Harris, wie auch immer sie ausgesprochen
wird, Kamala, glaube ich, mit A's, ist auch ein recht großer Hype. Wie gehypt bist du?
Ich bin nicht sonderlich gehypt und würde auch mich davon distanzieren wollen,
von diesen ganzen Hypes, die es gerade gibt.
Also, wir, jetzt hier ein deutsches Publikum, das nicht wählen kann in den USA.
Aber wir können doch Unsere amerikanischen Brüder und Schwestern unterstützen
in ihren Wählerentscheidungen.
Wir können sie gar nicht unterstützen. Also wir sind nur Beobachter.
Das müssen wir schon mal verstehen.
Wir sind nur Beobachter und wir brauchen die Wahl nicht zu treffen.
Wir müssen gar nicht zwischen Kamala oder Trump wählen.
Aber es betrifft uns auch, wenn es passiert.
Es betrifft uns und wir werden ja heute sehr viele Beispiele hören,
was könnte dann passieren, wenn das eine oder das andere passiert,
aber wir können deshalb beide Kandidaten kritisch betrachten,
müssen uns also diese Frage, wen wähle ich denn jetzt am Ende, gar nicht stellen.
Und jetzt würde ich erst einmal festhalten, für die amerikanische Bevölkerung
wäre es sicherlich besser, wenn Kamala Präsidentin wird, als wenn Trump es wird.
Geopolitisch sieht die Sache sehr viel verrückter, vertrackter aus,
wie wir heute noch hören werden.
Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Trump bringt uns allen den Frieden,
aber wir werden heute sehr viele Beispiele für das hören, was Trump machen könnte
und man weiß es nicht, wohin es mit Kamala geht, sie hat ja jetzt noch gar keine Möglichkeit,
das auszubuchstabieren.
Ich würde jedenfalls Abstand nehmen vor einem Hype.
Denn das macht ja jetzt eigentlich wieder das Falsche.
Man versucht ja jetzt wieder nicht klar auf die Dinge zu blicken,
sondern man wartet jetzt einfach auf eine andere Erlöserfigur.
Also man hat für die Rechten und die Verrückten Trump und jetzt wollen aber
die anderen auch eine Erlöserfigur haben und finden die dann in Kamala Harris.
Und ich muss eines konstatieren, durch Trump sind wir alle dümmer geworden.
Wir sind alle dümmer geworden und ich will Beispiele dafür geben,
wie die Debatte läuft. Lass uns mal beginnen mit einem Beitrag,
den Trump abgegeben hat. Wahlkampf 2020.
Also da war Kamala Harris nur als Vizepräsidentin angedacht,
ist es ja dann auch geworden.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal an, was Trump 2020 gesagt hat über Kamala Harris.
Gut.
Das Lachen von Kamala Harris ist ja Thema bei Fox News.
Das 2020.
Seit vielen Jahren ist das großes Thema bei Fox News.
Immer wieder dieses Lachen. Es gibt Interviews, da hat Tucker Carlson eine Stimmenimitatorin
zu Gast, die lachen kann wie Kamala Harris. Es ist sehr absurd.
Nur, die Frage ist, wie antwortet man darauf?
Ich finde, dass das Team Kamala Harris gerade eine ganz gute Idee hat,
nämlich einfach zu sagen, die sind weird.
Das ist eine sehr, sehr gute Strategie. Dass man nämlich einfach sagt,
die sind seltsam, die sind ein bisschen komisch.
Das stimmt fast nicht mit denen. Das ist nämlich,
Etwas, womit man die einfach abräumen kann und dann geht man zu den eigenen
Themen über. Wenn Kamala Harris bereit ist, sie zu setzen.
Ich bin da noch unsicher. Also nur zu sagen, ich bin identitätspolitisch bestens
aufgestellt, wird nicht genügen.
Wir müssen auch noch uns daran erinnern, dass sie eigentlich als Vizepräsidentin
dazu da war, die rechteren Demokraten mit einzufangen.
Sie ist nicht die linke Progressive, wie das hier zum Teil dargestellt wird
und sie ist auch nicht in den schwarzen Communities unbedingt die Favoritin.
Denn ich kenne noch aus den vergangenen Jahren diese ganzen Memes von linken
Aktivisten. She is a cop.
Ja, also sie gehört zur Polizei. Aber Trump hat gesagt.
Sie wollte doch die Police defanten.
Okay, ja. Aber wir müssen also hier schon sehen, sie ist jetzt nicht die große Progressive.
Wahrscheinlich waren beiden der Progressivere. Wahrscheinlich werden wir,
trotz all der Geprächtigkeit, die wir thematisiert haben, noch in Situationen
kommen, in denen wir sagen, schade, dass Biden nicht mehr da ist.
Ist durchaus möglich.
Wie antwortet man nun jetzt aber auf solche komischen Angriffe da?
Man kann sagen, das ist weird und damit wäre es eigentlich gut.
Wie man nicht darauf antworten sollte, macht jetzt ein Tagesthemen-Kommentar
von Katrin Brandt vor vom WDR.
Wir spielen es einfach mal ab.
Wenn Kamala Harris lacht, dann verzieht sie nicht nur den Mund,
sie röhrt, sie gluckst, sie lässt das Lachen aus dem Bauch aufsteigen bis zu
ihren Augen. Sie lässt ihr ganzes Gesicht strahlen und ihren Körper beben.
Ich finde das ansteckend, die Republikaner nicht.
Sie zeigen in ihren Werbespots Bilder der lachenden Vizepräsidentin und machen
Harris als wierende, linksextremistische Irre lächerlich.
So ist das im US-Wahlkampf. Er ist hässlich und persönlich. Man braucht ein
dickes Fell und die volle Rückendeckung der eigenen Leute.
Kamala Harris wird gerade von einer großen Welle der Euphorie emporgehoben.
Eine schwarze Frau als Präsidentin, das hätte es noch nie gegeben.
Und dann noch eine frühere Staatsanwältin, die einen verurteilten Straftäter
an der Wahlurne besiegen könnte.
Was für eine großartige Geschichte.
Aber reicht das wirklich? Ist sie nicht 2020 kläglich bei den Vorwahlen gescheitert?
Müsst ihr den komplett hören?
Gibt es nicht diese ungelenken, peinlichen Momente in ihren Interviews?
Sollten die Demokraten nicht jetzt ganz offen und demokratisch nach einem wirklich
guten Kandidaten oder Kandidatin suchen?
Alles richtig, wenn es Januar wäre. Aber es ist Juli, die Zeit ist viel zu kurz,
um jemand anderen zu finden, auszuprobieren und aufzubauen.
Um Kamala Harris führt kein Weg herum.
Sie hat dreieinhalb Jahre an der Seite des Präsidenten ihre Erfahrungen gemacht.
Sie kann es, sie wird es können, sie wird es können müssen.
Und ich freue mich schon darauf, wie Harris, wenn sie denn die Kandidatin wird,
in ihrer ersten Fernsehdebatte den wütenden, düsteren, quengelnden Donald Trump
einfach an die Wand lacht.
Für mich ist das ebenso weird, wie das, was Donald Trump so von sich gibt.
Allerdings.
Wenn man sich auf dieses Niveau einlässt, wir reden jetzt mal alle über das
Lachen und wie befreiend das Lachen sein kann und das Lachen hat auch eine emanzipatorische
Kraft und so weiter, dann ist das einfach ein Nonsens-Diskurs.
Bitte Inhalte.
Also in der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung, haben wir alle mitgekriegt,
gibt es eine Autorin, Birgit Schmid, Kamala Harris lachen irritiert,
das hat auch nicht nur damit zu tun, dass sie eine Frau ist und so weiter.
Dieselbe Frau hatte neun Tage vorher auch in der Neuen Zürcher geschrieben,
Georgia Meloni fällt auf mit ihrer mimischen Ausdruckskraft,
sie gibt sich grimasierend volksnah.
Achso, das ist dann das Positive.
Also die Journalisten sind sich selber nicht ganz einig.
Gut, das ist jetzt die konservative Schlagzeile da aus der ZZ.
Also wenn man jetzt ein Tagesthemenkommentar gehört, der könnte in einer Woche auch und so weiter.
Also das ist ja, das sind ja diese, hier wird ja Strohfeuer begleitet.
Nun ist das ja die konservative Ansicht jetzt oder die rechte Ansicht,
dass man auch dieses Lachen problematisiert, das Kremassieren von Meloni großartig findet.
Und die Antwort kann aber nicht von links darauf sein, dass man jetzt über das
Lachen redet und sagt, ja das ist doch herrlich, dass wir eine lachende Präsidentin bekommen.
Also ich möchte auf dieses Niveau einfach nicht herunter.
Musst du auch nicht.
Ich biete dir einen Ausweg an. Moment, lass mich noch, bevor du hier,
ich hatte geahnt, dass du gehypt wirst.
Du weißt gar nicht, warum ich gehypt bin. Du denkst, ich bin Kamala Harris Fan.
Führe aus, dann führe ich aus. Okay.
Warum redet eigentlich unsere Außenministerin so viel Unsinn?
Sie wird auch gefragt zu Kamala Harris. Wir hören rein.
Und sie wird es nicht überraschen, dass mit Blick auf eine Welt,
in der vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel Testosteron manchmal herumfliegt,
starke Frauen vielleicht auch gewissen Situationen nicht schlecht tun, sondern eher gut tun.
Aber das Schöne an unseren Demokratien ist ja, auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Regierungsformen, dass die Entscheidung, sowohl wer nominiert wird von Parteien
als auch wer dann die nächsten Staats- und Regierungschefin werden,
in den Händen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger liegt.
Und wir haben selber erlebt in unserer direkten Nachbarschaft in Polen,
aber auch gerade wieder in Frankreich, dass das Zusammenarbeiten von Demokraten
in solchen Momenten essentiell ist.
Und das tun wir als starke europäische Demokratinnen und Demokraten.
Und dass vor allen Dingen die Wahlen oftmals erst in den letzten Momenten entschieden werden.
In diesem Sinne wird es sicher eine sehr, sehr spannende Zeit,
nicht nur für die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, sondern gerade auch für uns hier in Europa.
Erstes Argument Testosteron. Ich möchte es einfach nicht mehr hören.
Es ist nicht das Problem der Weltpolitik. Ich kann sagen, ja Putin ist Testosteron
getrieben, meinetwegen, was ist Georgia Meloni?
Das ist eine liebe gute Frau oder was, weil sie eine Frau ist.
Also ich verbitte mir wirklich diesen Diskurs.
Zweitens, kannst du dich erinnern, dass du schon mal einen Kandidaten für die
Bundestagswahl, für das Kanzleramt gewählt hast?
Äh, nein und wenn, hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass da irgendwann mal ein Testosteron
eine Rolle spielt, aber das sehe ich weder bei Olaf Scholz noch bei Friedrich
Menz noch bei Linnemann noch bei Robert Habeck.
Wo ist unser Hulk Hogan eigentlich, frage ich mich.
Nein, aber was redet sie denn dann, dass das Schöne an der Demokratie ist,
dass die Bürger das entscheiden?
Also hier Kamala Harris, ein Tweet von Adam Tooze.
Die amerikanische Vorstellung von der Präsidentschaft ist so monarchisch,
dass Biden als Herrscher gefeiert wird,
der zugunsten einer gesalbten Nachfolgerin die Macht abgibt und nicht als eitler
Politiker, der sein Verfallsdatum falsch eingeschätzt hat und sich erst spät
dazu überreden ließ, sich eine Demütigung zu ersparen und den Demokraten eine Chance zu geben.
Das heißt, das ist die Entscheidung eines Einzelnen und jetzt kommt hinzu,
dass sehr viele Geldgeber auf Kamala Harris angesprungen sind und sehr viele Spenden geben.
Das ist nicht die Entscheidung der Bürger.
Also dazu sagen, das ist ja so großartig, dass wir eine Demokratie sind,
das ist doch einfach Quatsch und das ist jetzt auch nicht ihr als Lapsus passiert.
Sie sagt es dann nochmal später im ZDF-Interview.
Ich glaube, in diesen Zeiten wäre es für das erste Mal eine Frau im Präsidentenamt
zu haben, ja auch ein großer, großer Beitrag mit Blick auf die Gleichstellungsfragen.
Also das wird sicherlich ein sehr spannender Wahlkampf. Aber wie gesagt,
bisher ist ja noch gar nichts entschieden.
Es zeigt aber ja, wie spannend Demokratie sein kann.
Ja, aber das ist ja gerade nicht Demokratie. Also ich kann natürlich sagen,
Biden wurde mal gewählt und insofern ist eine Biden-Entscheidung dann auch noch
irgendwo demokratisch abgesichert.
Ja, es ist definitiv nicht so wie in Putins Reich oder gar im Iran.
Aber das sind nun keine demokratischen Prozedere, die hier laufen.
Offen, die Frage ist auch, braucht man die?
Wäre das sinnvoll, wenn das demokratischer wäre?
Das kann man alles groß diskutieren, nur kann man nicht behaupten,
dass das jetzt gerade besonders demokratisch ist.
Es gibt ja auch die Überlegung, dass man doch noch da so eine Convention macht
und dann die Demokraten andere Kandidaten haben.
Und dann ist aber oft die Argumentation nicht, dass andere dann eine Chance
wirklich hätten gegen Kamala Harris, nur dass man ein bisschen simulative Demokratie
eigentlich da präsentiert.
Aber du darfst jetzt gehypt sein. Gut.
Zum einen, zu dem letzten Punkt, wir werden diesen Text lesen von Ezra Klein,
der das vorgeschlagen hat.
Der hat ja, bevor Biden zurück trat, lange mit der Unterscheidung gespielt,
macht man eine Krönung oder eine Competition.
Also ist ja dann noch eine Frage der Zeit, wie viel Zeit hat man denn noch?
Und jetzt hat er ja eine Synthese daraus vorgeschlagen und hat gesagt,
wir machen eine Exhibition.
Wir stellen, nachdem alles immer nur Biden, Biden, Biden, Biden,
Biden hieß und Biden alt, nicht zu gebrauchen und es spricht auch niemand für
ihn. Ehrlich gesagt, man hat ja niemanden gesehen.
Sagt man, okay, wir machen nicht eine Vorwahl im Sinne von Vorwahl.
Es geht ja auch nicht nur um das Amt des Präsidenten.
Trump kommt und sagt, wir wollen 50.000 Stellen auswechseln.
Man kann da ruhig auch mal eine Exhibition machen, eine Ausstellung mit Personal, das man so hat.
Und ich glaube, sehr viele Leute sehen jetzt gerade Pete Budicic so durch die
Talkshows inklusive Fox News tingeln und es macht einfach Spaß zu gucken,
weil man da auch einfach jetzt wieder Leute sieht, die in unserem Alter ungefähr
sich mit Fox News Hosts anlegen und dort wirklich intellektuelle Hochleistungsarbeit betreiben.
Also das ist eigentlich die Olympiade, die ich mir so anschaue,
wie sich Pete Budicic in diesen ganzen Dingern da schlägt.
Und zu diesem, ja, Annalena Baerbock sagt immer, was sie sagt.
Ich würde sagen, das kann man ja heute wirklich mal alles verkürzen und damit
gehe ich auch den Schritt, den ich gehen will.
Denn ihre Chefin, Ricarda Lang, hat ein Video gepostet.
Vielleicht hast du es gesehen. Ich zeige es dir aber hier auf dem Handy.
Ich beschreibe, was man sieht, aber dir zeige ich es natürlich direkt.
Riccarda Lang war bei Taylor Swift und ich weiß nicht genau,
es gibt jetzt sieben Trillionen Videos von wie man sich bei einem Taylor Swift Konzert filmt.
Man hält das Handy eigentlich neben sich, filmt sich dann seitlich,
zeigt aber auch sozusagen Menschen und die Bühne und sowas.
Ricarda Lange hat sich entschieden, so das Handy direkt vor sich und dann sinkt
sie Fakte Patriarchie in das Ding rein.
Ja, aber das könnte auch auf der Kirmes in Koblenz sein.
Genau, dieser kleine Ausschnitt, ja genau, hinter ihr sind einfach halt Leute,
man sieht jetzt überhaupt keinen Bezug, wo sie ist und so weiter.
Also, Also, man kann das alles noch viel blöder machen, als sie das schon gemacht
hat. Und jetzt würde ich aber sagen, warum ich gehypt bin.
Als großer Verfechter guter Soziologie haben wir doch jetzt festgestellt,
in der Politik geht es um Macht.
Macht haben, Macht nicht haben. Es zählt nichts anderes.
Es zählt nicht, ich sehe mich aber als links an, ich sehe mich aber als vernünftig
an, Ich sehe mich aber als ordentlich trainierter Sprecher an.
Ich rede nur Blödsinn oder alles egal. Es ist alles zweitrangig.
Entscheidend ist, Macht nicht Macht. Und die Welt und vor allem ich habe jetzt
acht Jahre darunter gelitten, dass Trump das verstanden hat und die anderen nicht.
Trump hat eine Macht errungen. Er war Präsident.
Nicht mit, ich bin der bessere Kandidat, ich rede besser, ich rede klug oder was auch immer.
Sondern die Leute wollen Action, die Leute kriegen Action.
Jetzt hat Joe Biden gesagt, ich bin es nicht, ich trete von meinem Amt zurück,
da würde ich Adam Tooze auch widersprechen.
Ja, es ist halt so ein monarchisches Verfahren, wo es einfach nur darauf ankommt,
ist er jetzt bereit, diese Entscheidung zu treffen, ja oder nein.
Man kann ihn nicht drängen, man kann gar nichts.
Man kann ihm sagen, ey, du hast aber gar kein Spendengeld mehr, ja und, ist doch egal.
Du hast gar keinen Unterstützer mehr, ist doch egal. Niemand spricht für dich
und du auch nicht, ja ist doch egal. So, ihm kann das alles egal sein.
Trotzdem hat er diese Entscheidung getroffen, ich bin es nicht.
So. Und ab dann, sagen wir mal so, ab eine Stunde danach, als dann schon 40
Minuten klar war, Kamala Harris ruft er aus und die anderen haben keinen Wettkampfapparat,
der da irgendwie dagegen halten kann,
hat sich irgendwie die progressive,
eingeschüchterte, junge, weibliche, urbane Schicht in Amerika gedacht,
scheiß drauf, wir gehen jetzt hier all in.
Wir shitposten den Scheiß. Wir machen jeden Tag 100 Videos, in denen wir die
letzten Auftritte von Trump einfach nehmen, uns darüber lustig machen.
Hatte J.D. Vance Sex mit einem Sofa? Ist die wichtigste Frage der Welt gewesen.
Und so. Und ich denke mir, jawohl, genau so geht's.
Ich behörte auf mit diesen Was ist in den Nachrichten? Was sagt Annalena Baerbock?
Ist mir alles egal. Ich will einfach nur aufstehen morgens und dann kriege ich
nicht einfach nur John Stewart oder zwei andere Comedians, sondern tausende Videos,
in denen ich mich darin suhlen kann, dass Trump ein Idiot ist und man sich jetzt
auch endlich traut, es auf diesem Niveau, auf dem es gesagt werden muss, es zu sagen.
Und das findet gerade statt und das finde ich großartig.
Man macht das aber tatsächlich dann mit Humor und nicht in so einer Kirchentagspredigt.
Die aus den Tagesthemen... Es gibt so viel Shit-Talking gerade auf YouTube,
es ist wirklich eine Freude.
Nur werden wir irgendwann wann auch über Inhalte reden müssen und da, warum?
Trump hat auch nicht irgendwann mal über Inhalte reden müssen,
um den amerikanischen Präsidenten zu gewinnen.
Nein, wenn man jetzt aus der kritischen Perspektive heraus Kandidaten beurteilen will.
Also für mich macht das ja erstmal keinen Unterschied, ob die dann Hype im Internet
produzieren. Ja, aber wer braucht denn jetzt noch Inhalte?
Naja, die Frage ist ja schon interessant und die können sich deutsche Journalisten
ja mitunter mal stellen.
Welche Wirtschaftspolitik will eigentlich eine Kamala Harris?
Welche Geopolitik will eine Kamala Harris?
Wenn man aber in den Tagesthemen hört, dass sie so herrlich lacht,
dann kann, die Tagesthemen sind ja nicht TikTok,
also dass jetzt da irgendwelche 22-Jährigen großen Spaß daran haben,
diese Videos zu produzieren und dass das einen Effekt auf die Wahl haben wird
und dass das möglicherweise ihr den Weg ins Amt bereitet, alles gut und schön,
nur muss ja die journalistische Auseinandersetzung eine andere sein.
Und da sehe ich in Deutschland schwarz, ich habe jetzt in den vergangenen Tagen,
als dann bekannt wurde, Kamala Harris wird es wohl werden,
eigentlich ein reines Déjà-vu-Erlebnis, nämlich man hat nochmal den Hillary
Clinton-Kram neu aufgerührt.
Also das ist ja eigentlich jetzt, wir haben Hillary Clinton nicht bekommen,
jetzt bekommen wir Kamala.
Die meisten deutschen Journalisten verlieben sich blind und mit blind meine
ich ja auch, dass sie bis vor drei Wochen oder bis vor vier Wochen nicht bereit waren zu erkennen,
dass Biden sehr geprächtlich ist.
Die haben ja noch bis vor kurzem in Interviews gesagt, der ist sharp as a knife, der ist super drauf.
Also das werden wir nachher, also zum einen nachher und dann aber auch anders diskutieren,
denn was deutsche Journalisten inhaltlich in diesem Medium Fernsehen dazu sagen,
können wir aber jetzt ignorieren.
Das gibt es noch, wir haben eine gewisse Pfadabhängigkeit, 70-Jährige sitzen
vorm Fernseher und wollen wissen, was passiert so grob in der Welt,
für die wird das gemacht.
Wir wissen auch noch, unsere Eltern haben ja auch noch Fernsehen gesehen oder
unsere Großeltern, aber es wird….
Ich kenne dein Argument, nur diese Fernsehanstalten sind ja im Internet sehr stark vertreten.
Das heißt, was dort so gesagt wird, doch, doch, doch, was da schon so gesagt
wird in den Talkshows, findet auch bei TikTok, findet bei Twitter überall dort statt.
Bei YouTube wird es sehr viel sich angesehen. Das heißt, es hat schon einen
Ausschlag, was in diesen Talkshows verhandelt wird und wie diese Nachrichtensendungen
aufgebaut sind und wenn sie vor allem sich mit dem Lachen der Kamala Harris auseinandersetzen,
dann hat das einen allgemeinen Verblödungseffekt.
Also die Tagesschau 20 Uhr vom 30.07. gestern, 13 Stunden alt,
bei YouTube hat 118.000 Views und ich kann dir 100 Kanäle nennen,
die gerade die amerikanische Wahlkampf-Sachen thematisieren,
die innerhalb von 13 Stunden entweder 10 Mal oder 15 Mal so viele Views haben.
Es spielt wirklich keine Rolle mehr, was die Tagesschau dazu macht,
auch nicht in der 20 Uhr und man muss eben dazu sagen, die Leute,
die die Tagesschau gucken sind zum Teil Redakteure in irgendwelchen Redaktionen
und nehmen diese Themen mit.
Ansonsten sind das aber Leute, die wissen nicht mal, was Social Media ist.
Also die verbreiten da nichts.
Dass wir hier so ein Clip aus der Tagesschau gesehen haben, ist schon,
wir sind schon eine Orchidee in dieser Medienlandschaft, dass wir nochmal ein
Tagesschau-Kommentar hören.
In der Hinsicht, ich bin sehr gehypt. Endlich läuft dieser Wahlkampf auch auf
der progressiven Seite dort, wo er laufen muss.
Und damit meine ich nicht nur eine Verortung regional, sondern auch eine Verortung intellektuell.
Niemand wird gequält mit irgendwelchen Inhalten.
Wir haben uns sehr, also wie oft haben wir uns darüber beschwert,
lustig gemacht, das intellektuell durchdrungen in Salonbüchern und so weiter
besprochen, dass es absolut absurd ist, zu sagen, das Schicksal der Welt hängt davon ab.
Erstens, Von einer Person.
Zweitens, von der Tagesform am 5. November, ist doch egal.
In Deutschland werden doch auch Koalitionsverträge geschrieben und dann heißt
es schon drei Wochen später, ja, dass jetzt Putin in der Ukraine einmarschiert,
da konnten wir ja nichts für, wir mussten jetzt erstmal eine Grundgesetzänderung
machen, 100 Milliarden hier, 200 Milliarden da und so, ist doch eh alles egal.
In der Hinsicht, dieses amerikanische Wahlmodell, was wir da haben, ist absurd.
Es ist viel zu sehr auf Personen zugeschnitzt, es ist viel zu sehr auf Wahlzeitpunkte zugeschnitten.
Es ist monarchisch, wie Tussauds.
Es ist noch viel monarchischer, als wir dachten. Bloomberg hat gesagt,
ja, es ist ein Königreich.
Wir haben jetzt Königtümer wieder neu gegründet. Es ist völlig absurd.
Und das, was wir jetzt inhaltlich an Wahlkampf die letzten zehn Tage erlebt
haben, ist auf Augenhöhe mit dieser Absurdität und hat dadurch endlich die Chance,
Donald Trump da aus dem Spiel zu nehmen.
Ich bin nicht mehr so überzeugt, dass Donald Trump diese Wahl gewinnt wie vorher,
denn wir haben auch gesehen, Donald Trump ist wirklich der Einzige,
der diese mediale Ansprache, die dieses Publikum braucht, beherrscht.
Alle anderen scheitern auf ganzer Linie. Dass selbst sein Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat,
So versagt ist, also das hat historische Ausmaße, diese Art von Fail, die da stattfindet.
Das heißt, du schlägst vor und dem kann ich mich ja eigentlich nur anschließen.
Wir beobachten das jetzt auf der reinen Performance-Ebene und sagen,
die Demokraten haben nun die Chance, auch gut zu performen, eine tolle Show
zu liefern. von Beyoncé hat schon ihren Freedom Song freigegeben.
In diese Richtung geht es. Und wir sehen jetzt auch die Performance von Trump.
Allein, dass es eine jüngere Gegenkandidatin gibt, wirkt älter.
59, eine jüngere Gegenkandidatin.
Ja, aber er wirkt ja direkt jetzt zehn Jahre älter, dadurch,
dass Biden nicht mehr daneben steht. Das ist ja immer in Relation.
Ja, Trump will ja auch schon dafür entschädigt werden, dass er hinters Licht geführt wurde.
Er hat ja Investitionen in den Wahlkampf auf Thema Alter gemacht. macht.
Und jetzt ist aber das Alter nicht mehr das maßgebliche Thema,
also hätte er gerne ein Reimbursement.
So absurd ist es ja. Und auf der Ebene will ich das auch behandelt haben.
Über Inhalte, so traurig es ist, können wir wirklich erst nach dem 5. November.
Jetzt ist Wahlkampf, danach ist Politik. Beim Wahlkampf möchte ich,
dass alles getan wird, um die Macht zu erringen.
So dumm wie es geht. Und wenn das amerikanische Publikum dumm ist,
dann muss der Wahlkampf auch dumm sein.
Aber es ist unterhaltsam. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig unterhaltsam.
Jeder hat gespürt, wir in Europa natürlich insbesondere, wie erlösend es war,
nicht mehr Joe Biden ausgeliefert zu sein.
Und das alleine ist schon ein kleiner Hype-Moment, den kann auch jeder emotional
für sich einfach mal ausleben, statt ihn gleich wieder akademisch,
intellektuell durchdringen zu wollen und so weiter. Alter, dieser Wahlkampf.
Ich habe noch andere Freuden im Leben, außer amerikanische Präsidentschaft.
Aber trotzdem war es doch ein sehr drückendes Gefühl zu wissen,
da ist irgendwie ein 81-Jähriger, der es echt nicht mehr auf die Kette kriegt,
aber wir sind ihm ausgeliefert.
Ja.
Und das ist jetzt anders.
Es hält sich bei mir im Grenzen. Man weiß ich nicht, ich denke nicht so viel
darüber nach, wie die in Washington so gerade drauf sind.
Beziehungsweise, wenn es um große Geopolitik geht, ja, aber ob jetzt,
also ich verfolge den Wahlkampf ja nicht in dem Sinne, dass die Performance
mich besonders interessiert, ich gehe da lieber ins Konzert,
aber ich kann sehr nachvollziehen, was du da meinst, du hast aber jetzt gerade einen Satz gesagt,
nämlich, wenn die Wähler dumm sind, dann muss man einen dummen Wahlkampf machen
und das führt uns zu einem Dumm meine.
Ich übrigens nicht dumm im Sinne von dumm.
Sondern wenn die blöden Wahlkampf wollen, so muss man es eigentlich sagen,
dann machen wir blöden Wahlkampf.
Wenn sie unaufgeklärten Wahlkampf wollen, dann machen wir unaufgeklärten Wahlkampf
oder absurden Wahlkampf.
Also lass mich da wirklich kurz sagen, ich finde das wahnsinnig aufgeklärt.
Und man muss es aber nicht sozusagen akademisch durchdringen,
sondern man kann es einfach fühlen, es bringt jetzt nichts, eine Debatte über
irgendwas zu führen, sondern wenn Trump auf der Bühne steht, muss man das spiegeln.
Man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie erwarten, dass Obama das Supreme Court Urteil
in einer staatsrechtlichen Vorlesung eine Stunde lang durchdringt und die Leute
dann überzeugt sind, ach so, ja nee, dann müssen wir jetzt so und so wählen.
Sondern nein, das muss jetzt go with the flow, das muss jetzt richtig ausgelebt werden.
Ja, ich befürchte nur, dass man schon eine gewisse Vision braucht.
Also Trump hat Make America Great Again, da steckt etwas Retrotopisches drin,
aber auch wiederum, was in die Zukunft gewandt ist, also die Zukunft wird besser.
Wenn Kamala Harris nur anzubieten hat, we are not going back,
dann ist das auch zugleich eine Bestätigung des Status Quo, mit dem sehr viele
Amerikaner nicht einverstanden sind, weshalb man sich da nochmal was einfallen lassen muss.
Aber du hast es da schon angesprochen, ja wie ticken denn die Wähler.
Wie sind sie drauf?
Man könnte ja auch sagen, warum wählen denn eigentlich die Kinder nicht?
Und damit kommen wir jetzt gleich zu unserem Kinderfamilienwahlrecht.
Vielleicht lass uns aber erst ganz kurz ein paar Ankündigungen machen bezüglich des Salons.
Wir haben den Sommersalon am 24.
August. Er ist so gut wie ausverkauft. Ich glaube, es sind noch 24 Karten da.
95,5% ausverkauft. Es gibt noch 36 Karten. Man kann also noch kommen.
Okay.
Und wir müssen schon mal dazu sagen, wenn ihr dann am 23.
Feststellt, ich habe Husten, ich bin doch verreist oder wie auch immer,
schickt nicht uns die Nachricht.
Wir können gar nichts machen, sondern ihr müsst es twittern oder bei Instagram.
Wir können es dann teilen, aber diese Art von, ich habe noch ein Ticket,
also Wolfgang und ich haben schon ein Ticket für diese Veranstaltung.
Wir brauchen dann keins.
Wir können auch, wir haben keinen Zugriff auf den Server, können nicht einen Platz freimachen.
Wir kriegen da immer wieder die Mail an uns, nein, ihr müsst es selber twittern,
uns dann erwähnen, wie auch immer, wir können es dann teilen.
Mehr als das einfach resharen können wir nicht.
Und wir werden natürlich das auch aufzeichnen und dann ist das für alle hörbar.
Im Salon, genau.
Und zwar im Salon. Im nächsten Salon sprechen wir ja über ein Buch,
das den interessanten Titel trägt, Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere
Moderne von Ingolfur Blüthorn.
Da geht es um die Frage, ob das ökologisch-emanzipatorische Projekt an sein
Ende kommt oder gescheitert ist.
Warum ist es gescheitert? Hat es sich vielleicht selbst unterminiert?
Mit anderen Worten, ist vielleicht diese liberale Demokratie gar nicht mehr
die Antwort auf unsere Fragen.
Es ist ein Buch, über das wir dann trefflich streiten können, nehme ich an.
Meine Augen, meine Links sind bereit.
Andere Texte haben, ja, ja, ja. Wir müssen nur sagen, dass sich beim Salon ein
bisschen was ändert und zwar für alle, die jetzt im Salon schon sind, ändert sich gar nichts,
für die läuft alles genau weiter, aber Steady hat uns freundlichst gebeten,
eine Preiserhöhung zu machen.
Wir wollten das aber nicht für unsere schon Bestandskunden machen,
für die, die uns schon so lange die Treue halten, sondern für die,
die neu kommen, werden wir den Preis anheben, aber nicht jetzt sofort,
sondern am 24.
August. Bis dahin hat man Zeit, kann also sich jetzt noch die günstigen Pakete
sichern und du sagst noch gerade was zur Preisstruktur.
Ja, ich will auch nochmal was sagen zum Preis. Also der Preis ist 2,50 Euro
bislang und noch bis 24. August.
Danach springt der Mindestpreis, also pro Monat in der jährlichen Abrechnung, auf 3 Euro pro Monat.
Und nicht nur haben wir erfragt, ob wir das dürfen, sondern es wurde uns angeboten,
wir dürfen sagen, Steady ist schuld.
Wir wollten das nicht, Steady ist schuld.
Finde ich auch ein bisschen witzig, dass das gleich in der ersten Mail drin
stand, aber wir haben uns jetzt zwei Jahre oder so dagegen gewehrt.
Man kann auch derzeit, wenn man bei Steady ein neues Projekt eröffnet,
nicht unter drei Euro pro Monat anfangen.
Das heißt, wir waren noch eins der ganz wenigen, vielleicht das einzige Projekt,
das für 2,50 Euro im Monat zu haben war, aber wir gehen jetzt auch den drei Euro Schritt mit.
In den Salon kommt man, wie wir es immer betonen, über die Webseite die neue20er.de
oder man googelt einfach neue20er Salon oder mein Lieblingspodcast Salon,
da kommt man auch raus, wahrscheinlich,
dort ist ein goldener Button, dem kann man dann folgen, wir haben erstaunlich
wenig, es ist wirklich erfreulich, technische Probleme bei Hörern,
wenn klärt Steady.de sofort,
also man kann einfach auf den Button klicken und sich ein Paket buchen oder
zu Apple gehen, diese Preise werden allerdings auch erhöht.
Und bei Patreon auch. Also wir sind auf diesen drei Kanälen,
stellen wir zur Verfügung. Wir präferieren aber Steady.
Und da kostet es jetzt bei Steady dann, wenn man das Jahresabo abschließt, 3 Euro im Monat.
Also 36 Euro im Jahr.
36 Euro.
Ab 24. August.
Bei Apple dann ein bisschen mehr. Also wer jetzt sich noch schnell ein Paket
sichert, der hat also noch den günstigen Tarif und wird den dann auch über diese
Preiserhöhung hinaus haben.
Für alle, die sowieso schon Abo haben, ändert sich wie gesagt gar nichts.
Und vielleicht auch nochmal hier der Hinweis, wir freuen uns sehr,
wenn ihr den Podcast teilt, weiterempfehlt. Es ist gerade Sommerpause,
viele Podcaster sind im Urlaub, wir nicht.
Wir arbeiten durch sozusagen und würden uns sehr freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast
ein bisschen teilt oder auch gut bewertet auf den entsprechenden Plattformen.
Das hilft uns sehr, dass der Podcast sichtbar ist und uns hilft natürlich auch,
wenn ihr uns über Steady, Patreon oder Apple unterstützt und dann Zusatzinhalte
genießt, die doch sehr reichhaltig inzwischen sind, denn wir machen das ja seit Januar 2020.
Das heißt, da sind sehr, sehr viele Salonfolgen, sehr viele Buchempfehlungen,
sehr viele Diskussionen, die man noch nachhören kann.
Zum Beispiel, wir lesen im nächsten Salon einen Text über J.D.
Vance natürlich, den von Ezra Klein angekündigten.
Oder auch einen älteren über J.D. Vance, also verschiedene Sachen.
Und dabei fiel mir wieder auf, wie toll unser Salon ist. Denn im Januar 2021
haben wir von Jeffkin das Buch über Peter Thiel besprochen.
In dem stecken gigantische Pointen zu J.D. Vance drin.
Wir werden sie im nächsten Salon nochmal rausholen. Ja, das ist wirklich grandios,
dass wir, bevor das alles losging,
im, glaube ich, zweiten Monat des Erscheins des Buches, es gleich bei uns besprochen
haben, also wer ein Salonhörer ist und das ist jetzt eins von ungefähr 80,
90 Büchern oder so, die wir insgesamt im Salon besprochen haben,
da ist man wirklich ganz vorne dran.
Das müssen wir auch nochmal wirklich empfehlen, diese Biografie über Peter Thiel,
über die wir sehr ausführlich gesprochen haben, kann man wie gesagt nachhören,
weil man dann nochmal sehr genau versteht, wie jetzt so eine neue Generation
bei den Republikanern das wahrscheinlich so sehr an sich reißen wird,
dass das also die Zukunft sein wird eines großen Teils von Amerika.
Also die Sache ist jetzt auch, Trump kann verhindert werden durch Kamala Harris.
Ich bin da auch vorsichtig optimistisch.
Danach aber werden ja die Karten wieder neu gemischt.
Ja, es ist auch nur, wir reden hier wirklich nur über das Präsidentenamt.
Also es gibt noch ganz viele andere Posten.
Und wir sehen, welche Auffassungen dort vertreten werden.
Wir sehen auch gerade, wie Trump die Bitcoin-Bros umarmt.
Man kann also darüber sehr viel
lernen, wenn man sich mit dieser Peter Thiel-Biografie auseinandersetzt.
Ja, also zeigt mal wieder, lesen hilft. Und wir lesen.
Eine Sache möchte ich hier noch ankündigen. Es gibt eine neue Subscribe von 18.
Bis 20. Oktober in Berlin. Subscribe ist unsere, aus der Community geborene,
von Tim Brittlaff getragene, vor allem auch, was diese ganze Technik,
über die auch unser Podcast hier läuft.
Da war natürlich jetzt Corona-Pause. Die letzte hatten wir ja 2019 beim Deutschlandfunk in Köln organisiert.
Diesmal gibt es sie in Berlin. Und es sind sehr viele, sehr krasse Projekte damals entstanden.
Joscha zum Beispiel ist da reingekommen in das ganze Podcast-Game und produziert
jetzt ein prämiertes Ding nach dem anderen.
Danny ist Civic-Preisträger. Das ist auch ein Podcast, der aus der Subscribe geboren wurde.
Oder er hat Podcasts, die aus der Subscribe geboren wurden und macht damit Alex
diesen Ost-Podcast und so weiter.
Also sehr cooles Zeug. Ich nehme an, das wird wieder historisch.
Meldet euch an im Oktober.
Und wir haben eine Mail bekommen, lieber Stefan, lieber Wolfgang. Es scheint...
Große Schwierigkeiten zu geben bezüglich der Aussprache des Namens,
und ich sage jetzt Rutger Bregmann.
Ich bin Niederländerin, wohne seit über zehn Jahren in Deutschland.
Seit vielen Folgen wird der oben genannte Name, also Rutger Bregmann,
ihr hört den zum letzten Mal falsch, auf verschiedene Weise falsch ausgesprochen.
Deshalb einmal hier die Aussprache für euch und ich habe die direkt auf meine
Aussprache-Datenbank gelegt.
Also, liebe Maylin, sofern ich diesen Namen jetzt richtig ausgesprochen habe,
M-Y-L-E mit Apostroph N-E, also Maylin wahrscheinlich, sie sagt,
der Name wird so ausgesprochen, wir hören das jetzt und stellen dann fest,
niemand kann das so aussprechen.
Rüttger Brechmann.
Ja, ich will es gar nicht versuchen, aber du hast es immer da.
Ich hab das immer.
Rüttger Brechmann.
Wir sagen jetzt immer, wisst ihr noch, die große Frage, die gestellt wurde,
wir werden auch nachher drauf zu sprechen kommen. Rüttger Brechmann hatte doch
gesagt, mit den Politikern stimmt irgendwas nicht im Kopf.
Jetzt haben wir ja dankenswerterweise den ersten Eintrag in unserer Aussprache Datenbank.
Soviel zum Housekeeping, kommen wir zu einem lebensbedrohlichen Thema für mich.
Hast du diesen Clip dabei? Ich habe ihn dir auch nochmal extra ausgenommen.
Nicht nur du, sondern ungefähr auch 75 Hörer.
Und zwar muss man sagen, gibt es JD Vance der möglicherweise der nächste Vizepräsident
werden könnte, wenn Trump gewinnt.
Und J.D. Vance denkt eigentlich ganz genauso wie unser Stefan.
No. Also ich werde gleich dagegen anargumentieren, warum ich auch der Meinung
bin, es braucht ein Wahlrecht für Kinder.
Aber nicht so wie J.D. Vance. Soll ich anfangen oder willst du anfangen?
Willst du erstmal den Clip von J.D. Vance spielen, damit alle aufstand sind?
Ja, ich würde ihn ansonsten nämlich direkt einbetten in meine Argumentation,
denn ich bekomme ja auch eine Mail. Also, okay.
Dann lass mich nur mit einem Satz anfangen, um nicht missverstanden zu werden.
Ich mache mir keine Illusionen über unsere Demokratie und über unsere Regierung.
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen sehr viele Interviews gesehen mit Christian Lindner
und Carsten Linnemann und gehe so weit zu sagen,
ich würde lieber von Siebenjährigen regiert werden.
Ja, siehste, Punkt.
Da geht es schon gar nicht mehr ums Wählen, sondern ich würde sagen,
wegen mir können die auch regieren. Aber jetzt fang mal an.
Kinder an die Macht. Herbert Grönemeyer hat schon immer recht gehabt.
Nun ja.
Okay.
Also, ernstes Thema, denn dieses Thema wurde, das muss man wirklich sagen,
nicht nur torpediert, sondern da ist so eine Atombombe draufgefallen,
weshalb ich zum Beispiel auch, also wir beide eine Mail bekommen haben von Johannes,
ich habe ja auf einige schon reagiert, ich lese sie mal vor.
In puncto Stimmrecht pro Kind deckt sich Stefans Position mit der von J.D. Vance.
Gehören wir eigentlich mit zu den Shit-Talkern, die jetzt immer Shady Vance
sagen? Oder lassen wir es J.D.?
Ich möchte J.D. sagen.
J.D. Vance, okay. Dem Running Mate von Donald Trump, der Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat,
und jetzt wird es schon ein bisschen toxisch in der E-Mail, Klammer auf,
oder laut Stefan, zukünftige Vizepräsident, Klammer zu,
vertritt schon länger dieses Wahlrecht, dass dieser Vorschlag aus dem rechtskonservativen
Lager kommt, ist kein Zufall. Ich kann da nur ergänzen die Pointen.
Ja, der größte Verfechter in Deutschland ist Jens Spahn.
Richtig.
So, jetzt machen wir es so.
Wir hören nicht J.D. Vance im Wortlaut, sondern wir hören nachgesprochen das
Originalzitat, weil wir wollen ja jetzt uns auf Inhalte konzentrieren,
aber die Szenerie, ihr habt sie bestimmt alle gesehen, J.D.
Vance steht irgendwann vor drei Jahren so in einer Konferenz am Rednerpult und
so ganz locker und lakonisch, warum eigentlich nicht?
Aber dieses Video ist so ein bisschen verkürzt. Ich habe jedenfalls als keine
vollständige Version gefunden,
denn das Zitat ist in seiner dramatischen Schärfe noch etwas länger,
weshalb wir hier von India Today eine Vor-, also es wird uns vorgelesen,
dieses Zitat, wo dann auch, finde ich, alles drinsteckt.
Vance proposed that people with children be given more voting rights than non-parents.
The video is from Vances address to an organization called Intercollegiate Studies
Institute, in which he said people with no children have no investment in the future of America,
J.D. Vance sagte laut und cheers let's
give votes to all children in this country but let's give
control over those votes to the parents of those children when you
go to the polls in this country as a parent you should have more power you should
have more of an ability to speak your voice in our democratic republic than
people who don't have kids let's face the consequences and the reality if you
don't have as much of an investment in the future of this country maybe you
shouldn't get nearly the same voice,
Doesn't this mean that non-parents don't have as much of a voice as parents?
Doesn't this mean that parents get a bigger say in our democracy functions? Yes, absolutely.
So, wir hören ja schon, es geht ja nicht um Kinder, sondern die Parents.
Parents, Parents, Parents. Oder Erwachsene, die keine Parents sind.
Zwischen Kinderwahlrecht und Familienwahlrecht.
Genau.
Du hast dich ja ausgesprochen damals für ein Familienwahlrecht,
deine Argumentation war ja, wenn jemand sehr alt ist, gebrechlich ist, dann wählt der Pfleger.
Für denjenigen, so hast du es ein bisschen zugeschüttet, so darf es natürlich
nicht sein, sondern natürlich kann man jemanden technisch unterstützen.
Es ist ja zum Beispiel auch sehr stark liberalisiert worden und ich unterstreiche,
ich bin sehr dafür, dass Menschen auch mit geistiger Behinderung in Deutschland wählen dürfen,
weil sie volljährig sind, allerdings müssen sie selbst ihren Wählerwillen kundtun.
Das heißt, man kann nicht sagen, ach ja, das mache ich jetzt aber mal für die.
Also das geht nicht. Also das ist Betrug. Das mag irgendwo vorkommen,
das ist aber nicht richtig, dass es das gibt.
Und Familienwahlrecht würde tatsächlich ja bedeuten, dass man sagt,
der Vater oder die Mutter, ist dann auch die Frage, wie ist das in Patchwork-Familien
so, die wählen für ihre Kinder.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass sie nur den Auftrag der Kinder, die Kinder geben
den Auftrag, sondern die haben einfach eine Stimme mehr, um es ganz deutlich zu sagen.
Und man versteht auch ein bisschen, warum konservative Rechte sehr dafür sind,
weil ich sagen würde, dass man, glaube ich, damit sehr gut konservative Politik machen kann.
Aber das ist ja noch eine strategische Sache, aber das ist ja erstmal die Unterscheidung
Kinderwahlrecht und Familienwahlrecht.
Genau, also ich habe ja von Claude eine Auswertung machen lassen,
so vor ein paar Tagen schon, da sind jetzt die letzten Mails dann nicht dabei,
aber ich habe das ja auch mal geschickt, wo so zusammenfassend 30 Mails in die
Richtung, 30 Mails in die Richtung oder so kreuz und quer.
Ich möchte hier sagen, das wandert alles nochmal analytisch natürlich auch in mein Buch rein.
Nur es ist halt alles wahnsinnig viel komplizierter, denn Kinder eine Stimme
geben und man ist sofort bei der Frage, also machen das dann die Erwachsenen?
Und was ist mit Erwachsenen, die keine Kinder haben?
Haben die dann weniger Stimmrecht als die Erwachsenen mit Kindern?
Und was ist eigentlich mit Familie?
Ist ja nochmal ein anderer Begriff. Also der meint ja nochmal was anderes als
einfach nur Vater, Mutter, Kind oder Vater, Mutter ohne Kind.
Nee, das sind ja dann nicht Vater, Mutter, aber es ist trotzdem eine Familie
und so weiter und so fort.
Also mein Plädoyer wird ja dafür sein, wir brauchen ihn wirklich gänzlich und
ich meine jetzt wirklich, auch wenn du gerade hier zuhörst und denkst,
ich habe schon einen modernen Familienbegriff.
Nein, ich werde einen noch weitergehenden,
wir müssen das wirklich zertrümmern, was ist Familie und so.
Okay, aber bleiben wir mal bei der Wahl. Was heißt das?
Johannes hat jetzt hier in der Mail weitergeschrieben, ein Wahlrecht,
das Eltern für ihre Kinder mit Stimmen betraut, schwächt die emanzipierte Frau
und erhöht das Stimmgewicht für traditionelle Familien, was höchstwahrscheinlich
zu einem weiteren Rechtsruck führen würde.
Natürlich unterstelle ich Familien mit mehr Kindern nicht generell diese politische
Gesinnung, aber in Anbetracht, wie knapp Wahlen bislang ausfallen,
halte ich diesen Vorstoß für demokratiegefährdend.
Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das haben wir beim letzten Mal auch schon so diskutiert,
wenn wir jetzt Angst davor haben, dass jemand falsch wählt, ist das vielleicht...
Also es ist dann der Olaf-Scholz-artige Weg, so hat er das ja argumentiert,
dem würde ich nun gar nicht folgen.
Damit kommt man auch nicht weit, also dann kann ich auch sagen,
dann sollten Leute, die zum Mindestlohn arbeiten, lieber nicht wählen,
weil die häufiger die AfD wählen oder sowas.
Das treiben die in Amerika sehr weit. Du wohnst in dieser Straße,
dann gehörst du nicht in unseren Bezirk, sondern dann wählst du einfach für die AfD.
Also ich halte das auch für keine gute Argumentation, würde aber unterstreichen
wollen, weil manche glauben, dass man mit so einem Familienwahlrecht was Progressives
schaffen könnte, das glaube ich nicht. Wir können uns zwei Szenarien vorstellen,
um das ganz kurz zu machen.
Das erste Szenario ist, wir haben Familienwahlrecht, also man wirbt um die Eltern und sagt,
wir investieren mehr in Schulen, wir bauen die Tagesbetreuung aus,
wir investieren grundsätzlich in Bildung mehr, wir sorgen dafür,
dass es ein Grunderbe für Kinder gibt. Ab dem 18.
Bekommen sie das dann ausgezahlt. Das sind all die Dinge und dann würden hier
fast alle zustimmen, die uns hier zuhören.
Aber wir können uns fragen, ist das die erfolgreiche Politik?
Also wir reden jetzt nur gerade strategisch. Oder ist die erfolgreiche Politik…,
Aha, ich bekomme also bei Eltern mehr Stimmen. Ich bin jetzt ein konservativer
Politiker, ich bin jetzt irgendwas zwischen J.D.
Vance und Spahn und sage mir, wir brauchen dringend eine Maximalquote von Ausländern in Schulen.
Wer in der ersten Klasse kommt, muss Deutsch sprechen können, sonst geht es nicht.
Wir müssen Migration stoppen und mehr unsere eigenen Kinder unterstützen.
Wir brauchen dringend mehr Polizei, weil überall Leute mit Messern rumrennen.
Genau. Und damit könnte man also wunderbar konservative Politik machen.
Ich hatte kürzlich das Gespräch mit einem sehr linken Vater,
der sich auch sehr mit Polizeigewalt, Rassismus und all dem auseinandersetzt
und der sagt, naja, seitdem ich Kinder habe, denke ich auch immer wieder mal
in Law and Order Kategorien.
Das heißt, das ist also die strategische Argument, das ist erstmal nicht jetzt
für die grundsätzliche Entscheidung wichtig, aber man muss sich klar machen,
es ist nicht unbedingt progressiv, wenn man Familien wählen lässt.
An sich ist vorgesehen, wenn man, ich habe eine Hausarbeit geschickt bekommen
von Giuliano, dass eigentlich… Sehr gut.
Wenn sie uns Hausarbeiten schicken, das ist wirklich, dann zeigt ihr uns,
dass ihr wirklich Premium-Hörer seid.
Also sehr interessant, weil er sagt, ja, es ist eigentlich ein Menschenrecht,
das alle wählen und es gibt keine Begrenzung dort.
Es ist nicht gesagt und erst ab dann und dann. Und er verweist auch darauf,
1970 konnte man in Deutschland erst ab 21 wählen, dann hat man das bis dahin,
dann hat man es runtergesetzt auf 18 Jahre.
Das heißt, auch da sehen wir immer wieder Anpassungen und er sagt auch,
das Argument der Kompetenz ist nicht das Entscheidende, denn sonst sind wir in einer Epistokratie.
Sonst müssten wir wirklich Tests machen und müssen schauen, kennen sich die Leute dann wirklich an.
Ja, aber man kann natürlich auch,
wenn man dieser Argumentation folgt, muss man sich immer auch gewahr werden
dessen, dass die Demokratie ja an sich ein Begriff ist, der ein Ideal markiert, das,
der Welt nicht zu erreichen ist und auch nirgends erreicht wird gerade.
Ja, wir haben ja dieses, genau, Böckenförde, man muss immer ein bisschen mehr
arbeiten als einfach nur Selbsterhaltung der Demokratie und so weiter.
Also die Frage ist ja, wo sollte die Demokratie enden?
Wir haben uns jetzt darauf geeinigt, dass wir das hier in Deutschland alle vier
Jahre so an so einer Wahlurne machen und dann gibt es nochmal Landtag,
Wählen und Kommune und sowas.
Aber wir könnten ja auch sagen, also wirkliche Demokratie ist erst,
wenn wir bei allem mitbestimmen. Wir brauchen ein Schweizer Modell.
Jetzt würden die Schweizer auch sagen können, dass ihre Demokratie nicht vollendet ist.
Das heißt, die Demokratie, das muss einem, glaube ich, klar sein,
ist immer ein unvollendetes Projekt.
Und da ist nur die Frage, wie kann man es näher an eine Vollendung bringen?
Und da wäre ja dann zum Beispiel eine Öffnung hin für ein Kinderwahlrecht sinnvoll.
Und ich habe wirklich nochmal darüber nachgedacht und würde auch meine Position
ein bisschen revidieren wollen, Weil wir ja auch so genau wissen,
wie inkompetent erwachsene Leute sind.
Wenn es um Kompetenz nicht geht, dann bin ich gegen ein Familienwahlrecht,
weil dann nimmt man einfach von jemand anderem die Stimme.
Das kann man nicht machen. Ich kann auch nicht für meine Verwandtschaft wählen,
auch wenn ich es manchmal vielleicht gerne würde.
Aber, was man machen könnte ist, dass man das Alter radikal runterstuft,
dass man sagt, also ab wann ist man in der Lage ein Kreuz zu machen auf einem
Wahlzettel, dass man auch nicht einfach ein willkürliches Kreuz setzt,
ja, dann könnte man sagen, man geht runter bis auf sieben Jahre oder so.
Das könnte man tatsächlich machen.
Man muss sich, also dann kommt man vielleicht dem demokratischen Ideal näher,
muss sich aber auch gewissen Gefahren bewusst sein, denn das bedeutet auch,
Kinder werden mit Wahlkampf adressiert.
Das bedeutet also Wahlkampfwerbung im Kinderkanal.
Kinder werden mit aller möglicher Werbung adressiert.
Ja, ja, aber man muss sich im Klaren sein, die AfD wird vor Grundschulen Lutscher verteilen.
Ich will das jetzt nicht als Totschlagargument nehmen, sondern ich will sagen,
das ist dann die Wirklichkeit. Das kann auch die SPD da machen, aber das ist dann so.
Also man kann durchaus Werbebann meilen um Schulen.
Aber Kinder werden adressiert werden müssen.
Ja, aber. Wenn sie wählen sollen.
Dann müssen sie adressiert werden von Wahlwerbung.
Ja, das klingt jetzt moralisch und dramatisch. Ich möchte es gerne humoristisch
illustrieren. Ich glaube, das versteht dann sofort jeder.
In Deutschland ist es möglich, mit 17 Jahren oder jüngeren Abitur zu schreiben.
Ja.
So, man kann gerne mal auf die Server gehen und sich die Mathe-Abitur-Aufgaben
der letzten Jahre anschauen und sich fragen, Leute, die das bestehen.
Geben wir kein Wahlrecht für den Bundestag? Das ist absurd. Also auf der Ebene
ist es auf jeden Fall absurd.
Epistokratisch argumentiert, ja. Giuliano bringt ja dieses Beispiel,
das wir alle kennen, nur einer von acht Amerikanern weiß auf der Landkarte den Irak zu zeigen.
Aber man führt da Krieg und hat aber da eine Auffassung zum Krieg oder sowas.
Ich lese mal weiter aus der Mail. Jetzt nähern wir uns dem Punkt,
der mir am wichtigsten ist.
Johannes schreibt, als Feindbild, das sieht man ja auch gerade in Trumps,
Vans Kampagne, gegen die kinderlose Harris steht,
die selbstbestimmte Frau, die sich in vielen Fällen entscheidet,
keine Kinder zu bekommen und beispielsweise dem Berufsleben,
aber auch anderen gesellschaftlichen Impact den Vorzug gibt.
So, damit habe ich ein gigantisches Problem. Das ist im Grunde der Anlass,
warum ich überhaupt das Buch schreibe.
Diese Idee davon, die selbstbestimmte Frau ist dann besonders frei und förderungswürdig
und wird deswegen von Trump und Vance bekämpft, weil sie eine freie Entscheidung kann zwischen,
Berufsleben oder Familie.
Das ist der große Denkfehler. Das können wir uns nicht mehr erlauben.
Wir leben nicht mehr in diesen 50er, 60er, 70er Jahren oder in den 1800ern oder
1700ern, wo wir einfach immer sagen können, ja der nächste Jahr kommt.
Sondern nein, der kommt nicht. Also die Kinderzahl pro Frau in Berlin ist gerade 1,17.
Das bedeutet, innerhalb von einer Generation wird die Bevölkerung halbiert.
Damit ist kein Staat zu machen. Also das ist einfach faktisch.
Das ist jenseits von einer Meinungslage.
Wenn du 100 Leute im Rentenalter hast und es kommen aber nur noch 50 nach, dann ist aus.
Also dann sind das einfach nordkoreanische Verhältnisse für alle Betroffenen.
Da wird es ja wirklich kritisch, was eben bedeutet, wir können uns das gar nicht
länger leisten zu sagen, ja, die selbstbestimmte Frau soll einfach mit 23 entscheiden,
ob sie jetzt Beruf oder Kinder. Nein, es muss natürlich beides gehen.
Wir brauchen eine beruflich erfüllte Frau, die trotzdem noch drei Kinder hat.
Und wenn es dann heißt, ja, aber der Tag hat noch 24 Stunden,
ja, dann braucht sie halt Personal.
Jeder CEO hat Personal. Man hat eine Sekretärin, man hat einen Fahrer.
Mütter brauchen das dann auch. Drei Kinder kommen nicht einfach so in die Welt.
Also auf der Ebene würde ich gerne das hier neu genannt haben.
Du musst nur bedenken, dass das Personal auch wiederum.
Da gibt es ja dann die Energieeffekte. Das ist ja das Tolle.
Naja, in den USA haben auch sehr viele Leute Personal, aber das sind dann Mütter,
die ihre Kinder nicht sehen.
Weil die Kinder in Lateinamerika sitzen. Verstehe ich sofort,
was du sagen möchtest, aber ein ICE mit 30.000 PS,
der auf 400 Meter Länge so und so viele Menschen transportiert,
braucht jemanden im Führerstand,
fünf Leute, die anwesend sind, um sich um irgendwas zu kümmern und nochmal 100
Leute, die sich darum kümmern, dass der Betrieb läuft.
So. Man kriegt damit eine ganze Kleinstadt in den Urlaub gefahren.
Mit diesen 100 Leuten Personal. Das meine ich mit Personal.
Das muss natürlich organisiert werden. Ich meine jetzt nicht vorzeitliche aristokratische
oben leben die Dienstmädchen für die Familie und so. Sondern nein,
das muss natürlich klug organisiert werden, aber ein öffentlicher Nahverkehr
läuft für mich schon unter Personal.
Eine Kinderbetreuung bis 20 Uhr, Betreuungsschlüssel 1 zu 7 oder so,
das läuft unter Personal.
Also hier geht es nicht darum, dass wir nochmal zusätzlich Bevölkerung abziehen,
um Mütter zu unterstützen, sondern nein, das muss halt einfach clever organisiert werden.
Das ist nicht so ein 1%-Feminismus, wo man sagt, die CEO bekommt jetzt mehr Personal.
Wenn das Zauberwort, das hier neu vorzustellen ist, dann ist Sozialstaat.
Ja.
Ist gar nicht so kompliziert. Wir wissen eigentlich, um was es geht. Aber ja. So.
Also, ich muss hier gegen Johannes und Vance...
Familienbild anargumentieren, während wir gerade mitgekriegt haben,
dass Johannes ja der totale Gegner von Vance ist.
Und ich sage, ja, ja, die sind schon totale Gegner, aber die haben beide dasselbe Familienbild.
Das ungeräte Vorzeichen ändert hier gar nichts.
Was ja, glaube ich, der Fernseher halber, muss man es erwähnen,
sagen will, ist, dass es ja eine bewusste Entscheidung sein kann, keine Kinder zu haben.
Oder manchmal ist es auch gar keine Entscheidung, sondern man Man kann keine
Kinder haben aus anderen Gründen.
Oder man kann keine Kinder haben und will vielleicht trotzdem welche.
Vielleicht sollten wir selbst mal über die biologische Geburtenfolge nachdenken.
Vielleicht muss man den Familienbegriff sogar da mal aufbohren.
Aber wenn man jetzt Leute ausstattet mit Kindern, mit mehr Wahlrecht,
mit mehr Stimmen, als die Leute, die keine Kinder bekommen können oder wollen,
dann ist das eine Ungerechtigkeit.
Und auf diese zieht er ja hier ab. Und das würde ich auch ganz deutlich so unterstreichen
wollen, weil man dann einfach nur sagt, dass Eltern einen besseren Status bekommen.
Wir haben ja akzeptiert, dass Eltern zum Beispiel steuerlich besser gestellt
werden, ja, als Menschen, die keine Kinder haben.
Das hat auch seinen Sinn und es gibt ja viele weitere Förderungen,
kann man auch immer sagen, geht nicht weit genug, sicherlich an manchen Stellen.
Was ich aber nicht sagen würde, ist, dass man ihnen, nur weil sie Kinder haben,
jetzt mehr Stimmen geben sollte.
Und man muss ja auch erkennen, du gehst zwar immer auf das Demografische ein,
das ist auch richtig, nur ist ja die Entscheidung, ein Kind zu bekommen,
davon vollkommen losgelöst.
Also niemand bringt ja ein Kind auf die Welt aus demografischen Gründen,
sondern Kinder kommen auf die Welt entweder aus Versehen oder aus egoistischen Gründen.
Genau, und das ist ja der Punkt, weshalb wir dieses J.D. Vance Zitat über das,
was in dem Video hinaus zu hören ist, nämlich dieses Investment in Society.
Für J.D. Vance sind Kinder, die geboren werden, seine Kinder.
Er ist der Politiker, der als großer Patriarch da so drüber steht und sagt,
Und wir hören das gleich an Clips, also ich will es gar nicht weiter ausführen,
sondern an den Clips hört man dann, wie er das meint. Das ist wirklich hochgradig dramatisch.
Und ich möchte nochmal einen Begriff vorstellen, jetzt habe ich schon den Sozialstaat
genannt und so, das sind ja alles keine neuen Begriffe, sondern man muss sie nur mal anders anlegen.
Ich will nochmal einen Begriff vorschlagen, ich war ja auch in Bielefeld jetzt
im Monat und habe dort bei Stefan Kühl mal im Kolloquium mein Buch so ein bisschen besprochen.
Und das war natürlich, ich habe mir gedacht, wieso bin ich so selten in Bielefeld,
wieso bin ich nie in Kolloquien, wo sind die Studenten, ladet mich ein, ja.
Ich halte auch gerne Vorträge oder so, einmal im Jahr, aber Kolloquien,
ich komme immer gern. So, dort war die Frage, die du ja gerade aufgeworfen hast,
was ist jetzt mit denen, die keine Kinder haben wollen?
Die J.D. Vance ja dann als childless cat lady und so weiter und so fort.
Und jetzt, hierfür brauchen wir einen neuen Begriff und in Bielefeld kam der
Vorschlag, einfach einen alten zu benutzen, aber ernst zu nehmen. Haushalt.
Das Elementare in der Gesellschaft ist nicht das Individuum,
sondern der Haushalt, in dem man lebt.
So wie in der Gesellschaft auch nichts
hingekriegt wird, solange man nicht Organisationen hat, die gestalten.
So, Familien sind keine Organisationen, sie können nicht einfach über Mitgliedschaft
und so, da werden auch keine Boni ausgezahlt und keine Zwecke verhandelt oder
was auch immer, also es ist einfach keine Organisation, aber der Haushaltsbegriff,
Den kann man dafür wirklich nochmal, das werde ich im Buch richtig betonen,
das Elementare in der Gesellschaft ist der Haushalt.
Nicht ohne Grund kommt ja Dunja Hayali und sagt, jeder, der einen Haushalt führt,
weiß, Christian Lindner hat es schwer.
Und dann machen wir uns darüber lustig, weil da eine Verwechslung stattfindet.
Aber der Haushalt ist ein sehr wichtiger Begriff.
So, ich möchte jetzt diesen Haushaltsbegriff so benutzen, dass egal ist,
ob da Kinder leben oder nicht.
Wenn ein Haushalt aus zwei Menschen besteht, zwei stimmen. Wenn es drei Leute
sind, weil sich drei Erwachsene entscheiden, Haushalte führen, haben die drei Stimmen.
Wenn jetzt zwei Leute sich entscheiden, zwei Kinder zu haben,
ist das ein vierköpfiger Haushalt und meine Frage ist dann, warum hat der nur zwei Stimmen?
Aber wie wird...
Das kennen wir gleich. Dem nähern wir uns jetzt.
So, erstmal müssen wir diesen Haushalt, wie ich ihn jetzt vorgestellt habe,
gegen das Familienbild von J.D.
Vance abgrenzen, denn hier droht wirklich Gefährliches, wenn Jens Spahn jetzt
beim Parteitag rumsteht und sagt, wir halten mal mit denen Kontakt und die haben
ja auch ganz gute Ideen, wie zum Beispiel das Familienwahlrecht oder sowas.
Ich will jetzt mal, ich spiele Diese Clips sind auf Empfehlung von Humann,
die habe ich auch erst die Tage jetzt, ich bin wirklich aus allen Wolken gefallen.
Die Sendung, die wir jetzt hören, heißt USA extrem und wurde vom CDF produziert.
Man hat Idaho, Oklahoma und den ganzen wilden Westen da mal besucht.
Wir hören jetzt hier, wie extrem J.D. Vans Familienideologie auf die Spitze
getrieben werden kann und zwar als faktische Politik.
Reale, gelebte Gesellschaft. Es geht um die Frage, wann sitzen Frauen,
warum im Gefängnis, hier Oklahoma.
Viele der Frauen sitzen wegen Drogendelikten ein.
Andere für ein Vergehen, das in Oklahoma härter bestraft wird als anderswo.
Mütterliche Vernachlässigung.
Verkürzt heißt das, wenn ein Vater sein Kind schlägt, kann die Mutter dafür
härter bestraft werden als der Vater, weil sie die Schläge nicht verhindert hat.
Wie weit kann man es treiben? Hier Einzelfall.
2021 sind 342 Frauen in Oklahoma wegen mütterlicher Vernachlässigung in Haft. Jede 6. Insassin.
Auch die 19-jährige Tondaleo Hall wird dafür 2004 eingesperrt.
Ihr damaliger Partner schlägt ihre beiden 3 Monate und 2 Jahre alten Kinder.
Sie erleiden Knochenbrüche.
Er wird zu 10 Jahren Haft verurteilt, sitzt aber nur 2 ab.
Tondaleo Hall bekommt 30 Jahre, weil sie ihre Kinder nicht beschützt hat.
So, der Vater schlägt das Kind und J.D. Vance aus seiner Sicht sagt dann,
das geht nicht, du darfst Kinder nicht schlagen, sind ja meine Kinder.
Du ziehst die ja nur für mich groß, es geht ja um mein demografisches Heil.
Und dann fragt er sich, wen bestrafe ich denn jetzt, um auch ein Exempel zu statuieren.
Dann kriegt der Vater 10 Jahre für die Schläge und die Mutter bekommt 30 Jahre,
weil sie diese Schläge nicht verhindert hat.
Wahnsinn.
Und während der Vater nach zwei Jahren wieder raus ist, sitzt sie nach 20 Jahren,
2004 wurde sie verurteilt, immer noch im Gefängnis.
Erst medialer Druck hat sie dann sozusagen ein bisschen früher ausgeholt,
aber das Strafmaß war 30 Jahre und wäre auf juristischem Wege nicht zu verkürzen gewesen.
Das ist das Familienmodell von J.D. Vance. Also darauf läuft das hinaus.
Also das ist ja auch genau das, wo Kamala Harris, glaube ich,
sehr viele nochmal erreichen kann.
Also ich will das, und das stört mich so, dass man so wenig über diese konkreten Dinge redet.
Ich bin ja froh, die Amerikaner werden es wahrscheinlich intuitiv wissen,
was gemeint ist, wenn Kamala Harris da einige Projekte anschiebt.
Also worum es aber hier im deutschen Diskurs so geht, ja über irgendwas mit
Testosteron und wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Female Empowerment.
Nee, es geht um ganz, ganz konkrete Situationen, wo einfach eine Trump-Regierung
natürlich diese ohnehin desaströsen Zustände verschlechtern würde.
Und nicht nur wird dir Lebenszeit genommen als Mutter, wenn du nicht für Trumps
Nachwuchs sorgst, für den nächsten Jahrgang, sondern es kostet auch.
In Oklahoma müssen die Insassen einen Teil der Gefängniskosten selbst tragen.
Das heißt, je länger die Strafe, desto höher die Kosten.
Ich schulde den Behörden 107.000 Dollar für sieben Jahre.
Ja, die Frauen kommen dann aus dem Gefängnis und kriegen für ihre Haft eine Rechnung vorgelegt.
Wegen mütterlicher Vernachlässigung, das ist jetzt noch der Kostenfaktor dazu. Hier noch ein Beispiel.
Brandy hat ihr halbes Leben hinter Gittern verbracht. Auch ihr Vergehen lautet
mütterliche Vernachlässigung.
Heute wird sie entlassen.
Kannst du das fassen? 21,5 Jahre, auf den Tag genau. Ja, auf den Tag.
Du siehst fantastisch aus. Der Eyeliner passt zur Bluse. Passt perfekt. Ja, sehr hübsch.
Brandys Sohn stirbt mit einem Jahr an Meningitis. Das Gericht spricht Brandy
wegen Misshandlung schuldig.
20 Jahre Haft.
Wahnsinn.
Also diese alte Ronald-Dragon-Idee, wir dürfen keine Familienpolitik machen,
weil wir uns nicht in den heiligen Bund zwischen Mutter und Tochter oder Sohn
und Mutter einmischen dürfen. Ja.
Das wurde hier wirklich auf die Spitze getrieben. Ja. Die letzten Jahre.
Und das droht, das sind ja dann auch diese Bundesstaaten, die sagen,
ach so, das Supreme Court erlaubt uns jetzt wieder Abtreibung.
Keine Abtreibung mehr. Egal in welchem Fall. Jedes Kind wird geboren,
Weil es ist nicht das Kind der Mutter oder des Vergewaltigers oder was auch
immer, sondern es ist unser Nachwuchs.
Wir haben da eine staatliche Hoheit drüber.
Jetzt ist es so, als das jetzt diskutiert wurde, was J.D. Vance da gesagt hat.
Es geht um Verantwortung und Investment in die Gesellschaft.
Die Kinder sind nicht deine eigenen Kinder.
Du bist nur sozusagen von Gott auserwählt, das Kind auszutragen.
Es ist dann deine weltliche Aufgabe, dafür zu sorgen.
Und wenn du der widersprichst, dann gibt es von uns keine Gnade,
sondern dann wirst du da direkt.
Jetzt hat Pete Budichich bei Jon Stewart folgende Anmerkung zu diesem J.D. Vance-Spruch gemacht.
Er hat die Idee, dass man extra Voten bekommt, wenn man Kinder hat.
Extra Voten? Yeah, he suggested that you should have extra votes if you're a parent.
Really? I think there's lots of things... You don't even get that in your own house.
I'm a parent. You don't get anything. It's true, I'm starting to find that.
I mean, ours are not yet three, but...
And it's rooted in this strange idea that it's not just... He doesn't just say
that being a parent gives you, you know, an important role as a citizen,
which I agree with, that it gives you unique perspective on the future.
Es ist, dass es nicht ein Vater zu sein, dich weniger macht.
Ich denke, das ist absolut so, wie ich mich fühle. Er sagte,
Menschen, die keine Kinder haben, das ist ein Quote, haben keinen physischen
Vertrauen in die Zukunft dieses Landes.
Wow. Und ich denke nur daran, wie...
Kein physischer Vertrauen in die Zukunft des Landes. Als ich in Afghanistan
geflüchtet wurde, hatte ich damals keine Kinder. Back then.
But I will tell you, especially when there was a rocket attack going on,
my commitment to this country felt pretty physical.
Can I tell you something?
This is why people love seeing you go on shows. Because that framing is perfect.
Because it does, it points to that idea that who are you to tell what's in someone else's heart?
Waren unglaublich. Also, es ist schockierend. So, jetzt sagt also ein ehemaliger
Soldat, naja, wenn der J.D.
Vance sagt, Menschen ohne Kinder sind ja nicht so physisch involviert in die
Gesellschaft und ihre Zukunft, weil sie werden nicht überlebt von der nächsten Generation.
Und sagt er, naja, aber ich habe mich auch ziemlich physisch committed gefühlt,
als ich im Afghanistan-Einsatz dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
lebensbedrohlich da bedroht wurde, so.
Wenn man jetzt diesen Weg weitergeht, würde das ja wirklich bedeuten,
also er macht das ja nur als, ich will es nicht unterstellen,
es ist ja nur ein Kontrapunkt, aber wenn man jetzt diese Diskussion mit J.D.
Vance und wie Pete das hier vorgestellt hat, weitergeht, müsste man ja irgendwie
eine Argumentation machen und die liegt ja den Silicon Valley Leuten wieder
nah. na, ich habe ja 100 Angestellte, für die ich Verantwortung übernehme.
Warum habe ich nur eine Wahlstimme? Ich habe mein Leben für das Land riskiert.
Wolfgang möchte flüchten im Kriegseinfall. Warum bin ich nicht mehr wert, sozusagen, ne?
So, und da ist ja völlig klar, das machen wir ja nicht. Ne. One person, one vote.
Und jetzt ist ja nur die Frage, sind Kinder jetzt einfach so eine Minderheit,
die wir so ein bisschen mitschützen, bis sie irgendwann mündig werden?
Oder sagen wir einfach, ne, das ist auch one person?
Ja, dazu ist ja folgendes zu sagen, Kinder haben oder jeder Mensch hat ja das
Potenzial, in der Lage zu sein,
also grundsätzlich, wir müssen nochmal anders sagen, also anthropologischer
Sporn ist einfach der Mensch als Person,
Vernunftbegabte etc.
Das ist aber nicht immer aktuell der Fall.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel schlafe, bin ich nicht gerade der aufgeklärte Bürger.
Und trotzdem darf man mich dann zum Beispiel nicht totschlagen.
Außer Lindemann weckt dich und fragt dich, was sind die drei Kernpunkte der CDU?
Dann würde ich dann irgendwas mit Bürgergeld beantworten.
Sonst würde ich das Stimmrecht entzogen.
So, das ist so. Jetzt ist es bei Kindern ein besonderer Fall.
Es gibt sehr begabte Kinder, clever Kinder.
Wir können aber sagen, ja, ab einem gewissen Alter kann man größere Zusammenhänge verstehen.
Man kann wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass Kinder, die ein paar Jahre zur
Schule gehen, gerade kognitiv sogar weiter sind als manche Erwachsene,
die einfach gar nichts mehr lesen oder so.
Diese ganzen Sachen kann man stellen. Was man aber sagen kann, ist ja, dass,
dass aktuell Dreijährige nicht in der Lage sind, irgendeinen politischen Zusammenhang zu verstehen.
Weshalb wir ja gleich noch über das Delegatethema der Delegation sprechen.
Das können wir ja grundsätzlich für alle Kinder sagen. Man kann nicht sagen,
ja doch, aber manche schon. Wir können bei Erwachsenen sagen,
grundsätzlich ist das möglich, dann werden uns Fälle einfallen,
wo das dann doch nicht aktuell der Fall ist.
Aber wir können da so eine kategoriale Unterscheidung machen.
Machen wir, so funktioniert ja auch zum Beispiel Strafrecht,
dass wir sagen, also grundsätzlich kann man mit sieben Jahren nicht mündig sein,
kann das nicht wirklich gewollt haben, diese Tat.
Mit 18 oder 19 sieht es schon anders aus. Und hier ist die Frage,
kann man diesen Sprung machen, darüber hinweg zu gehen, also nicht mehr Potenzialität
und Aktualität von Kompetenz oder Vernunft oder irgendetwas zu sehen.
Spielt es grundsätzlich keine Rolle, sagen wir einfach nur, jeder Mensch eine
Stimme und dann stellt sich eine ganz praktische Frage, wie sollen jene wählen,
die noch nicht auf eigenen Beinen dorthin kommen und noch nicht wissen,
dass sie wählen können, nämlich zum Beispiel Zweijährige.
Das heißt, wir müssten also, wenn wir es nicht anderen übergeben wollen,
das wäre dann das JD-Vans-Ding, müssten wir sagen, erst ab, sagen wir,
sieben Jahren ist es möglich.
Ja, also eigentlich war mein Plan schon darauf hinzuweisen, dass nur weil jemand
anders wählt, das noch nicht der JD-Vans-Plan ist.
Sondern Lukas Dietrich zum Beispiel, Vater und Lehrer, schreibt ja,
wir tragen die Verantwortung über fünf Personen, die von allen politischen Entscheidungen
sicher betroffen sein werden.
Also der Haushalt ist auf jeden Fall betroffen.
So, und dürfen nur zwei Stimmen abgeben. Ich sehe absolut kein Argument auf
Wolfgangs Seite. Jeder sollte die Möglichkeit haben, über die eigene Zukunft entscheiden.
Und jetzt hast du ja schon eingewendet. Aber wie denn? Zweijähriger,
wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Ja, nicht für jemanden kann man entscheiden.
So, und jetzt werde ich diese Diskussion mal öffnen mit einer meiner Lieblingsargumentationen.
Martin Kroska schrieb nämlich zustimmend zu meinem Anliegen und dann allerdings
sehe ich einen Knackpunkt dabei, wer genau die Stimme der Kinder bekommt.
Die Mutter, der Vater, wird das durch das Sorgenrecht bestimmt.
So und wir haben ja schon festgestellt, wir haben alle ökonomischen Fragen irgendwie so modernisiert.
Also wir wissen so, was Profit ist, wir müssen nicht mehr um Erlaubnis fragen,
wir haben einfach so ein, ja und dann ist halt klar, okay, machen wir jetzt so.
So, politisch ist das ja so ein bisschen anders, wir sind immer noch so in normativen
Zwängen, also dieses Verhältnis aus Politik und Ökonomie ist ja sehr merkwürdig,
wie zum Beispiel dann wieder umgedreht, wir haben die Politik,
dadurch, dass sie in so normativen Zwängen ist, modernisiert.
Wir haben die normativen Zwänge modernisiert.
Es ist nicht mehr das Gottesgnadentum und dann ist so eine Urkunde,
wo steht, das ist Gottesgnade, sondern nee, du musst schon ein Wahlergebnis vorweisen können.
So, am Ende wird ein Stimmen ausgezählt. in der Politik damit sozusagen geregelt,
in der Ökonomie wieder völlig verworren.
Da sagt man einfach, das ist das Geld deiner Eltern. Klar, das ist deins.
Das muss jetzt nicht demokratisiert werden.
Da haben wir so eine Ungleichgewichtung.
Und jetzt in diesem Kontext, wenn wir im Restaurant sitzen und neben uns sitzen
zwei Erwachsene mit einem Kind, streiten sich diese beiden Erwachsenen darüber,
wer für das Kind bezahlt?
Oder ist das auf modernem Wege implizit einfach organisiert?
Geht man in einem Supermarkt einkaufen und sagt, ja, also das ist hier für das
Kind, ich will das nicht bezahlen, das ist ja nicht meins, ich kaufe ja nicht für mich.
Da kriegt man auch keine Rechtfertigungspflichten umgedreht. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich stelle mir das durchaus vor.
Dass es diese Streitigkeiten gibt. Nee, an wen zahlen wir Kindergeld? Es gibt keine, also.
In Deutschland ist völlig klar.
Aber es gibt auch unglaublich viele Menschen, die nicht mehr verheiratet sind
und Kinder haben und die voneinander getrennt sind. Wenn sie es aufgelöst haben.
Genau.
Und die voneinander getrennt sind.
Dann kommen nämlich diese Fragen.
Und dann kommen doch schon diese Fragen rein. Aber ich weiß auch gar nicht,
ob die Frage, also ich glaube, dass diese Frage lässt sich lösen.
Nein, die lässt sich nicht nur lösen, sondern die ist flächendeckend für 14
Millionen Kinder in Deutschland gelöst.
Das Kindergeld wird ausgezahlt, ohne dass diejenigen, die das Kindergeld bekommen, dem Staat antworten.
Also da wo das Kind im Haushalt lebt, könnte man sagen, wird gewählt,
nur ist es immer noch eine Übertragung einer Stimme und macht damit die Position,
nicht die Kinder wählen beim Familienwahlrecht, sondern man sagt nur,
wir übervorteilen die Eltern, nur weil sie Kinder haben, sollen sie mehr Stimmen haben.
Die Kinder, die Eltern, weil das hier so argumentiert wird, dass die Eltern
da Entscheidungen jetzt treffen auf Kosten der Kinder oder im Sinne der Kinder,
das geschieht die ganze Zeit.
Also ob die jetzt mit einer Stimme wählen oder mit fünf Stimmen wählen,
sie wählen immer nur ihre Sache.
Sie wählen nicht für die Kinder. Das bedeutet nur, dass alle Kinderlosen schlechter
dastehen. Und deswegen sollte es kein Familienwahlenrecht geben,
weil das tatsächlich einfach nur Leute bevorteilt.
Dann kann man auch sagen, alle Leute, die mehr als 5000 netto im Monat haben,
sollten drei Stimmen bekommen.
Das wäre genau so eine sinnlose Argumentation.
Nein, guck mal, ist ja genau nicht so. Ich habe ja eben, wenn jemand kommt wie
Elon Musk und sagt, ich habe aber 300.000 Mitarbeiter, ich hätte gerne mehr
Stimmrecht, der argumentiert ja so.
Ja, du machst aber Tür und Tor für so Sachen auf. Warum?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, stopp, stopp, stopp, guck mal. Ein Kind ist eine Person.
Ein Mitarbeiter ist auch eine Person, aber die hat ein Stimmrecht.
Die hat eine Stimmrechte. Okay, dann gehen wir nochmal einen Schritt zurück
und sagen, ein Kind soll wählen können.
Aber dann soll es auch wählen können. Aber nicht der Vater, der gerne seine….
Gehen wir mal von dem zweijährigen Kind aus. Das zweijährige Kind trifft keine Entscheidung selbst.
Es muss aber Entscheidungen getroffen werden für das Kind, ansonsten bleibt
es nämlich nur zwei Jahre und stirbt.
Irgendwer muss für ein Kind entscheiden, in allen Lebenslagen.
Und sonderbarerweise nehmen wir eine, von der ich dann wieder sage,
ist eine sehr wichtige, nehmen wir dann raus. Wie ernähren wir ein Kind?
Das entscheiden auch einfach die Eltern. Da kommt auch keiner um die Ecke und
mischt sich irgendwie ein. Da wird mal eine Kinderarztuntersuchung angehört. Ja, weil wir sagen.
Dass Kinder noch nicht mündig sind. Und deswegen ist die Frage...
Ja, aber das Kind muss ja trotzdem ernährt werden. Es ist ja trotzdem eine biologische Person.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber es ist ja auch eine politische Person.
Nein, in dem Sinne nicht. Also wenn man jetzt Bürgerschaft, das Cétunien auffasst,
der aufgeklärte Bürger, dann würde man genau sagen, nicht.
Also es liegt halt einfach da und schreit und kann deshalb keinen politischen Willen bekunden.
Aber es ist ja trotzdem eine Person.
Es ist eine Person, ja. Aber es wird ja auch mit abgedeckt von der Wahl.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass wir eine Politik haben, wir wählen ja für das Ganze,
das heißt ich wähle ja auch mit meiner Stimme zum Beispiel für Anliegen,
die mich gar nicht betreffen.
Ich zum Beispiel wähle, also ausschlaggebend für meine Wähler,
für meine Wahlentscheidung ist schon, macht man gute Politik für Kinder und für die Bildung.
Ich selbst bin kein Kind mehr, ich habe keine Kinder, mir könnte es also auch
scheißegal sein, aber ich mache das so, weil ich das als wichtig empfinde.
Also wir lesen im Salon diesen vierseitigen Text von Aladin Malafalani.
In dem steht einfach drin, das Bildungssystem in Deutschland ist gerade nicht
der Rede wert. Es ist einfach quasi nicht existent.
Aber daran würde ja ein Wien-Wahlrecht null oder null ändern.
Warte, wir haben sehr lange, also was heißt sehr lange, wir haben jetzt bei
Corona festgestellt, Homeschooling gibt es nicht. Und jetzt stellen wir so fest…,
Und Schulschooling gibt es auch nicht so richtig. Es hängt doch sehr viel von
der Motivation der Eltern ab, ob die Lehrer können, also die können das gar nicht.
Ein Kind, das von seinem Haushalt nicht dabei unterstützt wird,
in der Schule gut zu sein, kann die Schule nicht bewältigen.
Das Bildungssystem ist… Aber Stefan.
Das ist doch alles nicht zu leugnen. Natürlich, aber du sagst mir,
was das Familienwahlrecht daran ändert.
Jetzt warte auf mein Argument. Das ist ja erstmal nur eine These.
Die Argumentation folgt jetzt.
Meine Arbeitshypothese ist,
wenn in Deutschland 14 Millionen Menschen, die vom Schulsystem betroffen sind
und die sich zuletzt ein Recht auf Schule beim Bundesverfassungsgericht als
neues Grundrecht erklagt haben und zugesprochen bekommen haben.
Das waren aber nicht 14 Millionen.
Das war irgendeine kleine Gruppe, die geklagt hat.
Ja, so ist das. Das ist Repräsentation. Es gibt Leute, die sich für das Recht
auf Schule, nachdem sie das Defizit durch Corona feststellen.
So, 14 Millionen Menschen, die von diesem Bildungssystem betroffen wären.
Meine Arbeitshypothese ist einfach nur, es würde in der Bildungspolitik einen Unterschied machen.
Ich glaube es gar nicht. Also es wird eine andere Bildungspolitik geben.
Wir haben 18 Millionen Rentner, die
dürfen wählen. Und deswegen sieht die Rentenpolitik aus, wie sie aussieht.
In den Schulen ist nichts los und die höchste Rentenerhöhung seit 30 Jahren.
Ja. Ich gehe fest davon aus.
Einfach nur, weil die Rentner wählen dürfen.
Ich gehe fest davon aus.
Das liegt nur daran, dass die Rentner alle wählen. Wenn die 18 Millionen Rentner
nicht wählen dürften, würden sie wie sie behandeln, wie die Hochaltrigen während der Corona-Pandemie.
Die würden in irgendwelchen Häusern liegen. Niemand würde sich drum kümmern.
Und Bartsch würde im Bundestag sagen, das ist das dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen
Nachkriegsgeschichte.
Natürlich.
Und das dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen Nachkriegsgeschichte ist derzeit das Bildungssystem.
Ja. Aber daran würde sich durch ein Familienwahlrecht nichts ändern.
Wir bekämen mehr Polizei, irgendwelche verrückten Migrationsquoten in Klassen und, und, und.
Es würde sich am Bildungssystem an sich nichts ändern.
Hier hören uns jetzt fast nur progressive Eltern zu, die genau dir zustimmen,
mir zustimmen, Malfalani zustimmen, alles so sehen.
Aber das ist nicht die Mehrheit und genau deshalb findet Jens Spahn das ja toll.
Und ich will nochmal deutlich machen, ich will nicht, dass Stimmen übertragen
werden können, dass jemand anders mit seiner Idiosynkrasie plötzlich doppelt
ausgestattet wählen gehen kann. Da bin ich dagegen.
Dann sage ich, die Kinder müssen selbst wählen.
Ich bin dafür, die Kinder sollen wählen. Wegen mir ab sieben oder sechs Jahren,
die Pädagogen sollen es wegen mir entscheiden.
Ich habe kein Problem damit, das können wir gerne machen.
Das ist, finde ich.
Noch die verrücktere Idee als ein Familienwahlrecht.
Nein, das finde ich… Sechsjährige.
Siebenjährige Kinder, die wählen.
Wieso? Kinder sind gar nicht blöd, ne? Ich nagel mich gar nicht drauf fest.
Kinder sitzen nämlich in dieser Schule.
Ich hatte ja, ich habe es, glaube ich, schon erzählt, ich war ja vor einigen
Wochen in Trier bei einer Freundin, die zwei Kinder hatte und der eine kam aus
der Kita und sagte, und wie alt ist er?
Knapp fünf. und sagte dann, ja, das ist alles ganz schlimm im Sommer.
Alles ist kaputt, wir müssen in die Turnhalle, weil es da kühler ist,
Ich würde sagen, den kann man adressieren als Wähler. Bei diesem Familienwahlrecht,
glaube ich, macht man einen fundamentalen Fehler, man überträgt nämlich ein
Wahlrecht und entmündigt eigentlich die Kinder noch nur in einer anderen Weise.
Also Kinder sind nicht mündig und das hat ja sehr viele gute Gründe,
gerade was strafrechtliche Dinge anbelangt.
Und wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, dann müssten die aber doch eine Stimme haben und
ich wähle für die, die werden aber nicht gefragt, weil man Zweijährige nicht
fragen kann, dann entmündige ich sie nur in einer anderen Weise.
Weil ich nicht weiß, was dieses Kind will.
Vielleicht wird dieses Kind am Ende bittere Vorwürfe machen,
warum, liebe Eltern, habt ihr jahrelang noch meine Stimme verwendet, um Partei XY zu wählen.
Und das ist keine gute Geschichte.
Deswegen bleibt die Demokratie ein unerreichtes, unvollendetes Ideal.
Na gut.
Aber ich finde, man sollte das Wahlalter heruntersetzen. Auf sieben. Wir gehen auf sieben.
Okay. Also sieben Jahre heißt ja Zweitklässler, Erstklässler, Zweitklässler.
In dem machen die eh schon Demokratie. Die wählen Klassensprecher,
die entscheiden mit, wenn die Lehrerin fit ist.
Die können in Vereine gehen, Fußballvereine und sowas.
Ja. Ja, ich finde auch, man sollte erstmal relativ zügig Kinder in der Schule
ermächtigen, Selbstwirksamkeit zu erfahren.
Und da stelle ich mir echt, ich habe das eben jetzt so schlimm ausgemalt mit,
ja, die AfD verteilt Lutscher vor der Schule, aber da kann man sich ja auch
mal Positives ausmalen.
Was braucht ihr für euren Sportverein? Mhm.
Ich brauche die Kinder als Wähler.
Also sind sie doch plötzlich Wahlkampf-Innerlich-Verändernde Subjekte endlich.
Statt nur Objekte in einem politischen Prozess.
Dann sind sie nicht mehr Objekte.
Dann kann man sie direkt ansprechen. Und ich will hier nicht das verklären und
sagen, wie Kinder sind die besseren Menschen oder so.
Kinder können auch ungerecht, böse und alles Mögliche sein.
Aber da kann man natürlich einen Wahlkampf mit machen.
Und ich glaube, dass zum Beispiel auch Neunjährige nicht sagen werden,
dass Migration ihr großes Problem ist.
Dass Neunjährige, es gibt ganz herrliche Videos,
wie Kinder zu zweit aus Klassen übereinander ausgefragt werden.
Ja.
Dann hast du Kinder im Rollstuhl, Kinder mit afrikanischem Migrationshintergrund,
der nun wirklich sehr sichtbar ist und so.
Und niemand redet darüber, dass da jemand im Rollstuhl sitzt oder einen afrikanischen
Migrationshintergrund hat. Das kommt wirklich erst später.
Das sind wirklich, Ganz konstruierte Debatten.
Und da würde ich sagen, braucht man auch diesen feministischen,
emanzipatorischen, aus allen Richtungen Diversität fördernden,
also die Anerkennung fördernden Diskurse. Denn,
Während die eine Seite jetzt immer sagt, nee, die treiben es zu weit und wie
auch immer, sage ich, nee, das ist viel zu zaghaft. Viel zu zaghaft.
Also der Vokismus in diesen wichtigen Sparten wurde wirklich noch nicht weit
genug getrieben, denn die meisten Argumentationen, die man so hört,
sind einfach strunzdoof.
Also das, was J.D. Vance so erzählt die ganze Zeit. Ich glaube,
die Leute kriegen einfach mit, es macht keinen Sinn, darauf inhaltlich zu reagieren.
Deswegen ist dieser Wahlkampf im Internet jetzt auch so, wie er ist.
Der mobilisiert nicht über diese Inhalte, weil diese Inhalte sind aber witzig.
Angefangen, und das finde ich wirklich hervorragend, dass das Familienbild jetzt so zentral steht.
Scott Galloway hat schon dazu aufgerufen.
Dass die Demokraten jetzt all in gehen beim Thema Family Values und einfach sagen,
drei Kinder oder fünf Kinder mit drei Frauen wie bei Donald Trump,
begrüßen wir, finden wir gut.
Wir mögen es nicht ganz so sehr, dass unsere neunjährigen Kinder vorm Fernseher
sitzen und wir dann erklären müssen, wer Stormy Daniels ist.
Naja, die Prostituierte, die Pornodarstellerin, wie auch immer,
mit der Trump ist halt da und so weiter.
Das ist dann so ein bisschen ein Double-Cycle, aber warum man nicht mit drei
Frauen fünf Kinder haben sollte, um dann auch die Milliarden,
die man hat, da einfach zu investieren in das Lebensglück nachziehender Generation.
Und da muss man halt richtig reingehen. Und das finde ich auch.
Da sollten die Demokraten einfach sagen, ich bin kinderlos, kein Problem.
Donald Trump hat fünf Kinder mit drei Frauen, kein Problem.
Wenn, dann Dann habt ihr mit sowas ein Problem, wir nicht. Ja,
ja. Fangt nicht an, Family Values zu reden und so.
Und da finde ich, ja, da sollte man wirklich jetzt diese, wir sind halt eine
sehr träge Altenrepublik, aber das sind für mich die Themen, ja, und nicht,
Also Tag ist im Kommentar, ob Kamala Harris lacht. Es gibt doch so tolle Themen
zum Kommentieren, also es ist wirklich dramatisch.
Es gibt auch sehr viele ernste Themen. Wir hören jetzt einen kompletten Beitrag
aus dem Heute-Journal. Ich will den noch gerade kontextualisieren.
Ich habe an der Uni Tübingen einen Vortrag gehalten.
Da gibt es auch so neue ökonomische Denkweisen, also studentisch organisiert.
Die laden dann Leute ein und es ging um Schuldenbremse etc.
Ich fahre also von Tübingen nach Stuttgart, weil ich da auch dann am nächsten
Tag noch einen Vortrag hatte. Bin im Motel One in der Bar, trinke noch einen
und dort wird aber Fußball noch übertragen.
Dann kommt ja in der Halbzeit das verkürzte Heute-Journal.
Knapp fünf Minuten nur NATO-Gipfel, große Paraden und sie haben jetzt mal so
ein Manöver geflogen und und und.
Also diese ganze Pistorius, ein Soldat wird gefragt.
Lass mich kurz sagen, Pistorius stand in diesen Nachrichten auf dem Flugfeld
und meinte, was hier aufgebaut ist, das wird natürlich auch in Russland gesehen,
ist schon beeindruckend.
Genau, es kam natürlich diese Aussage, es wird natürlich auch in Russland gesehen.
Danach, also knapp fünf Minuten das Ganze, kommt Christian Sievers dann auf
das nächste zu sprechen.
Also wir bleiben dann im Thema und wir hören uns jetzt mal diesen gesamten Beitrag an.
Als gezielten Einschüchterungsversuch kurz vor diesem NATO-Treffen wehrten manche
den russischen Großangriff gestern auf verschiedene Städte in der Ukraine.
Aber im Grunde ist komplett egal, was das Kalkül dahinter gewesen sein mag.
Die Folgen jedenfalls sind klar und schwer zu fassen.
Kleine Patienten, die vor den Trümmern ihrer Kinderklinik in Kiew im Freien
sitzen und nicht begreifen können, was da passiert ist.
Der Ort, an dem sie gesund werden wollten, ist zerstört.
Diese Bilder werden nachwirken, rund um die Welt und natürlich in der Ukraine
selbst. Dort ist meine Kollegin Alisa Jung.
Solomir Fominuk wartet seit zwei Jahren auf eine neue Niere.
Seit Kriegsbeginn wurde sie im Kinderkrankenhaus von Kiew behandelt,
sie war gerade zur Dialyse angeschlossen, als die Stadt mit russischen Raketen geschossen wird.
Ich sah, dass der gesamte Flur, wo Solomija ist, von Trümmern bedeckt ist.
Und dann lag da ein toter Körper eines Arztes. Ich dachte, keines der Kinder hat überlebt.
Sie kämpft sich durch das Trümmerfeld und findet ihre Tochter.
Solomia hielt die Decke über ihr mit ihren Armen fest, die noch an Schläuchen
angeschlossen waren, durch die das Blut floss.
Sie konnte kaum atmen und dachte, sie erstickt.
In seinen Armen trägt ein Arzt Solomia nach draußen. Nun wird sie im Krankenhaus 1 weiter behandelt.
Die ersten beiden Stunden waren so traumatisch für die Kinder,
dass sie nicht einmal mit ihren Eltern gesprochen haben.
Nun arbeiten Psychologen mit den Kindern.
Am Angriffsort ist viel Schutt bereits weggeräumt. Wie schon so oft kann man
nur staunen, mit welcher Kraft und Geschwindigkeit sie hier weitermachen.
Dr. Oleg Godik zeigt uns, wo sie bis zum Moment des Angriffs noch behandelt haben.
Eine Kollegin aus meinem Team ist gestorben. Sie hat sich um die Vor- und Nachbereitung
von Patienten gekümmert, denen eine Niere transplantiert wird.
Ihr Name war Svetlana Lukjancic. Die Gebäude wird man reparieren können.
Dr. Godeks Kollegin werden sie morgen begraben.
Also eine grausame Angelegenheit. Es ging dann noch weiter, also wie die internationalen
Reaktionen sind auf diese Attacke auf das Krankenhaus.
Dann ging es noch darum, dass Putin und Modi zusammengekommen sind.
Und dann wird noch gerade Folgendes so wegvermeldet, bevor man schon wieder fast bei der EM ist.
Im Gazastreifen breitet sich nach
Einschätzung von mehreren UNO-Menschenrechtsexperten eine Hungersnot aus.
Die unabhängigen Fachleute verwiesen auf den Tod mehrerer Kinder durch Unterernährung
trotz medizinischer Behandlung.
Sie warfen Israel eine Hungerkampagne vor.
Die israelische Armee griff derweil nach eigenen Angaben erneut Ziele in mehreren
Gebieten des Gazastreifens an.
Schwerpunkt der Kämpfe ist demnach Gazastadt.
Tausende Bewohner wurden aufgerufen, ihre Häuser zu verlassen.
Ich sehe in den sozialen Medien unglaublich viele schreckliche Bilder und Videos.
So nicht von Aktivisten oder so, sondern von Journalisten aus der Welt, von Experten.
Ich sehe aber im deutschen Diskurs ganz, ganz wenig davon.
Man will eigentlich deutlich machen, ja, es gibt zwar da durchaus ein Leiden,
aber es muss halt irgendwie so weitergehen.
Und wir sehen ja auch bei diesen Argumentationen, die dann zum Beispiel von
Baerbock kommen, dass sie ja erst so eine Präambel wieder macht,
erst zehn Minuten über den 7.
Oktober, sprich bevor sie dann sagt, ja es gibt schon auch ein Problem mit der
medizinischen Versorgung in Gaza, aber mehr kommt nicht.
Und das ist wirklich so interessant und wenn man es jetzt nochmal so zusammen
sieht, also es gibt da Putins Angriff auf dieses Krankenhaus,
bei dem auch nicht ganz klar ist, warum haben da die Schutzschirme nicht gehalten,
warum konnte es nicht abgefangen werden.
Denn man weiß auch, diese Waffen von Russland sind sehr unpräzise.
Es gibt da auch militärisches Gebäude. Das ist im Prinzip eine ähnliche Argumentation
natürlich wie dann bei Israel, dass man auch sagt, naja, die wollten ja eigentlich
nur die Hamas treffen und sind dann leider auch wieder ein paar Kinder umgekommen.
Und wenn wir das jetzt mal so vergleichen, wir wissen, das Elend in Gaza ist groß.
Und ich werde gleich ein paar Texte auszuschneiden, vorlesen. Wie ist es denn mit.
Der Hilfe, die von Deutschland geleistet werden könnte. Wir haben hier in dem
Fall von einem Krankenhaus in Kiew sofort von Lauterbach die Zusage bekommen,
wir machen hier Plätze frei,
wir werden die Kinder versorgen, es,
soll reibungslos alles laufen und so fort.
Also die Kinder aus Kiew, denen Deutschland helfen konnte, die durften ja sofort
kommen, die sind ja auch in Deutschland.
Nur so wie wir hier unterstellen stellen müssen, dass dieser Angriff schon relativ gezielt ist.
Also so ein Krankenhaus trifft man ja vielleicht mit einer Rakete mal aus Versehen,
wie auch immer, so ein Krieg dann irgendwie gestaltet wird.
Aber das scheint mir ja ein gezielter Angriff gewesen zu sein.
So wie die Angriffe auf die Krankenhäuser in Gaza ja auch gezielte Angriffe
der israelischen, also von der Regierung beauftragt, von Militär durchgesetzt,
weil es dann immer hieß, da sind irgendwelche Keller drunter oder so.
Und dann haben die ehemaligen Premierminister selber noch betont,
ja klar sind da Keller drunter, wir haben die Keller doch gebaut.
Also es war ja unsere Verantwortung da in Gaza.
Falls du darauf anspielst, also ich habe diesen einen Clip, ich hatte ihn auch
schon wieder im Fernsehpodcast nicht unterbekommen, aber zu dieser Unterscheidung.
Wie gehen wir, unabhängig davon, wer hat da was bewusst zerstört und was ist passiert?
Deutschland ist in der Lage zu helfen, indem wir diese Kinder aufnehmen können.
Und es gibt hier einen zwei Minuten langen Bericht zum Thema Gaza,
Kinder, die betroffen sind von solchen Angriffen, in dem Falle dann der israelischen
Regierung und wie Deutschland damit umgeht.
Und jetzt hört man mal den großen Widersatz zwischen deutscher Bundesregierung
und zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement.
Und gleich am Anfang wird die Anzahl der Kliniken in Deutschland genannt,
die sich hier organisieren.
Jeder, der Kliniken kennt, weiß, da irgendwas zu organisieren ist schwer.
Der Alltag drückt alles weg hier in Frankfurt.
Die Uniklinik ist seit Oktober von einem bis heute nicht behobenen Cyberangriff betroffen.
Niemand hat Internet, es finden kaum Operationen statt, interessiert niemanden.
Kein Journalist hat das jemals irgendwie aufgeschrieben, von daher,
liebe Journalisten des Rhein-Main-Gebiets, ruft mal in der Uniklinik Frankfurt
an und fragt, was ist gerade ihr Problem?
Der Erste, der den Hörer abnimmt, kann euch schon eine Stunde dazu erzählen,
wie die Labore keine Gewebe mehr bekommen, weil ja gar keine Operationen mehr
stattfinden, der ganze Forschungsbetrieb gerade an der Uniklinik Frankfurt vorbeigeht,
weil da niemand mal eine E-Mail schreiben kann.
Das ist wirklich dramatisch. Man kann eigentlich nichts organisieren,
dennoch dieses große Engagement und dann mit der Antwort im Text, wer es ausgebremst hat.
Etwa 30 Kindern wie Karin sollte geholfen werden.
Rund 40 Kliniken in Deutschland waren bereit dazu. Auch die Uniklinik Bonn.
Die Kliniken haben sich schriftlich bereit erklärt, die gesamten Kosten für
solche Behandlungen zu übernehmen.
Für Dr. Jan Wienerns ist es wichtig,
dass die Kinder bei der Reise und der Behandlung nicht alleine sind.
Wir wollen die Kinder mit all ihren Leiden, die sie mittragen,
nicht dann nochmal zusätzlich traumatisieren, in einem völlig fremden Kulturkreis zu sein.
Insofern ist das eine unserer grundsätzlichen Notwendigkeiten,
eine Begleitperson zumindest dabei zu haben, die das Kind auch emotional abholt
und auch wichtige und zum Teil lebenswichtige Entscheidungen mittrifft.
Doch die Einreise von Begleitpersonen lehnt die Bundesregierung bisher ab.
Kinder dürfen nur alleine oder höchstens mit medizinischem Begleitpersonal zur
Behandlung nach Deutschland reisen.
Wir fragen beim Bundesinnenministerium und dem Auswärtigen Amt an.
Aus Regierungskreisen heißt es, in den letzten Monaten haben Sicherheitsprüfungen
im Gaza-Kontext deutlich gemacht, dass extremistische Einstellungen etwa unter
dem Gesichtspunkt der Hamas-Mitgliedschaft oder als deren möglicher Sympathisant vorkommen können.
Ein mögliches Risiko stellen dabei auch Personen dar, die zu einem späteren
Zeitpunkt einen Anspruch auf Familiennachzug geltend machen könnten.
Monatelang hatte die Deutsche Gesellschaft für Plastische Chirurgie und Hilfsorganisationen
wie die Kölner Refugees Foundation versucht, die Kinder nach Deutschland zu bringen.
Betten organisiert und spenden. Einige der Kinder, die ursprünglich auf ihrer
Liste standen, seien mittlerweile verstorben.
Die Kinder sind ein Jahr alt, die da auf unserer Liste stehen.
Und ich finde das ganz, ganz, ganz bitter, dass hier Politik gemacht wird auf
dem Rücken dieser Kinder. Noch
bleibt die Hoffnung, dass die Hilfsaktion nicht final gescheitert ist.
Denn die Ministerien stimmen sich noch ab, ob doch in Ausnahmefällen eine Einreise
von Begleitpersonen realisiert werden könnte.
Ich hoffe, dass die deutschen Behörden mich aus dem Gaza-Streifen evakuieren,
damit mir eine Beinprothese eingesetzt werden kann für ein normales Leben.
Auch das Krankenhaus, in dem Karim behandelt wurde, wurde diese Woche evakuiert.
Sicherheit in Gaza gibt es nicht.
Ja, liebe Bundesregierung, also das ist doch absurd. Das kann man niemandem erklären.
Nein, es ist eine Katastrophe, es ist ein politischer Totalschaden und es gibt
da keine Proteste interessanterweise in den bürgerlichen Lagern,
das wird wirklich totgeschwiegen, man kann es nicht anders sagen,
es sind ja hier rare Berichte, die wir hier rausklamüsern.
Es gibt im Neuen Deutschland einen Aufsatz dazu, einen Artikel dazu von Matthias
Monroy, der geht genau darauf ein und hat auch die Zahl, also sieben Kinder
ist schon sicher, sind gestorben, also denen man helfen wollte.
Hinzu kommt auch, dass deutsche Asylbehörden, schreibt der, entscheiden von
den meisten Flüchtlingen aus Palästina derzeit keine Asylanträge.
Das heißt, man schiebt es einfach, beschäftigt sich jetzt gar nicht damit.
Das hat eine Anfrage von Clara Bünger ergeben. Es ist katastrophal und wie katastrophal
empfehle ich, kann man nachlesen in Politico.
Und zwar ist dort etwas sehr interessantes erschienen, nämlich der Erfahrungsbericht
von zwei Medizinern, einmal Mark Perlmutter,
der ist Orthopäde und Handschirurg aus North Carolina und dann Feroci Sitwa.
Auch aus den USA, aus Nordkalifornien, der ist Intensivmediziner und Chirurg.
Und die beiden kennen sich nicht, haben sich aber verabredet oder über so Vereinigungen,
die es da gibt, dass man dort hilft.
Der Text beginnt einfach so. In den Vereinigten Staaten würden wir nicht im
Traum daran denken, jemanden ohne Einwilligung zu operieren.
Schon gar nicht ein unterernährtes und kaum bei Bewusstsein befindliches neunjähriges
Mädchen im septischen Schock.
Doch als wir Juri sahen, haben wir genau das getan.
Wir haben keine Ahnung, wie Juri in den präoperativen Bereich des Gaza European Hospital gelangt ist.
Alles, was wir sehen konnten, war, dass sie einen extrem externen Fixateur,
ein Gerüst aus Metallstiften und Stäben an ihren linken Beinen und nekrotische
Haut im Gesicht und an den Armen hatte,
die von der Explosion herrührte, die ihren kleinen Körper in Stücke gerissen hatte.
Schon die Berührung ihrer Decken löste Schmerzensschreie aus.
Sie lag langsam im Sterben, als wir beschlossen, das Risiko einer Narkose einzugehen,
ohne genau zu wissen, was wir vorfinden würden.
Im Operationssaal untersuchten wir Juri von Kopf bis Fuß.
Diesem schönen, sandflütigen kleinen Mädchen fehlten zwei Zentimeter ihres linken
Oberschenkels sowie der größte
Teil des Muskels und der Haut auf der Rückseite ihres Oberschenkels.
Ihre beiden Gesäßbacken waren aufgeschlitzt und so tief in das Fleisch geschnitten,
dass die untersten Knochen ihres Beckens freilagen.
Als wir mit unseren Händen durch diese Topografie der Grausamkeit strichen,
fielen Maden in Klumpen auf den OP-Tisch.
Und es sind nur solche Berichte. Ich will das jetzt hier nicht immer weiter
vorlesen, aber ich will deutlich machen, es gibt diese Berichte.
Es gibt die Aussage von UNICEF, die hier zitiert wird, dass der Gaza-Streifen
für ein Kind der gefährlichste Ort der Welt ist.
Hier heißt es, dass sie sich vorher
nicht kannten, sich durch diese Ärztevereinigung kennengelernt haben.
Sie sind dann in diesem European Hospital am südlichen Rand von Cannes-Junis
und ihnen fällt die Überbelegung auf. In einem 220-Betten-Krankenhaus wurden
1.500 Menschen aufgenommen.
In den Zimmern, die für vier Patienten vorgesehen waren, befanden sich in der
Regel 10 bis 12 und die Patienten waren in allen möglichen Räumen untergebracht.
Dann auf dem Krankenhausgelände.
Wie die Tieren, muss man sagen, 15.000 Menschen, die irgendwie Zuflucht suchen,
irgendwie hoffen, dass sie vielleicht doch mal ein Schmerzmittel oder irgendetwas bekommen.
Weiter heißt es, wir begannen eine Reihe von Kindern, meist Jugendliche zu sehen,
denen in den Kopf geschossen worden war.
Sie starben langsam, um dann von neuen Opfern abgelöst zu werden,
denen ebenfalls in den Kopf geschossen wurde und die dann ebenfalls langsam
starben. Ihre Familien erzählten uns eine von zwei Geschichten.
Die Kinder spielten drin, als sie von israelischen Streitkräften erschossen
wurden oder sie spielten auf der Straße, als sie von israelischen Streitkräften erschossen wurden.
Dann hier gibt es eine Anfrage an die Armee, ob das sein könne und IDF sagt
aber nur, dass man versucht, den Schaden für die Zivilbevölkerung zu minimieren.
Gut, das lassen wir mal so stehen.
Mehrere Mitarbeiter sagten uns, also jetzt die Mitarbeiter im Krankenhaus,
dass sie einfach nur warten darauf zu sterben und dass sie hoffen,
dass Israel das bald hinter sich bringen wird.
Also dass sie einfach erlöst werden durch Tod. So weit ist es da.
Es gibt weitere Schreckensberichte, die ich jetzt nicht alle vortragen will.
Ich würde nochmal sehr empfehlen, das nachzulesen.
Immer wieder, also wirklich Wunden, die voll sind von Maden.
Hier heißt es, in den nächsten zehn Tagen setzten vier Chirurgen Juri in einer
Reihe von Operationen so gut es ging wieder zusammen, indem sie ihre Wunden
entfernten, die beiden Enden ihres Oberschenkels zusammenführten.
Also es wird dann sehr genau beschrieben, was dann da ist.
Es gibt ein Geschwisterpaar Rafif und Rafik, die äh.
Haben ihre Mutter verloren und zehn weitere Familienmitglieder,
die laufen jetzt darum, also 13-jähriges Mädchen, das hat chronische Geschwüre
am jetzt amputierten Unterschenkel, die Wundversorgung ist schlecht.
Ihr Bruder, der 15-jährige Rafik, war so stark unterernährt,
dass er kaum sprechen konnte. Also das ist die Realität hier und nochmal auf Zahlen gebracht.
Zu Beginn des Krieges gab es in Gaza 3412 Akutkrankenhausbetten.
Das sind 1,5 Betten pro 1000 Menschen, verglichen mit 7,3 pro 1000 Menschen in der Ukraine.
Also das war schon zu Beginn schlecht. Nach der weitgehenden Zerstörung der
Krankenhäuser am Gazastreifen gibt es nur noch rund 1400 Akutkrankenhausbetten
für 2,2 Millionen Menschen.
Von denen mehr als 88.000 in den letzten acht Monaten durch militärische Waffen
schwer verletzt wurden.
Sie reisen nach zwei Wochen wieder ab und es haben dann noch einen Patienten,
Isra, da heißt es dann, es ist unmöglich Gaza in Würde zu verlassen,
als wir Isras Pfleger an ein Team kanadischer Orthopäden übergeben,
fleht sie ihre amerikanischen Ärzte an, sie nicht im Stich zu lassen,
wir betäuben sie mit Ketamin, um einen letzten Verbandswechsel vorzulesen und
schlichen uns dann davon. von. Ja.
So, und jetzt gibt es ein Engagement von 40 Unis in Deutschland,
um hier einzugreifen und zu helfen.
Und die Bundesregierung, Annalena Baerbock, sagt, nee.
Dieses Risiko gehe ich jetzt nicht ein. Es könnten Terroristen unter den Eltern sein.
Das ist einfach absurd. Das ist wirklich absurd. Das ist nicht zu verstehen.
Und ich will es mal wie folgt sagen.
In 70 Jahren wird es auch hier in Deutschland Publizisten geben,
die sagen, ich habe damals in Gaza 50 Mitglieder meiner Familie verloren.
So wie Michel Friedman das heute über den Holocaust sagt.
Das sind so diese Ereignisse. Klar kann man das immer noch größer denken und
so, aber in der Dramatik des Einzelfalls und in der Häuferung ist das hier wirklich schlimm.
Und das ist dann eine völlig verquere Debatte, wenn man jetzt sagt,
was kann man mit was vergleichen und so weiter.
Ich finde auch ehrlich gesagt, diese Debatte mit Genozid oder so,
das mag vielleicht auf der völkerrechtlichen Ebene relevant sein.
Ich finde, hier muss es nur um eine konkrete Frage gehen, wie kann man das Leiden
der Menschen in Gaza verhindern oder beziehungsweise wie kann man es stoppen?
Verhindern ist ja jetzt schon gar nicht mehr möglich.
Was kann man also tun? Wie kann man helfen? Das ist die humanitäre Angelegenheit,
vor der sich niemand drücken darf.
Da kann auch niemand sagen, ja, aber da waren pro Hamas Demos an irgendeiner Berliner Uni.
Das interessiert in dem Zusammenhang nicht. Das ist ein völlig anderes Tara.
Das kann man nicht irgendwie zusammenbringen. Das wird aber die ganze Zeit so
gemacht, dass man sagt, oh, oh, jetzt aber nicht so weit.
Dann würde ich sagen, nein, das ist ein ganz konkretes Leid.
Und da würde ich sagen, weil wir immer hier bei diesen ganzen Militärgipfeln
jetzt sagen, und Putin sieht das, das hier sieht die Weltöffentlichkeit.
Und die sieht ganz genau, was Deutschland da jetzt nämlich gerade macht. Nichts.
Dieser globale Süden, der uns in Anführungszeichen in der Ukraine so im Stich
lässt mit seiner Sympathiebekundungen und was auch immer.
Ja, kein Wunder. Also wirklich kein Wunder.
Wo es auch keine Debatte gibt, ist eigentlich noch verrückter.
Mittelstreckenraketen. Wir bekommen es hier mal aufbereitet von Tagesschau24.
Oberst Wolfgang Richter ist zu Gast und schätzt die Lage ein.
Darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit Wolfgang Richter, ehemaliger Oberst.
Ja, also natürlich sehen wir schon seit einiger Zeit eine Entwicklung,
die zurückführt in die Konfrontation.
Und dieses Anzeichen dieser bilateralen Vereinbarung, die wir gestern gesehen
haben, deutet darauf hin, dass die Konfrontation tiefer wird,
dass sie auch länger andauern wird.
Trotzdem gibt es einige Unterschiedlichkeiten, wenn man das jetzt vergleicht,
etwa mit der Debatte, die während des Nachrüsterungsbeschlusses 1979 geführt wurde.
Wir haben erstens gar keine innenpolitische Debatte gehabt bisher,
was natürlich erstaunlich ist. Das ist also bis jetzt zumindest eine Exekutiventscheidung.
Das zweite ist, es geht nicht um Nuklearwaffen, es geht um konventionelle Waffen.
Und das dritte ist, es geht hier um eine bilaterale Vereinbarung und nicht,
bis jetzt zumindest, nicht um eine Bündnisentscheidung.
Und das ist schon erstaunlich.
Eine Exekutiventscheidung halt.
Haben die irgendwie ausgemacht? Haben wir alle nichts vermittelt?
Niemand weiß wer.
Noch nicht mal im NATO-Bündnis ist es kommuniziert worden, was die Franzosen
nicht sonderlich freut.
Mit dieser Bewaffnung ist es zwar aktuell so vorgesehen, dass es nicht mit Atomwaffen
geht, aber dann sagen manche, naja, so grundsätzlich könnte man es schon machen.
Also da spricht nichts dagegen.
Wir hören mal, warum das vielleicht jetzt noch so schnell passiert ist.
Aber es gibt einen Satz in der Vereinbarung, die auch darauf hindeutet,
dass es einen anderen Zweck gibt, nämlich die Verpflichtung der USA gegenüber
Europa deutlich zu machen.
Und das in einer Zeit, in der zumindest die Möglichkeit besteht,
dass ein neuer Präsident Trump ans Ruder kommt und möglicherweise dann solche
Entscheidungen nicht mehr treffen würde.
Das sind die absurdesten Sachen, die ich höre hier in Europa,
vor allem in Deutschland.
Ja, das wird so ein bisschen Trump-sicher gemacht, wo man sich denkt,
nee, ihr habt die Dimension nicht verstanden.
Nichts ist hier Trump-sicher. Ja. Als ob das nicht alles, das sind doch alles
nur organisatorische Abläufe, da wird halt ein Verfahren geändert.
Naja, die Sache ist, man kann ja sagen, es ist insofern Trump-sicher,
wenn dies erstmal stationiert ist.
Nichts ist Trump-sicher.
Naja gut, Trump kann, es ist bis 26, also bis dahin kann natürlich,
wenn Trump dann Präsident wäre, das wieder zurückdrehen. Erstens das, wenn er es geliefert.
Wenn und selbst wenn sie schon geliefert wären, wenn er mit Putin Vereinbarungen
trifft über was auch immer, dann sind die Raketen dann nicht mehr da.
Also es ist einfach, wie auch immer. Nichts ist Trump sicher.
Das ist eine interessante Sache, dass du jetzt schon die Raketen,
wir kommen nämlich darauf gleich, wir hören auch gleich Norbert Walter-Borjans dazu.
Nochmal Richter, was bedeutet das denn eigentlich, wenn jetzt hier diese US-Raketen stationiert sind?
Naja, ich erwarte schon, dass es hier noch einmal Rückfragen gibt,
dass es möglicherweise eine größere parlamentarische Diskussion zu der Frage gibt.
Denn es gibt ja strategische Konsequenzen, die sich daraus ergeben.
Das Erste ist einmal, dass damit Waffen in Deutschland stationiert werden,
zum ersten Mal, muss ich sagen, seit 1992, mit denen man tief in das russische
Territorium hineinwirken kann.
Man kann sehr präzise, zwar nicht nuklear, aber heute eben sehr präzise Ziele,
auch strategische Ziele in Russland treffen.
Die Reichweite reicht bis über Moskau hinaus und das hat natürlich einen Einfluss
auf die Frage des strategischen Gleichgewichtes zwischen den USA und Russland.
So wird es Russland sehen.
Deswegen wird Russland wahrscheinlich auch Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen.
Also das Wettrüsten läuft, es nimmt an Fahrt auf und wir wissen von dir,
Stefan, dass du immer wieder darauf verwiesen hast, die Atombombe wird sie dann
geworfen, könnte Stuttgart treffen. Ja.
Vielleicht ist es nicht Stuttgart, aber relativ nah dran.
Erklären Sie uns vielleicht mal ganz nüchtern, welches Risiko geht Deutschland
konkret mit dieser Verhandlungsposition oder dieser Stationierung der Waffen ein?
Das erste Risiko ist rein militärisch. Wenn es zu einem Konflikt mit Russland
kommt, wird man natürlich versuchen, aus russischer Sicht diese Waffen zunächst
mal als Ziele auszuschalten.
Nun sind es bewegliche Waffen, die wahrscheinlich in einem Konfliktfall oder
noch im Vorfeld dann eben auch zerstreut werden.
Also man versucht sie dann auch zu tarnen, zu decken oder irgendwo beweglich
zu positionieren, sodass sie nicht gleich getroffen werden.
Aber gleichwohl, es gibt ja Kommandobehörden, die sogenannte Multidomain-Taskforce
hat ihren Sitz bereits in Wiesbaden und das ist natürlich dann ein erstrangiges Ziel.
Also wissen das die Wiesbadener?
Ja, Wiesbaden ist uncool, das ist nämlich relativ nah hier.
Ja, also muss man in Wiesbaden dann sagen, ihr seid übrigens jetzt erstrangiges
Ziel. Es gibt keine gesellschaftliche Debatte, es gibt nichts im Bundestag dazu.
Wir wissen auch nicht, wer nach Putin regiert oder wie das da weitergeht,
weil er Entscheidungen trifft.
Ja, können wir auch noch überreden, wer da regieren könnte.
Also das ist wirklich absurd, dass man das selbst verstehen lässt.
Die Vorhandenheit dazu ist von Farin Urlaub, von den Ärzten,
der ja Farin Urlaub heißt, weil er die ganze Zeit in der Welt unterwegs ist.
Und er auf die Frage, ja und hast du eine Pistole dabei? Und er so,
nein, Stahl zieht Stahl an.
Solange ich keine habe, haben die anderen auch keine.
Ja, sehr gut. Und es ist auch strategisch vielleicht nicht besonders klug.
Das andere ist, dass man hier eingreift in die strategische Balance und das
wird natürlich auch die Gespräche, die ja zwischen den USA und Russland immer
noch geführt werden, wie das strategische Gleichgewicht aufrechterhalten werden kann, beeinflussen.
Und ich befürchte, sehr negativ beeinflussen.
Und das Dritte ist, dass alle Gespräche, die bisher noch von einem Moratorium
für die Stationierung von Mittelstreckenwaffen ausgingen, damit auch tot sind.
Das heißt, das ist wirklich der letzte Sargnagel auf den INF-Vertrag.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle Beteiligten. Solche Turbulenzen sind genau das
Richtige. Das braucht man.
Wenn wir nicht wissen, wer wo wann wie regiert.
Ja, ja, also es gibt ja solche Szenarien. Das wurde ja auch von,
das war Christopher McCallion und Benjamin H.
Friedman auch in Politico erschienen, wo sie mal sagen, naja,
wo eigentlich eine Gefahr steht, also mit, wenn Putin wirklich…,
Wenn da jemand neuer Machthaber kommt, dann könnte das jemand sein,
der so irre ist, wie die und die, da werden da Beispiele genannt.
Und dann ist es wirklich, dann brauchen wir nicht mehr über,
naja, werden die uns nuklear weiter erpressen oder so, sondern da wird man auch
einfach mal gucken, wenn es knallt.
Also es ist Wahnsinn, dass man einfach diesen Schritt geht, wir keine große
Debatte haben, sondern nur jetzt irgendwie so Jusos bei Twitter einem nochmal
erklären, dass nun mal Russland die Bedrohung ist.
Und dann denke ich, ja danke, das habe ich jetzt inzwischen verstanden.
Nur ist das eine kluge Strategie und Norbert Walter-Borjans,
der dagegen ist, war im Deutschlandfunk zu Gast und hat auf eigentlich etwas
sehr Gutes hingewiesen, nämlich darauf.
Erstmal, weil es dieses Jungtim der Androhung im Falle des Nichtverhandelns
gar nicht gibt, sondern es gibt nur die Feststellung, ab 2026 wird nachgerüstet
und verhandeln ist eigentlich im Moment aussichtslos. Das ist ein Unterschied.
Denn das hätte man ja mit in die Waagschale werfen können. Also man kann ja Putin sagen,
wir würden durchaus mal darüber nachdenken, es sei denn, du setzt dich jetzt
mal mit Zelensky ins Benehmen und du gehst mal von deinen Maximalforderungen ab.
Denn sonst könnten wir auch mal US-Raketen da stationieren. Das heißt,
man könnte ja wirklich damit arbeiten.
Im besten Falle wird das gerade in die Waagschale reingelegt,
damit man es danach wieder rausnehmen kann, wenn man ein Gespräch führt.
Nur wie er es darauf hinweist, nee, es werden gerade gar keine Gespräche führen.
Nicht nur reden wir nicht mit dem Feind gerade in Anführungszeichen,
sondern wir reden auch nicht mit uns.
Hier wird auch niemand Bescheid gesagt. Also mit Macron wurde ja auch darüber
nicht geredet, was ja auch wieder interessant ist.
Diese Bundesregierung ist, was das angeht, also sowohl, Pistorius,
wir haben ja diese Clips gehört, Trump, der ist ja noch nicht mal Kandidat und
so, das wird schon, das wird schon.
Und jetzt hier, ach, mit Macron darüber reden, keine Ahnung,
nee, können wir ja später...
Das ist nicht gut.
Und wir müssen auch nochmal geografisch darüber nachdenken. Ja,
sagen ja viele, aber Russland hat ja auch solche Raketen stationiert. Ja, aber wo?
Wir haben jetzt eben gehört, Wiesbaden.
Aller tief dicht bevölkert. Stefanie an Frankfurt überlegt auch schon, wie das so weitergeht.
Mir ist das zu nah.
In Russland sind die ja woanders.
Vielleicht senkt das die Mietpreise in Wiesbaden.
Möglich.
Und der zweite Punkt, der eben im Kalten Krieg auch nicht funktioniert hat und
Anfang der 80er Jahre viele Menschen auf die Straße getrieben hat, ist,
dass Abschreckung zwischen den beiden damaligen Supermächten,
solange sie damit verbunden war, dass jeder rechnen musste,
selbst Ziel zu werden, vielleicht funktioniert hat.
Aber dass damals der Schritt gegangen wurde, dass die Interessen der USA ein
Stück auf das Schlachtfeld Europa ausgelagert werden und das jetzt von Russland
mit der Einbeziehung dieses extraterritorialen Gebiets Kaliningrad genauso gehandhabt wird.
Das heißt, wir haben eine Minderung in dieser Abschreckungswirkung,
weil in Wirklichkeit diejenigen, die da im Streit miteinander liegen,
gar nicht die Ziele sind eines möglichen Entgleisens.
Und das bedeutet auch, dieses Kaliningrad ist über 1000 Kilometer von Moskau
entfernt. Das heißt, da etwas auszuschalten, dünn besiedelt, ist das eine.
Also das Drohpotenzial funktioniert gar nicht, also es ist nicht symmetrisch.
Man kann nicht sagen, die stehen sich jetzt so genau gegenüber,
sondern da ist einmal das dicht bevölkerte Wiesbaden und Deutschland generell, ja,
und dann ist da irgendwo in Russland nochmal so extraterritorial,
hat der die Raketen stationiert. Das sind zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe.
So wie ich ihn jetzt verstanden habe, ist sein Szenario irgendwann,
sagen wir mal, Trump regiert, 2027, kriegt so einen Anruf, macht das und das
und wir machen Wiesbaden platt und er fragt, was, Wiesbaden kenne ich nicht, keine Ahnung, ciao.
Sprungsszenario ist leider nicht gegeben, weil sich der amerikanische Präsident
nicht für Wiesbaden interessiert. Die Idee, da Waffen zu installieren, war ein Fehler.
Wir haben ja beide den Oppenheimer Film gesehen. Du weißt doch,
dass da darüber gesprochen wird, wo kann man die Atombomben abwerfen und dann
ist das glaube ich der Verteidigungsminister oder sogar der Präsident.
Also es geht um die Frage, ob man es Tokio nehmen sollte.
Nee, da habe ich eine Hochzeitsreise gemacht, das war so schön.
Und das ist das Argument dafür, dass man Wenn man die nicht auf Tokio abwirft,
sagt man, da war es immer schön.
So, und Trump war vielleicht in Wiesbaden.
Das wäre auf Kyoto gefallen.
Auf Kyoto, ja.
Ich habe jetzt, wo ja ein bisschen Podcast-Pause ist bei vielen,
gedacht, ich höre mal in andere Sachen rein.
Ist ja langweilig, hast du zu wenig Podcasts gerade? Nein, nein. Fehlen dir Podcasts?
Ein bisschen. Also Paul Ronzheimer, Bild-Zeitung.
Also wir haben ja uns auch schon mehrmals zu ihm geäußert. Ich will jetzt auch
nicht hier eine Lanze fehlen brechen.
Ich will aber sagen, dass nachdem wir mal dieses Talkshow-Debakel vorgeführt
haben, wie Fragen gestellt werden und der ganze Umgang mit den Gästen ist,
würde ich sagen, dass man bei Paul Ronsheimer natürlich immer die Stoßrichtung weiß.
Ja, es ist Springer und wir wissen auch, Paul Ronsheimer ist für Waffenlieferungen und, und, und, und.
Aber Paul Ronsheimer ist auch erkenntnisinteressiert. Das ist ja etwas Und er reist.
Er sitzt nicht nur an seinem Schreibtisch. Und ich habe einfach mal so einige
Folgen runtergeladen und dann war dort ein Wall-Street-Journalist zu Gast.
Wall-Street-Journal-Journalist zu Gast, nämlich Bojan Jan Pantschewski,
Ronsheimer und er kennen sich seit über zehn Jahren, haben sich wo kennengelernt?
Natürlich in der Ukraine.
Sind also ganz tief beide in der Materie drin. Und ich dachte,
ah ja, jetzt kommt bestimmt so ein übliches Gespräch.
Wann kommen denn die Taurus-Lieferungen oder so? Natürlich das komplette Gegenteil
passiert dann und deswegen habe ich diese Clips jetzt mal mitgebracht.
Also aufhorchen.
Wenn du mit den Kontakten, die du auch gesammelt hast, in der Ukraine sprichst,
was ist dein Eindruck, was ist der ukrainische Plan momentan?
Gibt es überhaupt einen Plan? Das ist natürlich schwierig.
Die Bereitschaft bei der Bevölkerung, Verhandlungen zu akzeptieren,
war relativ niedrig, eine sehr, sehr lange Zeit.
Jetzt anscheinend ändert sich das. Es gibt eine unveröffentlichte Studie,
die nach der so fast 60 Prozent der Befragten Verhandlungen akzeptieren würden.
Jetzt sagen aber viele, Zelensky will halt nicht.
Die Ukrainer, der ukrainischen Führung, ich glaube, denen ist es ganz klar bewusst,
dass sie bald verhandeln werden müssen oder zumindest anfangen.
Der Zelensky hat selber gesagt, neulich in einem Interview mit Bloomberg,
dass man jetzt direkt mit den Russen verhandeln könnte.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie wir in Deutschland so eine Diskussion hätten,
wenn nach zweieinhalb Jahren Krieg es hieße, die Lausitz muss jetzt an Polen,
sonst haben wir ja nie wieder Frieden.
Wie viele Leute in Baden-Württemberg, NRW und Niedersachsen würden sagen,
Lausitz, ich dachte, das ist Polen.
Ist doch egal. Klar wollen wir verhandeln. Was heißt verhandeln? Wir kapitulieren.
Lausitz weg damit. Also diese Ost-Ukraine wird, so wie ich das verstanden habe,
ja auch so ein bisschen unter diesem, wir haben ja der Osten.
Ja, ja, ja.
Es läuft so unter dem Label Osten.
Natürlich, natürlich. Und es ist interessant, dass hier unterhalten sich ja Leute.
Die… Ich beschimpfe sehr fiese Kommentare. Ich sitze hier so lässig mit verschränkten
Armen und sage das so. Die Lausitz. Aber die Lausitz, ja.
Ja, also ich mache mir das hier nicht so ein. Ich will das deutlich unterstreichen.
Ich trete ja auch hin und wieder noch.
Ich mache auch nur Szenarioplanung. Ich habe nur für den Fall das und so weiter.
Würden wir akzeptieren, den Einberufungsbefehl, um die Lausitz zu verteidigen?
Also nein, ich würde die Lausitz auch nicht mit Leib und Leben verteidigen,
aber auch Koblenz nicht.
Aber du bist natürlich hier immer auf deinem Trip. Ich sitze in meinem Frankfurt.
Einmal im Jahr fahre ich noch nach Bielefeld rüber, besuche die Lehmann, die Luhmann.
Apologeten und das war es dann.
Genau. Perfekt einfach.
Ich bin ja ein bisschen mehr auch in Deutschland in der Breite unterwegs.
Wir hören jetzt nochmal, wie ist denn das mit Zelensky? Also ich finde das so unterstaunlich.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Leute, denen man nicht in irgendeiner Weise unterstellen
kann, dass die Kreml-nah sind oder so.
Also das ist ja hier immer der erste Verdacht, der kommt, wenn jemand solche
Sätze von sich gibt. Wir hören mal weiter.
Da ging es um den Schweizer Gipfel, wo ja keine russischen Vertreter dabei waren
und Selensky wurde in diesem Interview danach gefragt.
Und er hat, glaube ich, angedeutet, dass bei einem weiteren Format dann russische
Vertreter dabei sein können.
Eben, und so ein weiteres Format soll anscheinend in Saudi-Arabien stattfinden.
Und so wie ich höre, der Selensky hat die Saudis gebeten, das zu organisieren
und eventuell auch russische Vertreter dahin einzuladen.
Selenskyy bittet die Saudis, das mal zu organisieren, dass dann auch Russland
daran teilnimmt. Das heißt,
Geht nicht über eine Demokratie, die das jetzt organisiert. Du weißt,
wenn Deutschland das jetzt organisieren würde, würde Baerbock sagen,
man kann mit einem Kriegsverbrecher wie Putin nicht verhandeln, aus.
Und deswegen machen wir einfach nochmal so eine große Show. Das heißt,
Zelensky wendet sich jetzt bewusst nicht an die Demokraten der westlichen Welt.
Wir werden das nachher noch steigern, aber wir behalten das schon mal im Hinterkopf.
Wir reden ja morgen über ein Buch von Ingolf Fuhr-Blüdern, Unhaltbarkeit,
wie unhaltbar ist denn eigentlich die Demokratie?
Und wir sehen jetzt ja gerade, dass ganz viel gemacht wird, wo die Demokratien
zwar irgendwelche Werte artikulieren, ihnen dann oft selbst gar nicht treu bleiben,
in Bezug auf Gaza ist das deutlich geworden,
aber wir sehen auch, dass einfach die Demokratie da gar nicht gefragt wird,
sondern man fragt die Saudis.
Nun, wie geht es dann gerade an der Front voran?
Also ist es nicht so, dass die Ukrainer momentan an der Front selbst Fortschritte machen würden?
Also sie verlieren zwar nicht Massivgebiete, aber sie verlieren Dörfer.
Stück für Stück verlieren sie, natürlich. Aber diese Tendenz gibt es schon seit über einem Jahr.
Das Problem ist, dass es nicht so richtig berichtet wurde in der westlichen
Presse, weil man halt, man wünscht sich vielleicht was anderes.
Erstaunlich, ne? Es wird jetzt einfach mal gesagt, ja, da wurde gar nicht so
gerne drüber berichtet. Man hat sich was anderes gewünscht.
Ehrlicherweise gibt es ja gerade so gar keinen Diskurs, oder? Irgendwo.
Nee, nur noch so abstrakt, aber gar nicht mehr. Also Frontverläufe,
ja, das wird hin und wieder noch aufgegriffen.
Es gibt diesen MDR-Podcast.
Ja.
Mit dem General. Ja. Aber ansonsten, ja.
Hin und wieder ist der Oberst Reisner irgendwo eingeladen.
Zum Beispiel in diesem MDR-Podcast.
Ja. Und der schildert das ja dann auch sehr klar, wie es verläuft.
Ja, und es wird nicht besser.
Die Analyse ist ja überall, dass es nur noch schlimmer werden könnte.
Ich habe mit vielen Militäroffizieren hier gesprochen und auch aber im Westen,
ich war in Washington neulich.
Ich habe ja mit keinem so richtig gesprochen, der oder die meinte,
dass die Ukrainer wieder eine Chance hätten, im großen Stil Territorium zu erobern.
Das glaubt kaum ein Mensch mehr.
Und das ist doch eine ungeheure Aussage, die sich auch damit deckt,
was auch wieder Springer in der Welt zu lesen war. Christoph B.
Schilz hat einen Artikel verfasst, da heißt es, Militärs und Diplomaten von
EU und NATO beobachten die Entwicklung auf dem Kriegsschauplatz in der Ukraine
schon seit Monaten mit zunehmender Sorge.
Öffentlich wird darüber nicht gesprochen, um die Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung
des Westens nicht zu schwächen und die ukrainischen Soldaten in ihrem Verteidigungskampf
gegen Russland nicht zu demotivieren.
Das heißt, man macht sich Illusionen oder macht denen etwas vor.
Hier, Welt hat zahlreiche Gespräche über die weitere Entwicklung in der Ukraine geführt.
Die Gesprächspartner wollten namentlich nicht genannt werden.
Nicht ein einziger Diplomat oder Militärvertreter erwartet, dass die Ukraine
ihr selbst gestecktes Ziel erreichen wird, die seit 2014 durch Russland völkerrechtswidrig
annektierte Halbinsel Krim zurückzuerobern.
Biden und Scholz haben Angst vor einer Eskalation.
Das wird auch nochmal von diesen Leuten bestätigt. Man hat vor nuklearen Schlägen
Angst und zwar in zweifacher Hinsicht.
Einmal, Putin könnte taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen.
Das wäre ein Horror-Szenario.
Atomwaffen taktisch einsetzen. Ja.
Zweites Szenario, noch schlimmer. Die russische Föderation könnte zerfallen.
Dann steht hier 6000 russische Atomsprengköpfe.
Geraten damit in die Hände von Terroristen und blutrünstigen Diktatoren wie
dem Tschetschenenanführer Ramzan Kadyrov.
Da freut man quasi noch mehr Angst, dass so etwas passieren könnte. Und ich denke, zu Recht.
Und deswegen, weil ich eben so sagte, na, vielleicht werden wir beiden nochmal vermissen oder so.
Wir wissen noch nicht, wie Kamala Harris so drauf ist. Ich finde diese Geprächtlichkeit,
die aber auch mit einer Besonnenheit einhergeht von beiden, Ganz gut und hat
ja auch funktioniert mit Scholz zusammen.
Wir hören jetzt Panczewski auch zu diesem Krankenhaus, das angegriffen wurde.
Nur um das kurz zu machen, das habe ich jetzt nicht alles geklippt.
Seine These ist, dass die Waffen nicht besonders präzise sind der Russen,
dass es also durchaus sein könnte, dass sie ein militärisches Gebäude treffen wollten.
Aber generell sei es natürlich so, dass Putin auf diese Weise auch die Zivilbevölkerung tyrannisiert.
Und Pantschewski hat folgende Überlegung dazu.
Er sendet auch keine Zeichen, dass er irgendwie verhandeln will,
denn ich meine, wir haben jetzt erlebt, dieser Angriff auf das Kinderkrankenhaus,
gewollt oder ungewollt, aber dieser Einsatz,
der sagt ja auch etwas aus.
Also wenn jetzt Putin tatsächlich gedacht hätte nach dem Gespräch mit Orban,
Mensch, ja, irgendwie, ich will diesen Krieg auch beenden, dann wäre das sicherlich
nicht das Zeichen gewesen, das man sendet, oder? Oder doch.
Also wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, glaube ich schon, dass er Angst und Schrecken
verbreiten will, damit die Bevölkerung halt irgendwie mal einen politischen
Druck ausübt auf die Führung, damit die überhaupt verhandeln wollen.
Weil lange Zeit war ja die Sache, dass die Ukrainer und vor allem der Präsident
nicht verhandeln wollten.
Ja, es geht ein bisschen so in diese Richtung, dass sie sagen,
ja jetzt, also bevor hier noch weiter.
Lausitz okay, aber nicht Wiesbaden.
Ja, ganz genau. Also das ist diese Überlegung hier.
Er spricht auch von den Geheimdiensten. Es ist wirklich interessant,
weil man hier zwei Journalisten hat, die ja richtig tief drin sind.
Das ist ja nicht so wie bei, manche haben mal so den Eindruck,
die fahren schon mal nach Kiew, interviewen da die Baerbock oder den Steinmeier
und fahren wieder zurück und sagen dann, ich habe die Ukraine gesehen.
Aber hier sind ja Leute wirklich ganz, ganz dicht dran.
Und auch, ich wollte noch sagen, ich höre ja was anderes. Also ich habe schon gehört in Washington,
dass über gewissen geheimdienstlichen Kanälen zum Beispiel,
und das sind die üblichen Kanäle, mit denen man kommuniziert mit den Russen
heutzutage, dass die schon Signale abgesendet haben und vermehrt und regelmäßig,
dass sie doch auch verhandeln wollen.
Und wir erinnern uns, wir haben, das ist jetzt, ja, lange, lange her,
ich glaube über anderthalb Jahre her, haben wir über Mark Milley gesprochen.
Ich glaube, das war dann Herbst 2022.
Wir haben ja häufiger über ihn gesprochen.
Ja, also wir haben ausführlich mal Clips, wo er auf so einem Dinner eigentlich
zu Gast war und da so ein längeres Interview gab, das jetzt eigentlich das Fenster
für Verhandlungen wäre. Und das hat man… Naja.
Also ich rekapituliere, was ich noch weiß. Er hatte damals darüber gesprochen,
dass es diese alten und die neuen Kriege gibt und wir immer die Idee haben,
dass es jetzt neue Kriege sind, aber nein, es ist alles wie Verdun oder so.
Wenn der Krieg einmal läuft, liegt man in seinem Schützengraben und verteidigt den Kameraden.
Und jetzt hören wir Bojan Paszewski.
Also am Anfang haben sie natürlich eine relativ positive Entwicklung gehabt
an der Front, am Schlachtfeld.
Und dann gab es diese, die haben kulminiert sozusagen mit der Zurückeroberung,
mit der Befreiung von Kherson, die Stadt im Süden.
Und da, wenn du dich erinnerst, der damalige Oberbefehlshaber der Vereinigten
Staaten, General Mark Milley, hat öffentlich gesagt, jetzt ist die Zeit zu verhandeln,
weil besser wird es nicht mehr. Das ist halt ihr Höhepunkt.
Und es stellt sich jetzt heraus, fast zwei Jahre später, dass er recht hatte.
Das war der Höhepunkt. Und seitdem, so ist es halt mal.
Ja, und zwei Jahre ist weiter gestorben worden. auf beiden Seiten und eigentlich
hätte man auf Millie hören sollen.
Wie ist das denn jetzt mit der NATO? Können wir die erweitern für die Ukraine?
McCallion und Friedman haben in Politico gesagt, dass man der Ukraine falsche
Hoffnung macht, dass man so tut, als würde man die Ukraine aufnehmen.
Sie sagen ganz klar, das wird niemals passieren.
Sie sehen auch eine große Gefahr der Eskalation jetzt, gerade weil es so vertrackt alles ist.
Sie schreiben, in den letzten Wochen hat die Ukraine bereits ihre eigenen einheimischen
Fähigkeiten eingesetzt, um russische Radarstationen zu treffen,
die im Falle eines amerikanischen Atomangriffs eine Frühwarnung geben sollen.
Und im vergangenen Monat schlug die Submunition einer von den USA gelieferten
Rakete, die von ukrainischen Streitkräften abgefeuert wurde,
auf zivile Strandbesucher in Sevastopol auf der Krim ein,
nachdem sie wahrscheinlich von der russischen Luftabwehr abgefangen worden war.
Diese Ereignisse geben Anlass zu großer Besorgnis, ein Angriff auf die Frühwarnsysteme
untergräbt das Vertrauen Russlands in seine Fähigkeit,
im Falle eines nuklearen Erstschlags der USA zu reagieren und erhöht damit das
Risiko eines russischen Nuklearschlags.
Wahrscheinlicher ist jedoch, dass Moskau auf die Angriffe auf seinem Boden,
bei denen von den USA bereitgestellte Waffen zum Einsatz kommen,
mit der Suche nach Möglichkeiten reagieren wird, die USA oder ihre Helfer direkt anzugreifen.
Und sie sagen auch, Analysten, die sich als Befürworter der Ukraine verstehen.
Betonen oft, dass der Westen einer nuklearen Erpressung nicht nachgeben dürfe,
weil eine Eskalation zu einem Atomkrieg unwahrscheinlich sei.
Die korrekte Bezeichnung für nukleare Erpressung lautet jedoch nukleare Abschreckung.
Und dazu muss man nicht sicher sein, dass es zu einer Katastrophe kommt,
sondern nur befürchten, dass sie eintreten könnte.
Diese Kommentatoren scheinen zu glauben, dass unsere Fähigkeit,
Russland abzuschrecken, uns von der Last befreit, von ihnen abgeschreckt zu werden.
Also so funktioniert es natürlich. Natürlich.
Und ich frage mich auch, wenn jetzt tatsächlich irgendwo mal so eine Atombombe
explodiert, ob dann einfach nur neun Monate ins Land gehen und dann irgendwer
kommentiert, naja, so schlimm war es jetzt auch nicht.
Der Radius ist 50 Kilometer, aber nicht 500, irgendwie so. Es ist wirklich brenzlig.
Naja, wir haben jetzt ja eben wirklich sehr anschaulich beschrieben,
wie man einfach bei Gaza wegguckt und sagt, das muss aber jetzt sein, wegen des 7.
Oktobers und dann kann natürlich auch sein, dass man sagt, ja,
aber das ist natürlich schade um das Städtchen da, das da getroffen wurde und
von dort sollte man auch lieber kein Gemüse importieren.
Also diese Stadt dann zum allerersten Mal hören, dass sie existiert hat?
Ja, also Wiesbaden soll es dann nicht sein. Ich denke, das wäre schlecht.
Ich gehe da auch zu gern in die Oper.
Wie sieht er das jetzt mit der NATO?
Der NATO-Gipfel ist ja auch kein Denk für die Ukraine, weil die Ukraine kommt
nicht in die Allianz, die wird nicht so richtig eingeladen.
Der Biden hat selber gesagt neulich vor einem Monat oder zwei Monaten,
dass er Ukraine in NATO nicht haben will.
Der hat das irgendwie auch komisch formuliert. Der meinte, keine NATO-isierung
von Ukraine werde er je akzeptieren.
Im Grunde genommen, das sagt der Trump auch.
Also die Aussichten sind da klar. Ja, wir wissen ja auch, wie der Bundeskanzler
denkt, der will ja Ukraine auch nicht in die Allianz als Mitglied.
Ja, und der Westen hat eigentlich keinen Plan, meint er.
Wie gesagt, die haben keinen Plan, die haben negative Aussagen von der Zukunft.
Also die beiden Regierungen und die westlichen Regierungen insgesamt sagen,
wir werden nicht zulassen, dass Putin gewinnt. Wir werden so lange die Ukraine
unterstützen, wie es nötig ist.
Wir werden halt die Ukraine nicht drängen zu verhandeln, aber wenn sie zur Verhandlung
bereit sind, dann gut ist.
Tja, oje, das klingt aber wirklich...
Und wie sieht es mit Trump aus?
Alleine durch die Tatsache, dass das eine neue Regierung sein würde,
wenn sie dann mal die Wahl gewinnen, haben sie ein kleines Bonus,
dass die vielleicht mehr exekutive Macht haben.
Und es ist fast kaum vorzustellen, dass eine amerikanische Regierung weniger
exekutive Macht haben könnte als die beiden Regierungen momentan.
Also insofern, vielleicht kann man nur hoffen, dass in der Zukunft neue Ideen
hineinkommen in diesem System von westlicher Unterstützung der Ukraine.
Also das, ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal beschrieben, das Szenario.
Trump, die haben sich so lustig gemacht darüber, wie Biden aus Afghanistan abgezogen ist.
Ja.
Dass Trump genau einen Plan hat, wenn ich hier gewählt werde,
werde ich meinen Wählern, die absolut nirgendwo Kriege wollen,
anbieten, dass es eine Feierstunde gibt.
Ich und Putin. Handschlag.
Ausverkauf von allem. Hauptsache Weltfrieden. Er wird sich als den großen Weltfrieden präsentieren.
Aber das Ausverkauf, er ist ja ein Businessman. Wir müssen schon verstehen.
Dass Trump… Wir werden Putin schon noch ausquetschen und so.
Jaja, also Trump hat keine NATO-Liebe vielleicht oder keine besondere Liebe
zu Deutschland, aber er weiß ja auch schon, dass die NATO durchaus den USA hilft.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die NATO einfach nur ein Gottesgeschenk ist an die
Europäer, sondern dieses Bündnis hat ja seinen Sinn für die Amerikaner auch.
Aber es ist für die Europäer noch viel alternativloser als für die,
für die es eigentlich gestaltet wurde, Amerika. In der Hinsicht würde es so
eine Friss oder Stirb-Anzeige sein.
Nur ich glaube, dass man, Ronsheimer argumentiert in eine ähnliche Richtung
und fragt deshalb auch nach.
Du teilst nicht die Sorge, die ja viele haben momentan, wenn sie auf den Wahlkampf
schauen und wenn sie in der Ukraine sind oder auch Leute, die mit der Ukraine zu tun haben,
dass sie sagen, dass Trump einfach eiskalt die Ukraine verkaufen könnte und
zu Zelensky sagen könnte, du musst
das jetzt akzeptieren mit diesen vier Regionen und hier ist die Grenze.
Und entweder machst du das, dann unterstützen wir dich weiter.
Also du, meine Meinung ist irrelevant, aber ich glaube nicht mal,
dass Zelensky das glaubt.
Im Gegenteil, ich glaube, Zelensky glaubt langsam, dass Trump bessere Karten hätten.
Das höre ich eben hier in Kiew, dass Trump viel bessere Karten hat. Was hörst du da?
Ich höre schon, dass in der obersten Etage der Regierung beim Zelensky und seinem
Berater langsam sich die Meinung durchsetzt, dass Trump die besseren Karten haben könnte.
Obama war die Ukraine ziemlich egal.
Was ist das für eine komische Hoffnung? An Trump.
Warum? Man muss ja halt nicht vergessen, dass Trump war ja der allererste amerikanische
Präsident, der Waffen in die Ukraine geschickt hat.
Ich glaube, das war im Jahre 2019, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Das hat der Obama nicht gemacht und nicht machen wollen.
Der Obama hat gesagt, die Ukraine ist nicht wichtig für die nationale Sicherheit
Amerikas. Das hat er öffentlich gesagt.
Trump hat anders agiert.
Also dem ist vieles zuzutrauen. Ja, ein schlechter Deal ist,
wenn er dem Putin sagen würde, du kannst die Ukraine umsonst haben.
Das ist, was die meisten Menschen befürchten. Aber das wäre nicht so der in
der Historie von Trump als Politiker wäre das nicht unbedingt, was er will.
Ja, oder? Ich meine, der will ja keine schlechten Deals machen.
Der redet ja die ganze Zeit, dass er gute Deals machen will.
Also er wird gute Deals machen, dass er 2019 als erster amerikanischer Präsident Waffen geliefert hat.
Also ich weiß noch sehr genau, wie 2016 es damals hieß, Obama hat noch schnell
beauftragt und Clinton wird das dann vollziehen. 8.000 Tonnen Militärmaterial
ist verpackt und steht bereit, verschifft zu werden.
Dann hat Trump gewonnen. Diese Pläne sind mit dem Personal einfach sozusagen
in Luft aufgelöst worden.
2019, ja, der Kongress hat der Ukraine 400 Millionen zugestanden,
woraufhin Trump sagte, hier, Zelensky, mach aber für mich diese und jene Schose,
sag bei CNN das jetzt hier irgendwie und so weiter.
Und es hat ihm ein Amtsenthebungsverfahren eingebracht, dass er Zelensky dann
noch erpresst hat und so.
Also, dass Putin, dass Trump da irgendwie auf der ukrainischen Seite steht und
ihn das irgendwie interessiert, nee. Das ist also...
Das glaube ich auch nicht, dass er eigentlich ein Ukraine-Fan ist,
das ist uns nur noch nicht gesagt.
Trump wird vor allem um dieses Signal an seine Wähler gehen,
ich habe für Weltfrieden gesorgt.
Möglicherweise bedeutet das aber für die Europäer, dass er denen sagt, ihr kümmert euch darum.
Genau, wenn ihr weiterkämpfen wollt, macht das. Ich bin der Präsident des Weltfriedens.
Das wird die Ansage sein. Und dann kann man ja mal gucken, wie gut Pistorius
und Macron sich verständigt haben darauf, wie das jetzt weitergeht in der Ukraine.
Oder ob man das dann einfach akzeptiert.
Manche werden es mitbekommen haben.
Viktor Orban, der… Lass uns kurz nur in einem Satz.
Als wir diesen Podcast begonnen haben, Januar 2020, wurde Ursula von der Leyen gerade gewählt.
Sie war damit neue EU-Kommissionspräsidentin, hatte große Vorschläge und so weiter und so fort.
Damals war es aber schon ziemlich knapp. Knapp in diesem ganzen Wahlkampfstress,
den wir jetzt hatten, dieses ganze politische Drama, ist sie mit mehr Stimmen
aus dem Parlament als damals jetzt gewählt worden.
Also das Drama war relativ klein und ich würde sagen, ja man hat sich dann doch
mal so die Sachlage angeschaut und gefragt, wollen wir jetzt echt einen neuen
Kandidaturprozess starten oder nicht.
Also hat man sie gewählt, aber Drama gibt es trotzdem, denn die erste Amtshandlung
von Ursula von der Leyen als jetzt neue Kommissionspräsidentin war ein Boykott
gegen Ungarn, die gerade die Ratspräsidentschaft haben wegen diesen Reisen.
Das ist wirklich bescheuert.
Wir werden ja mit Blünern darüber sprechen, wie weit die Demokratie handlungsfähig ist.
Und wir können uns jetzt alle mal schön ausmalen, wie hätten wir es dann gerne
auf der Welt und wie hätten wir es gerne in Bezug auf den Ukraine-Krieg.
Welchen EU-Kommissionspräsidenten hätten wir denn gerne, wenn wir von den Laien
nicht trauen? Und diese Frage, niemand auf der Straße kann gerade irgendwelche Namen nennen.
Niemand, noch die politisch interessiertesten Leute, haben irgendeine Idee,
was jetzt anders gemacht hätte werden können.
Wenn die bisherige sagt, ich kandidiere nochmal,
Aber in einer Position, bei der selbst die CDU sagt, ja das ist schon schwierig,
ich bin eine schwierige Kandidatin, kommt zwar aus unserer Partei, aber es ist schwierig.
Und die FDP im Parlament geschlossen gegen sie stimmt.
Ja, ja.
Da muss man sagen, ja das sind halt einfach vertragte Zustände,
aber Ursula von der Leyen ist nun mal jetzt Kommissionspräsidentin.
Und die anderen Präsidenten sind die anderen Präsidenten. Das heißt,
ich kann jetzt mir einen Demokratisierungsprozess in Russland wünschen,
der wird aber jetzt morgen nicht eintreten.
Mit China ist es ähnlich, mit anderen Ländern sowieso.
Das heißt, ich kann, wenn ich über die Geopolitik nachdenke,
immer nur mit dem umgehen, das vorhanden ist. Und das ist auch Viktor Orban.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen, ich brauche einen ganz großen Disclaimer.
Aber wir brauchen das hier nicht. Wir haben ein aufgeklärtes Publikum.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht 15 Minuten über antisemitische Wahlkämpfe,
homophobe Politik und all das sprechen.
Wir sagen nur kurz, dass Ungarn an diesem Punkt ist, wo er ist,
hat er auch dem zu verdanken, dass er das Wahlsystem so ein bisschen hingebogen hat.
Sobald da jemand eine gewisse Schwelle von eigentlich nicht Mehrheit überschreitet,
kriegt er gleich mal 60 Parlamentare extra oder sowas und regiert dann einfach durch.
Aber das sind die demokratischen Abläufe, wie sie in Ungarn eben stattfanden
unter dieser medialen Öffentlichkeit, die wir haben.
Da kann man halt, sieht man ja bei Trump auch, die Leute hinters Licht führen.
Und deshalb ist es so gut, jetzt Orban einfach mal zuzuhören.
Ich kenne überhaupt keine längeren Orban-Interviews im deutschen Fernsehen.
Ich weiß, dass er schon mal irgendwo dann gefragt wird und dann geht das meistens
immer um diese Sachen Migrationspolitik oder so.
Und da muss ich aber auch oder ich will es mal anders sagen.
Es gibt durchaus Festreden bei der CSU von Kompagnon.
Das gibt es natürlich, ja. Aber mein Problem ist, glaube ich,
mit diesen ganzen Talkshows ist, dass die Leute das, wenn immer jemand kommt,
Man hat den Eindruck, die Journalisten müssen ihrer Peergroup beweisen,
dass sie jemanden dekonstruieren können.
Ronsheimer muss niemandem beweisen, ob er jemanden dekonstruieren kann.
Er muss jetzt nicht Orban einladen und gucken, ob ich es zum Eklat schaffe.
Mache ich den jetzt wütend? Konfrontiere ich den damit?
Entzaubern.
Entzauber ich ihn? Sollen wir jetzt über homophobere Politik reden?
Nein, er will einfach mal was wissen.
Also Orban ist im Ronsheimer Podcast sogar.
Ist im Ronsheimer Podcast, nachdem er Selensky und Putin getroffen hat.
Erstmal ganz kurz, das nehme ich jetzt vorweg, das kommt eigentlich am Ende
erst des Podcasts, wie ist das Trump, wie ist das, ach nee, das machen wir auch
erst später. Wir gehen eine Reihenfolge durch.
Erstmal die Einschätzung von Orban zum Krieg.
It was in the last seven months, even. the previous period was also very brutal.
So what is ahead of us is far worse than we think now.
Bestätigt hier nochmal was wir an der Westen...
Naja, aber bei EU-Konferenzen zum Thema Hilfspakete, Sanktionen hier und so
weiter, alles blockieren und dann in einem Podcast zu sagen,
dass die Russen aber ganz schön stark auf dem Schlachtfeld sind,
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen verlogen.
Ja, natürlich. Der spricht natürlich mit zwei Zungen, mit gespaltener Zunge, sagt man ja.
The argument from EU politicians would be that a trip like you did to Moscow
would divide the position inside Europe and to show Putin that Europe is not
talking with one voice. Sehr primitiv.
Was ich mache, ist nicht das. Es gibt fünf Hauptaktoren in dieser sehr komplizierten Situation.
Und jetzt habe ich zwei aus den fünf getroffen.
Ukrainians, Russians, then United States, then China, then European Union.
And I will continue to manage to get and collect the opinions,
the positions, the talks, how we can formulate to find a way,
the quickest way to the ceasefire.
Fall stimme ich wirklich komplett komplett überein mit dem, wie das auch kommentiert wurde.
Der ist nach Russland gefahren, hat dann dort gesagt, ich komme ja hier nur
als Ungarns Ministerpräsident und Putin eröffnet die Ansprache mit,
herzlich willkommen Ratspräsident der Europäischen Union Viktor Orban.
Dann haben alle zurückgemeldet, nicht nur spricht er nicht mit uns,
sondern der kennt auch unsere Positionen nicht oder sonstiges,
weil wir ja nicht mit ihm sprechen.
Aber Orban war vorher bei Scholz.
Er war erst bei Scholz, ist dann zu Zelensky und ist dann zu Putin.
Ich finde auch nicht, dass Scholz diese Termine absagen oder Einladungen nicht
aussprechen sollte. Ich finde es gut, wenn alle miteinander reden.
Aber… Ja, die Sache ist doch die, wir können ja jetzt noch 50 Mal unterstreichen,
wie furchtbar Orban ist und ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass Ungarn einen völlig
anderen Ministerpräsidenten hätte.
Nur muss ich ja mit den Gegebenheiten umgehen und muss ja einfach erkennen,
diese EU wird nicht einem demokratischen und liberalen Ansatz entsprechen,
den sich beispielsweise Ursula von der Leyen erträumt.
Und Ursula von der Leyen ist ja auch da selbst mal so, mal so.
Mit Meloni kann sie ja wahnsinnig gut, wo es genauso viele Gründe wäre,
gegen Meloni zu sein, genauso viele Gründe gäbe, wie gegen Orbán zu sein.
Ja, aber in diesem Falle des Ukraine-Kriegs ist doch Europa auf einer Seite.
Die können eh nicht in eine neutrale Verhandlungsposition.
Ja, aber Ihnen geht es ja darum, also wir versuchen es jetzt mal nachzusehen,
also wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt hier nicht angetreten, um zu sagen,
eigentlich ist der Orban doch ein prächtiger Kerl, wir haben es nur nie erkannt.
Ich finde ja auch, wir sollten ihm zuhören.
Ich finde, dass die Idee ist ja folgende, wir haben es ja mit fünf Mächten zu
tun oder sagen wir jetzt, fünf sind involviert, das USA…,
EU, wenn man es mal so als Ganzes sieht, und Ukraine, also demokratisch,
dann haben wir autokratische Staaten mit Russland und China.
Das heißt also, es gibt nicht irgendeine gemeinsame Wertebasis in Bezug auf
Demokratie und wie sollte man die Bevölkerung regieren.
Der Weltkriegscharakter ist schon ganz gut abgebildet in dieser Konstellation.
Und da ist jetzt doch für mich die interessante Frage, wenn Zelensky sagt,
ich würde doch vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken, mit Russland zu verhandeln,
aber das sollen bitte die Saudis organisieren, also nicht Demokraten.
Das soll nicht Ursula von der Leyen mal organisieren, könnte er sie ja auch bitten.
Oder Orban.
Naja, das würde wahrscheinlich schon eher funktionieren, dass Zelensky Orban bittet.
Ja, für mich sind das jetzt so Medienspiele.
Nein, was ich hier doch ganz klar machen will, ist, wir unterscheiden,
wir teilen gerne auf, da ist die demokratische Welt und die wird das regeln.
Wir sehen die ganze Zeit jetzt, dass die demokratischen Staaten es nicht geregelt
bekommen aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Und das Schlimme ist jetzt, dass wir gerade mit so einer Orban-Reise,
die wahrscheinlich gar nicht so unerfolgreich war, wie das gern dargestellt
wird, sehen, wie sich das im Allgemeinen verschiebt.
Und das ist ja auch eine These von Blüthorn, dass wir sehen können,
dass wir eigentlich diese Idee, die mit Demokratie von autonomem Subjekt und
all dem verbunden ist, von einer freiheitlichen Erfahrung und so etwas,
dass das zwar noch als wichtiger Wert die ganze Zeit da ist,
aber dass es auch die ganze Zeit unterminiert wird.
Und wir sehen, wie das unterminiert wird, ja gerade auf einer weltpolitischen
Arena, wo man einfach nicht mehr mit unseren demokratischen Maßstäben arbeitet.
Irgendeinen Blumentopf gewinnen kann, das mag man bedauern und ich bedauere es auch ganz offen,
aber ich würde sagen, dass wir eine Verschiebung haben dahin,
dass immer mehr Weltpolitik auch gemacht wird,
wie ein Orban oder ein Trump es machen und wie geht man damit um?
Warum? Also das ist auch eine große Frage.
Also wir können natürlich jetzt sagen, so wie Ursula von der Leyen,
jetzt wird da wieder irgendwas sanktioniert oder so, aber das sind ja doch alles
sehr hilflose Aktionen, die da in Gang gesetzt werden.
Das ist ja sehr erstaunlich, dass die Hilflosigkeit ist ja enorm groß.
How How the road to the peace starts is that those who are in the war or surrounding
the war would like to have a peace.
Und da spielen jetzt die, die nicht im Krieg sind, eine große Rolle?
If China, United States and Europe would like to have a peace,
it's far easier for the Ukrainians and the Russians to find a solution how to
stop fighting, how to save lives, how to negotiate and find a durable solution.
Da kann man erstmal sagen, ja das wird sicherlich so sein, wenn da von außen
Druck kommt, dann wird man eher dazu bereit sein zu verhandeln.
Das ist ja auch das, was man immer versucht hat mit China, dass man sagt,
der Xi soll mal bitte den Putin einheizen, damit Putin aufhört weiter diesen Krieg zu führen.
Aber jetzt das Szenario ist ja wie folgt, also dieser Krieg beginnt durch den Angriff Russlands. Ja.
Und eigentlich könnte Europa und Amerika das locker abwehren,
wenn sie nicht Widerstände bei sich hätten, die immer wieder da rein torpedieren,
Waffendieferungen, finanzielle Hilfe, was auch immer.
Das ist dann in Europa urban, weil er schon die Hinwendung zur autokratischen
Seite auf der anderen Seite des Krieges macht.
Und der amerikanische Kongress, der auch schon, wir haben hier schon mal eine
Mehrheit und tun schon mal so, als wären wir schon eine Trump-Peske-Autokratie.
Und dann verweigern die da auch monatelang das Geld. Was bedeutet,
wir haben jetzt einen Zustand, der aus Blockade und Boykott durch autokratische
Kräfte auch auf der anderen Seite des Krieges, nicht nur auf Russland und Chinesischer.
So, aber diesen Zustand von einem Vertreter dieser autokratischen Seite jetzt
plötzlich zu verkaufen als, ich bin der Vernünftige, der jetzt diese Blockade,
die sich hier eingestellt hat, die ich selber hergestellt habe,
nutzt um, ach, da sterben so viele Menschen, das ist ja gar nicht gut,
wir sollten der autokratischen Seite mal Zugeständnisse machen und hier jetzt
verhandeln und so weiter. Das finde ich schon wirklich problematisch.
Jaja, also definitiv ist das problematisch, aber du bist ja auch der Ansicht,
dass jetzt der Ukraine-Krieg…,
Nicht zu gewinnen wäre, das lag ja jetzt nicht daran, dass Orbán irgendwelche
Gelder nicht genehmigt hat.
Auf meine Ansicht gefragt würde ich sagen, ja, wir haben gesehen, wir schaffen es nicht.
Wir haben nicht genug Kraft, auch wenn wir es uns anders wünschen,
mit demokratischen und progressiven Kräften Russland der Einhalt gebieten,
weshalb wir uns jetzt auf uns konzentriert sollten. Was zum einen bedeutet,
Abkopplung von Amerika.
Europa muss wehrtechnisch und wehrorganisatorisch und wehrpolitisch auf eigenen Füßen stehen.
Plus, wenn die EU es nicht schafft, sich so zu organisieren,
dann muss sie manche Länder da wieder ausschließen. Dann muss sie sich wieder verkleinern.
Also Ungarn raus aus der Europäischen Union und dafür aber wieder Europäische Union.
Das sind natürlich jetzt Szenarien, die sind nun gar nicht. nicht mal dran zu denken.
Orban ist übrigens auch dafür, dass Europa aufrüstet und sich unabhängig macht
von den USA. Interessant, ne?
Ja, aber trotzdem würde ich jetzt Orban ausschließen und sagen,
hör mal zu, du hast uns hier so berkortiert, du musst jetzt dich um deine Verteidigung selber kümmern.
Du kommst nicht in unseren europäischen Abwehrschirm, denn hier sind nur Länder,
die sich erstens verstehen, zweitens wohlwollend miteinander umgehen und da
ist dann auch die große Frage, wie geht eigentlich Deutschland mit Frankreich um?
Also dieses Dieses ganze Modell scheitert ja gerade auf ganzer Linie.
Dass Orban jetzt auch sagt, wir sollten uns mal europäisch auf eigene Füße stellen.
Orban möchte mit Brüssel gerade Wehrpolitik organisieren.
Er hat doch die letzten drei Jahre gezeigt, dass er dazu nicht in der Lage ist,
dass er nicht bereit dazu ist und dass er nur lügt.
Also lasse ich ihm das nicht durchgehen, wenn er jetzt sagt,
ich will ja auch, dass Europa auf eigenen Füßen steht.
Die Frage, die ich mir nur stelle ist, Was ist,
wenn wir es mit einem geopolitischen Parkett zu tun haben,
auf dem lauter Orbans unterwegs sind, die ständig lügen, möglicherweise haben
diese Orbans irgendwann die Möglichkeit,
irgendwelche Verhandlungen zu machen und es wird, du hast auch eben das Trump-Szenario
geschildert, Trump klärt das mit Putin.
Und das ist doch genau diese Idee jetzt hier von Orban zu sagen,
wir Autokraten, wir klären das jetzt mal unter uns, die Idealisten und Bürokraten
in Brüssel kann man vergessen.
Das ist ja das, was wir jetzt hier erleben und das liegt natürlich auch daran,
dass er das nur so kann, weil, wie Tchewski ja vorher gesagt hat,
Europa überhaupt keine Strategie hat, außer solche Lippenbekenntnisse wie,
die Ukraine muss gewinnen und man denkt so, ja, wie denn?
Ja, meine Kritik an Orban ist ja auch nicht an Orban gerichtet,
sondern an Pistorius. Pistorius reagiert nicht darauf.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber auch einmal bereit sein, diese sicherlich sehr verquere
Perspektive von Orban einzunehmen. Bin gespannt.
Weil die Ukrainer sagen würden, wenn wir den Russen Territorium geben,
müssen unsere Leute unter russischen Regeln leben, dass sie sie zerstören,
dass sie sie töten, dass sie unter russischer Kultur leben müssen,
dass es keine ukrainischen Bücher mehr gibt, keine ukrainische Kultur und dass
sie das nicht akzeptieren können.
Ja, ich würde nicht gerne in Details über die ukrainische Minoritätspolitik gehen.
Sie haben jetzt eine Konversation mit dem hungarischen Premierminister.
Ja, aber Sie haben Putin und Zelenskyy getroffen.
Aber ich weiß, wie die Situation der hungarischen Minoritäten in Zakarpattia,
die heute Teil der Ukraine ist,
Sie werden von der ukrainischen Regierung behandelt. Auf Bildung,
hungarische Bücher und so weiter.
Also der spricht jetzt auch noch zu der ungarischen Minorität in der Ukraine,
die zum Beispiel da auch Auflagen bekommen hat, was Schulunterricht anbelangt,
Sprachen, ungarische Sprache in Schulbüchern etc.
Also da ist das natürlich nicht vergleichbar mit den Repressionen,
die jetzt Russland den Ukrainern aufzwingt, aber er stellt das also sofort in
ein Verhältnis dar und da sind wir sehr ehrlich,
wir wussten gar nichts von ungarischen Minoritäten in der Ukraine.
Ja, aber diese ganze Art der Antwort.
Wir richten da jetzt so eine DDR ein. ja, alle kriegen wieder einen Besen in
die Hand, es gibt keine Arbeitslosigkeit, es gibt hier keine Nazis und so und
dann erklärt man irgendwas für 40 Jahre und dann stellt man fest, also krass jetzt,
50 Jahre später haben wir aber mal die Renten angeglichen und so weiter,
also man baut innerhalb von 40 Jahren so ein gigantisches, so eine gigantische
Asymmetrie zwischen zwei Ungarns auf.
Diese ganzen Kosten, über die muss man doch, das ist doch die Verhandlungsmasse,
da kann er doch nicht jetzt da sitzen und sagen, ich sorge erstmal nur für Frieden,
Dass niemand mehr stirbt und der Rest müssen sie mit anderen Leuten kriegen.
Du hast ja eben über die Ostukraine gesprochen und die Frage,
die sich ja jetzt hier stellt ist,
wird die ukrainische Regierung bereit sein in Assoziationen mit den westlichen Partnern,
Die Ostukraine in Teilen aufzugeben, das bedeutet aber für die Bevölkerung,
die dort lebt, dass sie unter russischer Herrschaft, unter russischer Knute leben müssen.
Und diese Frage bekommt er jetzt nun gestellt und verschiebt das natürlich auf,
ja wir haben ja auch ukrainische.
Ja, aber ich als Kommentator kann doch ganz zynisch über die Lausitz sprechen.
Ich habe ja keine Verantwortung für diese Menschen, aber ich kann die doch jetzt
nicht ausverkaufen, nur weil ich meine Autokratie gerne schützen möchte und
es cool fände, wenn umso mehr Autokratien um mich herum mich nicht bedrohen,
weil ich einer von ihnen bin.
Das ist ja Urbans Ansinn.
Jaja, also dazu kommen wir gleich noch zu dieser Bedrohung durch Russland.
Aber du bist doch selbst jemand, der sagt, also es wird Verhandlungen geben
müssen und diese sehen natürlich nicht so aus, dass die Maximalforderungen der
Ukraine dort bewilligt werden.
Also es wird Abstriche werden gemacht werden müssen. Anders wird es nicht gehen.
Ja, aber die will ich doch nicht von Orban jetzt diktiert haben mit,
das liegt jenseits meines Interesses. Ich will nur, dass da keiner stirbt und
das hat er ja gerade so gesagt.
Naja, aber was soll Orban jetzt?
Orban ist einfach nicht der richtige Ansprechpartner dafür.
Nein, ist es doch interessant, wenn man jemandem zuhört, der natürlich uneigentlich redet die ganze Zeit.
Ja gut.
Also das ist ja klar. Also dass der Orban jetzt nicht da sitzt und sagt,
mir tun die Menschen, die sterben so leid und um die kümmere ich mich.
Für Orban gilt die Logik von Rüttger Brechmann. Mit diesen Leuten stimmt irgendwas
nicht. Die stellen sich selber über alle Schicksale im nahen und fernen Bereich
ihrer sozialen Landkarte.
Und deswegen hören wir das ja hier, weil ich sagen würde, so funktioniert ja
leider ein ganz großer Teil der Weltpolitik.
Na gut, unter diesen aufklärerischen Sichtpunkten.
Also wir müssen es ja erkenntnisinteressant geleitet hören.
Wir können ja nicht sagen, aber das wäre viel schöner, wenn wir das alles ganz
unter guten, rationalen Menschen ausmachen könnten, die nur für alle das Beste
wollen. Das wäre ja toll, aber dieses Personal haben wir ja nicht.
Du unterstellst, ob er da so eine wichtige Rolle hat, ich glaube das nicht.
Das war eine kleine dreitägige Medienreise, Putin, China, Trump.
Wie ist es, mit Wladimir Putin zu schälen, der meiner Meinung nach ein Kriegskriminal ist?
Treffen macht. angehen kann, wenn man sagt, guten Tag, Sie sind ja Kriegsverbrecher oder sowas.
Naja, also der, wie hieß er, von der Leyen's Vorgänger, Luxemburg,
der hat ja Orban immer mit Herr Diktator begrüßt. Vielleicht hat er es gar nicht so mit sich gemeint.
Ja, aber wir wissen auch bei Jean-Claude Juncker, dass da auch einiges ein bisschen schiefgelaufen war.
Und das ist ja unter Freunden quasi. Also das ist ja unter EU-Leuten.
Aber das hätte Juncker nicht zu Putin gesagt. Das ganz gewiss nicht.
Und hier ist aber auch wieder die Sache, wir kriegen doch gerade Folgendes mit.
Zum einen gibt es da diese Bestrebung, wie kriegt man Putin nach Den Haag?
Das belächeln wir, weil wir sagen, gut, eh aussichtslos. Und was haben die mit dem Völkerrecht zu tun?
Die Amerikaner haben auch nur dann was mit dem Völkerrecht zu tun,
wenn sie sich da positiv drauf beziehen können für ihre Sache.
Wir sehen gerade, dass es Bestrebungen gibt, Israel wegen Kriegsverbrechen vor
das Gericht zu bekommen.
Da weiß man schon, egal wie das ausgeht, Deutschland wird sich da irgendwie
so zu verhalten, dass man sagt, ja,
wissen wir jetzt gerade nicht, ist vielleicht gut, wenn wir jetzt mehr Israel
besuchen, als wenn die israelische Regierung uns besucht, damit dann nicht irgendwelche
Schwierigkeiten entstehen.
Das heißt, wie wir das bei den Realisten um Mersheimer gelernt haben,
eigentlich spielt das gar keine Rolle, weil es am Ende die Staaten sind,
die sich konfrontativ gegenüberstehen. Und so beschreibt er es jetzt hier auch.
Es geht nicht darum, wer recht hat und wer nicht. Denn jeder Partei hat immer
seine eigenen Argumente, warum es sinnvoll ist, in die Krieg zu gehen.
Was durch Krieg entschieden wird, ist,
Wer wird sterben und wer bleibt lebendig? Also verstanden Sie nicht.
Sitzen Sie in Brüssel, sitzen Sie in Paris oder nahe zum Atlantischen Ozean.
Sie können eine richtige Distanz in einem theoretischen Weg der Krieg untersuchen.
Aber die Realität der Krieg ist nicht das.
Die Realität der Krieg ist eine sehr scharfe Realität.
Die Menschen sterben jeden Tag. Tausende jetzt, jeden Tag, auf beiden Seiten.
Und das tut ja auch den Russen inzwischen empfindlich weh. Also es ist ja nicht
so, dass Putin sagt, ich habe da meine Gruppe Wagner nur.
Und daran kann man doch ganz klar sehen an dieser Argumentation,
die da jetzt gemacht wird.
Ja, dem geht es nicht um die Menschen, Orban, das ist ja völlig klar.
Was er aber hier deutlich macht ist, dass diese Fragen, die bei einer Verhandlung
sich als erstes stellen, nicht eine Frage ist,
wer hat jetzt welche Kriegsverbrechen verübt, sondern wie kann das Sterben aufhören
und da würde ich sagen, da hat Orban absolut recht zu gehen,
alle die verhandeln da rein.
Aber das ist doch, also wenn er da so da sitzt und sagt, also im Krieg entscheidet
sich nicht dieses und jenes, sondern nur wer stirbt, das ist doch Taschenspieler-Trick-Philosophie.
Naja, aber das stimmt doch.
Ja, klar stimmt's. Aber er hat doch diesen Krieg selber, wie viele sagen,
unnötig verlängert, indem er die ukrainischen Kämpfern Unterstützung versagt
hat. Und das hat er ja nun faktisch.
Militärhilfen wurden nicht gezahlt und Sanktionen nicht ausgesprochen für die
andere Seite, weil Orbán da Vetos eingelegt hat.
Ja.
Und dann...
Darüber zu sitzen, darüber zu reden, ohne das in diesem Moment mitzureflektieren.
Sei es von Ronsheimer in Fragen oder von ihm selbst.
Aber das können wir doch selbst reinlegen. Also das finde ich ja gerade die
Qualität von Ronsheimer, dass er jetzt mir nicht nochmal...
Ich finde sowas sollte explizit angesprochen werden.
Die Geschichte des Krieges gehört.
Dass Orban auf der falschen Seite kämpft.
Ja.
Und jetzt uns Verhandlungen schönredet.
Wenn Ronsheimer konfrontativ wird, führt das zu gar nichts. Ich bring dir jetzt
nämlich ein Beispiel dafür.
You don't find many Es gibt viele Leute, die sagen, okay, wir müssen jetzt mit
den Russen diskutieren,
weil sie sagen, wenn die Russen näher zu meinem Zuhause kommen,
wenn sie näher zu meiner Frau kommen, zu meiner Mutter, dann will ich das nicht.
Das ist der Grund, warum wir die Ukraine verteidigen.
Also, wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, du als deutscher Mann,
ein deutscher Kerl, versuchst mir zu erklären, was es bedeutet,
nahe zu den Russen zu leben.
Nobody can educate the Hungarians about Russia I don't want to educate Das finde ich ganz perfide.
Das finde ich ganz perfide. Natürlich ist es perfid. Ich will dir nur damit
zeigen, eine Konfrontation bringt nichts.
Orban braucht die Bedrohung durch Russland.
Um jetzt das Argument zu machen, ich verstehe am besten, wie es ist von Russland bedroht zu sein.
Wir waren ja schon häufiger besetzt. und gleichzeitig diesen Punkt zu fahren,
aber dann latent unausgesprochen, ich brauche Strongmen um mich herum,
damit nicht so auffällt, dass ich ein Strongman bin.
Ja, aber es ist doch eigentlich eine Qualität eines Interviews,
wenn genau das rauskommt.
Wenn es rauskommt.
Ja, aber es kommt ja auch raus. Also es ist ja in aller Deutlichkeit.
Wir haben es dechiffriert.
Naja, also ich würde sagen, das spricht schon sehr für sich.
Also bei Orban hast du es schon mit einer Figur zu tun, die kannst du sprechen
lassen und dann kriegst du die Informationen schon, die du brauchst.
Dass der jetzt nicht sagt, ja, ich bin homophob und ja, ich habe auch ein Problem
mit den Juden. Das ist ja klar, dass der das nicht sagt.
Wenn es jetzt einen Zerstörer geben würde und Putin das akzeptieren würde,
sagen wir mal, wie die Linien jetzt sind, dann wäre seine Strategie,
seine Armee wieder zu verbinden und wieder zu attackieren.
In zwei, drei, vier, fünf Jahren.
Übrigens auch eine Diskussion ja dann immer, wenn man jetzt C-2 in Gaza hätte,
dann würde die Hamas sich neu aufstellen und so.
Und jetzt hat Orban ja gerade dann mit beiden gesprochen, Zelensky und Putin,
und sie genau dazu befragt.
Ist es möglich, einen unbegrenzten Zeitraum zu erheben,
der die Friedenstöße akzeptiert und dann die guten Folgen einer akzeptierten
Friedenstöße genießt? Denn jetzt denkt jeder nur das Gegenteil.
Zuerst müssen wir einen Friedensvertrag machen und wenn es einen Friedensvertrag
gibt, dann können wir einen Friedenstöße erheben. And they were not positive on that. None of them.
They said exactly the same thing as you. The Ukrainians and the Russians.
Ceasefire would be the interest of the other because during the ceasefire they
can reorganize their position in preparation to continue to war.
Okay, I understand that position.
But that's where the mediators has a role to be done.
Ja, also dieses Dilemma gibt es ja tatsächlich und das wird nicht seine Rolle
sein, das natürlich zu verhandeln.
Auch nach den Opfern wird gefragt.
Also diese Opfer zahlen nach wie vor im Dunkeln. Wie ist es denn jetzt mit dieser
Gefahr, Putin greift die NATO an?
We're talking about that for many months, actually since the beginning of the
war, that the Russian army could attack NATO, a NATO country.
You know, I don't like to become ridiculous.
So no serious man can raise any serious conversation that Russia has an intention to attack NATO.
Und ich finde auch das, was er hier sagt, stimmt.
But they are rational. They are hyper-rational. Wie war es rational,
um Kiew zu attackieren, wenn du sagst, dass die Russen rational sind, dann würde jeder sagen,
dass es nicht rational war, was es war?
Es war eine Misskalkulation und zu sein irrational ist zwei verschiedene Dinge.
Irrational means to do madness. Miscalculation to do some mistake.
Calculation mistake. That's a different thing.
To attack NATO by anybody, not only Russia, but anybody of the world,
to attack NATO is totally impossible.
Because NATO is far the strongest military community. It's a defense system.
We are far better and stronger than anybody else.
Und nach wie vor gilt doch, wenn Putin es nicht schafft, Kiew einzunehmen,
soll er aber zugleich schon morgen in Berlin stehen, was ist das immer für eine Argumentation?
Diese Unterscheidung, die er macht zwischen Misskalkulierungen und Irrationalität.
Finde ich es nicht haltbar.
Das kann man so sagen, weil das eine Pointe im Gespräch ist,
aber es war irrational, diesen Krieg so zu beginnen für Putin und für Russland, also beidermaßen,
denn Denn weder kann diese Biografie daraus wieder zurückkommen,
noch das politische Schicksal Russlands irgendwas Positives daraus ziehen.
Dafür sind die Einschnitte viel zu groß.
Und wenn er dann sagt, nee, die haben sich einfach miss, also da gab es so andere
Kalkulationen, die gingen dann halt nicht auf.
Nee, das ist ja der Madness-Anteil daran, dass es trotzdem gemacht hat.
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei Oppenheimer. Ich habe nur diese eine Szene nochmal
so bei YouTube gesehen, wie sie so diese Berechnung machen.
Ja, entzünden wir dann die ganze Atmosphäre und dann kriegt er ja diesen Stapel
Papier und dann sagt er, nee, verschwinden geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Da setzt sich niemand hin und fragt, ist das jetzt Misskalkulation oder Madness,
sondern es ist einfach Madness.
Es trotzdem mal zu versuchen, könnte ja sein, dass die Kalkulation richtig ist
und wir nicht die ganze Welt in Brand setzen und dann haben sie es einfach gemacht.
Also hier gilt einfach, es ist dann Madness, es ist Irrationalität.
Die Idee, dass man das kalkulieren könnte, gehört schon auf die Seite der Madness.
Wir kalkulieren jetzt mal einen Krieg durch und dann stellen wir fest,
die alten Philosophen hatten doch recht, sobald Planung Realität wird,
ist sozusagen die Grenze überschritten. Das ist bescheuert.
Und hier würde ja unser, du musst draufklicken, unser Rüttger Brechmann sagen, dass das,
die Politiker auszeichnen. Die machen das halt.
Das ist deren Auszeichnung, diese Madness einfach zu machen.
Wir testen jetzt die Atombombe. Ihr habt unseren Befehl.
Wir setzen sie jetzt ein im Krieg. Wir wissen nicht, was dann passiert.
Vielleicht gibt es noch mal graduelle Unterschiede. Also ich sage mal so,
dass ein gewisser militärischer Erfolg seitens Russlands in der Ukraine zu erzielen
war, ist ja wahrscheinlich.
Zugleich gibt es diesen hohen Madness-Anteil, den du da eben ausgeführt hast.
Während wir es jetzt, wenn Russland auf die Idee käme, Berlin zu erobern,
nur mit Madness noch zu tun hätten und mit keinerlei sinnvollem militärischen
Erfolg, den man erwarten könnte.
Die Unterscheidung von Sieg und Frieden oder Sieg und Niederlage und Gewinnen
und Verlieren, die muss man wirklich hinterfragen.
Precht hat immer wieder darauf hingewiesen in seinem Podcast,
ja, Deutschland hat den Zweiten Weltkrieg verloren, wie noch nie ein Land einen Krieg verloren hat.
Und zehn Jahre später war das die Power-Nation Europas. Haben sie wirklich verloren?
Ja, sie haben eine Niederlage gehabt. Aber haben sie wirklich verloren?
Nee, der Erfolg zeigt dann doch irgendwie was anderes.
Hier auch, wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, wir geben irgendwie die ukrainische Lausitz Putin.
Gleichzeitig ist aber das Land nicht nur durch Corona, sondern dann auch durch
diese Sanktionen gegangen, die nun wirklich einschneidend sind.
Egal, was ansonsten über irgendwelche Spin-Doktoren uns nochmal erklärt wird,
wenn da einfach ganze Märkte, Weltmarktzugänge gestrichen werden,
ja, man kriegt sein Öl schon noch verkauft.
Genau, aber Russland war vorher auch schon, naja, gut, das Einzige,
was sie haben, ist halt Öl und dieser Verlust an volkswirtschaftlicher Kraft,
Lebenszufriedenheit und so weiter, ja, wir müssten dann irgendwie sagen,
sie haben den Krieg so ein bisschen gewonnen.
Es ist ein Sieg, aber haben sie wirklich gewonnen?
Nein, nein, nicht in dem Sinne.
Russland ist in einem Zustand, wo man echt sagen muss, diese Kategorien schon
überhaupt anzulegen, sind völlig daneben.
Genau, und wir sehen ja jetzt gerade, wir hatten im letzten Salon ja diesen
Text über, wie BlackRock und andere Investoren ihre Unterstützung abziehen von der Ukraine.
Man kann sich also durchaus eine Situation vorstellen, in der die Ukraine den
Krieg doppelt verliert.
Und zwar einmal jetzt militärisch wird man irgendwas dann ausbaldowern mit Trump
und Putin und dann hat man aber noch westliche Investoren,
hat westliche Staaten, die auch alle sagen, ach interessiert uns jetzt gerade
nicht mehr so der Aufbau.
Wir wollen das Geld zurückhaben.
Wir werfen euch jetzt in die tiefste Schuldenfalle, die ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Das ist die große Gefahr, die da ist. Jetzt nochmal auf Orban und das Ziel seiner Reise.
More person who would like to argue in favor of peace, which was not the case even one week ago.
So it's a fermentation, may I say, what we need. And I think it's already started to happen.
Fermentation, also eine Gärung, findet statt.
Wir haben den Blüthorn schon gelesen. Wir werden morgen über ihn,
nicht morgen, aber im Salon dann über ihn diskutieren.
Blüthorn hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Unhaltbarkeit.
Unhaltbar sind ja auch militärische Posten, ja, da kann man nicht mehr weiter,
man muss also irgendetwas sehen.
Er diagnostiziert, also wir müssen einen anderen Weg einschlagen. Er will ja,
Zeigen, welcher Weg da gerade so läuft, in welche Moderne man kommt.
Nicht in eine zweite Moderne, sondern in eine andere Moderne kommt man dann.
Und er sagt, unhaltbar wird zunehmend dieses demokratische Projekt.
Nicht, weil er die Demokratie scheiße findet, sondern er sieht das als sehr
dramatisch an. Und wir sehen jetzt, wir haben nur wenige Staaten eigentlich,
die demokratisch regiert sind in der Welt.
Das sind gar nicht so viele, wirklich demokratisch regiert.
Ja eben, was heißt denn wirklich demokratisch?
Naja, also China, da gibt es auch irgendwas, wird da rumgewählt oder in Russland
wird auch ein bisschen gewählt, aber jetzt also sagen wir, die sich mit unseren Maßstäben messen,
die sich mit Maßstäben von Deutschland zum Beispiel messen könnten,
da fallen einem nicht so viele ein.
Wenn man sich anguckt, wie groß die Weltbevölkerung ist und wie viele Menschen
dort demokratisch regiert werden, dann ist das eine ganz deutliche Minderheit.
Die wohlhabende Minderheit.
Ja, aber wir sprechen hier von einer Minderheitenposition aus und zu dieser
Gruppe gehört Orban nicht.
Gehört Xi nicht, gehört Putin nicht. Aber die haben irgendwie ein Draht zueinander.
Nun ist Ungarn nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig, aber irgendwas passiert da.
Das heißt, wir sehen doch jetzt gerade, wie in China Klimapolitik gemacht wird, die uns betrifft.
Adam Tooze hat ein riesen Essay geschrieben der Zeit darüber.
Er sagt, konzentriert euch nicht nur auf die US-Wahl, noch wichtiger ist die
Entscheidung 2025, wie wird die Klimapolitik organisiert sein in China.
Das wird uns alle betreffen.
Da stellt sich am Ende heraus, ob wir wenigstens das 2-Grad-Ziel erreichen.
Und jetzt sehen wir hier Autokraten unterwegs, führen miteinander Gespräche und die….
Versuchen jetzt irgendwas herzustellen, was sie dann Frieden nennen oder wie
auch immer. Das heißt, auch das ist wieder etwas, wo wir sehr stark ausgeklammert sind.
Die Frage ist jetzt, wie verhält man sich zu so einem Orban?
Man kann den nochmal bestrafen, wie von der Leyen das getan hat.
Das ist aber vielleicht nicht besonders effektiv, sondern die Frage ist also
jetzt, wie kann man selbst zum aktiven Part werden?
Also müsste man nicht eigentlich sagen, Macron und Scholz reisen jetzt erst
zu Zelensky, dann zu Putin.
Also um selbst wieder Teil des Spiels zu werden, damit das nicht nur eine Strongman-Politik
ist, wie Orban und Co. sich das vorstellen.
Und ich glaube, diese Herausforderung ist da und wir haben Patschewski gehört,
der sagt, der Westen hat ja gar keinen Plan.
Er ist ja, also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass der Trump-Anhänger ist,
der Mann, der kommt auch aus Großbritannien, aber wenn er selbst die Hoffnung
hat, dass wenigstens mit einem Regierungswechsel, dass Trump da etwas Positives
für die Ukraine rausholen könnte und er sagt,
ich weiß, dass die im Selensky-Kreis schon ähnlich denken,
dann muss uns das doch in erheblichem Maße zu denken geben.
Da kann es doch nicht sein, dass wir nur dastehen und wie so ein Roboter wiederholen,
das ist ein völkerrechtswidriger Angriffskrieg.
Man darf aber jetzt nicht unterschätzen, wie sehr diese Regierungsleute,
so wie alle Investoren, egal worein sie investieren, auf Stabilität und Perspektive aus sind.
Und so schlimm es für die Menschen an der Front gerade ist...
Im geopolitischen Maßstab, Turbulenz oder Nicht-Turbulenz, ist der Kriegszustand
gerade ziemlich viel Nicht-Turbulenz.
Also da sitzen zwei Leute im Podcast und sagen, seit einem Jahr ist eigentlich
nicht sehr viel passiert.
Und man hat so eine Ahnung davon, dass man nur in kleinen Milliardenbeträgen
feilensteuern kann, ob da jetzt noch was passiert oder nicht.
Also bald eine Offensive angekündigt ist, kommt ein Medientheater,
da ist eine Offensive angekündigt, wir müssen auch. Auch da wird die Offensive
so ein bisschen abgewogen, ausgewogen, ausgeglichene Zustände hergestellt.
Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob erstens China gerade wirklich daran interessiert
ist, dass sich in Russland groß was ändert.
Und es würde sich einiges ändern, wenn es diesen Krieg nicht mehr gäbe.
Und zum anderen, ja für uns sieht es so aus, als gäbe es da eine autokratische Allianz.
Für Russland sieht es so aus, als gäbe es da gerade eine ganz andere Allianz.
Denn Obama Biden und Macron und,
Scholz, die sind ja durchaus im Gespräch, also es ist ja klar,
dass die da reden und als Scharnierstelle da irgendwie von der Leyen und so
weiter die sind viel mehr im Gespräch als jetzt Putin und Xi wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Und aus deren Richtung betrachtet sind wir halt die Verlangs so, ne?
Also zwischen Sieg und Niederlage, Gewinnen und Verlieren gibt es halt einfach
noch so jetzt mal nichts auf nur.
Es sind ja ja, die Menschen, die sterben, du hast sie angesprochen. Genau.
Die sind Xi ganz egal. Also der sperrt auch eine Million Uiguren ein.
Genau, aber wer am Ende den Krieg beendet, ist ja, also wer das Sterben beendet,
beendet das Sterben. Da kann man jetzt nicht sagen, die Intention war eine andere.
Ja, das macht es ja so interessant, dass Trump die Intention bei der Bundesregierung
ist ja offensichtlich auch nicht das Sterben der Menschen.
Der Einzige, der aus dem Ende des Krieges etwas ziehen kann, ist Donald Trump.
Weil er seinen Wählern erklären kann seiner Base, ich bin der Weltfriedenspräsident.
Und das, würde ich sagen, ist auch einer der größten Antriebe zum Frieden gerade.
Diese Hoffnung der Autokraten, dass Trump den Weltfrieden herstellt und über
das Weltfriedensargument eine sozusagen latent mitlaufende Argumentation für
autokratische Politik.
Nur diese Art der Politik kann es gestalten. Und deswegen ist diese amerikanische
Wahl auch nochmal besonders interessant.
Und Orban, den man ja als den kleinen Trump bezeichnen kann oder der schon viel erfolgreicher war.
Großer Trump im kleinen Land.
Ja, großer Trump im kleinen Land ist da ein Beispiel für und neben der ganzen
Sache um die Soldaten, die sterben,
ist es ja auch so, dass wir zwar sagen, ja, das kommt einem fast wie Ruhe vor,
aber es gibt ja dann doch, wenn man so ein bisschen tiefer sich reinliest,
da zum Beispiel diesen Artikel von McCallion und Friedman in Politico liest,
dann sieht man schon, dass es große Ängste gibt,
dass so etwas eskalieren kann,
dass also solche Grenzübertritte die ganze Zeit stattfinden,
also dass es keineswegs so ruhig verläuft.
Insofern ist es also eigentlich im Sinne aller, dass das passiert.
Die Intention ist doch am Ende völlig egal.
Also Orban geht es nicht um die Menschen, das wissen wir. Die Frage ist,
kann so eine Gehrung tatsächlich in irgendeiner Weise funktionieren,
wo er sich sicher ist, dass Trump nicht derjenige ist, der die Ukraine ausliefert?
Ich kenne viele Ukrainer, die sehr Angst haben, dass Trump Präsident wird und
Putin einfach was er will.
Er ist nicht dieser Art Mann.
Be sure. To give somebody what he would like to get. That for a self-made man
does not sound very logical.
Was nochmal?
Ja, es sei nicht besonders logisch für einen Businessman wie Trump,
dass er Putin das gibt, was er will, sondern Trump wird schon verhandeln und
dafür ist er ja auch bekannt.
Jetzt ganz zum Abschluss noch wird er zu Merkel befragt und daher kennen wir ja Orban vor allem,
dieser Dieser permanente Streit mit Merkel über das Thema Migration,
es ist ja wirklich absurd gewesen, wie Orban da Politik gegen Brüssel und gegen
Merkel ganz speziell gemacht hat.
Und jetzt fragt Ronsheimer.
Do you miss Angela Merkel? Always.
Und dann erklärt er ein bisschen, ja, ich bin, wie Sie ja wissen, gegen Migration.
Und Ronsheimer sagt noch, ja, ich habe davon gehört.
Aber in Sachen Diplomatie sei sie einsame Spitze gewesen.
Die Konflikte, die für Europa schlecht sind, zu isolieren. Ja,
also wir haben nur eine Welt und nur eine Geschichte.
Es gibt keinen AB-Test.
Ihr wisst es nicht und Und, ja, wer weiß.
Ich würde sagen, es hängt, es hing wirklich mehr von Trump und Trumps Wahlniederlage
zusammen als jetzt mit Merkels nicht mehr im Amt.
Auch wenn es näher dran liegt. Aber wer weiß.
Gut. Die amerikanische Wahl. Wir wollen alle wissen, was ist im Juli in Amerika
passiert und worauf sollte man den Fokus insbesondere legen.
Im Juli? Achso, was ist passiert?
Was ist passiert?
Ja, ja, ja.
Oder was jetzt im August passiert, wenn wir in die Zukunft schauen.
Ich dachte, du prediktest doch bestimmt jetzt gleich schon, wie es sein wird.
Nein, wir machen jetzt eine Timeline des Juli in Amerika, was ist passiert,
seit wir zuletzt darüber sprachen, seit der Debatte.
Wir haben alle mitbekommen, es läuft eine Wahl. Sie ist wichtig,
wird uns gesagt. Wir wissen nicht so genau, warum.
Aber sie ist auf jeden Fall mega unterhaltsam. Wir haben zuletzt die Debatte
gesehen und dachten, so wird das nichts.
Dieser Wahlkampf wird sich wohl verändern und er hat sich jetzt im Juli verändert.
Nur um an den Tenor der Debatte anzuschließen, hier aus dem direkten Nachbesprechungsreigen
bei CNN N diese kleine beliebige Wortmeldung?
In 18 Wochen wird Donald Trump Präsidenten-Elekt werden. So,
also wenn sich nichts verändert wird, amerikanischer Präsident Donald Trump
und irgendwie ist die Democracy on the line oder was auch immer.
Es bleibt alles so ein bisschen unscharf, ist es ja geblieben und auch zu der Frage,
was kann sich denn jetzt verändern, war ja bis dahin noch die Frage,
ja müssen wir jetzt den Kandidaten austauschen und es ist ja,
wie wir heute wissen, Kamala Harris geworden und nicht Gavin Newsom oder irgendwer anders,
weil diese Idee von, wir rollen das es nochmal ganz auf, ging gar nicht,
auch wenn Harris ja sofort erklärt hat, ich will mir die Kandidatur erarbeiten
und verdienen, statt einfach nur ernannt zu werden.
Hier kann man das mal raushören, die soziologische Dramatik wird darüber nicht
richtig deutlich, aber man kann sie danach zumindest mal umreißen.
Also auch an diesem Abend in dieser Halle war dann auch Gavin Newsom anwesend
und man Man fragt ihn, was ist jetzt von dieser Debatte damals zu halten?
Und ich denke, es ist unnötig. Wir müssen rein, wir müssen unsere Hände hochhalten.
Und wie ich sagte, wir müssen den Backen dieses Präsidenten haben.
Du wirst nicht den Backen wechseln, weil du eine Performance hast.
Welche Art von Partei macht das?
Es war ein Masterclass. 15,6 Millionen Jobs.
Das sind achtmal mehr als die letzten drei republikanischen Präsidenten zusammen.
Das einzige, was die letzten drei republikanischen Präsidenten zusammen haben,
sind Rezessionen. Die Demokraten erzeugen.
Dieser Präsident wird erzeugt. Wir müssen für ihn erzeugen.
Klingt das zuversichtlich? Nein.
Es klingt panisch.
Wenn Geldgeber sagen, wir sind raus. Ja. der Druck kann alles mögliche,
aber formal gesehen kann auch...
Obama im Hintergrund, also da haben schon einige mitgespielt.
Alles richtig.
Aber am Ende ist es der Präsident.
Der Formalia ist das egal. Die Formalia kennt keinen medialen Druck.
Sondern Olaf Scholz ist der Kanzler. Egal was diskutiert wird.
Er ist der Kanzler. Bis er sagt, ich stelle ein Misstrauensvotum.
Es gibt sonst keine Möglichkeit, da irgendwas zu tun.
So, und die besondere Dramatik und Panik bei ihm, der Stimme,
die hier wirklich hörbar ist, bedeutet ja auch, es braucht Königsmörder.
Es gibt aber keinen formalen Weg. Der informale Weg wäre medialer Druck.
Man kann an dem Moment nur hoffen, dass das passiert. Der Tenor war ja schon,
das wird er nicht überleben.
Der mediale Druck wird entsprechend groß sein, aber man braucht ja dann auch
einen Ersatz. Ersatz bedeutet alternative Kampagnen.
Wenn man eine Vorwahl hat, stehen die Teams, angeführt von ihrem Personal und
dahinter die Wahlkampftruppen.
Was hier in dem Falle bedeutet, Joe Biden hat an Kamala Harris eine 1300 Vollzeitstellen
mannstarke Mannschaft übergeben.
Gavin Newsom in dem Moment, wo er das sagt, Null. Und er dürfte nicht mal eine
Person anrufen, um sie zu fragen, ob sie für einen Wahlkampf bereit stünde,
wenn es zu einem Wahlkampf käme, weil das sofort gemeldet würde als,
er glaubt nicht mehr dran, er ist der Königsmörder, das wird nichts.
Also inwieweit diesen Leuten die Hände gebunden waren und sie einfach nur als
in dem Falle dann wirklich Person des Interesses in der Öffentlichkeit zu stehen
und zu sagen, wir wenden uns nicht von ihm ab,
wir unterstützen ihn, er hat delivered, Masterclass.
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich im Rückblick, finde ich, das nochmal so zu sehen,
wie da einfach in dem Falle dann ja wirklich einfach einzelne Personen dastehen
und sagen, ich kann leider gar nichts machen.
So, und dann gab es ja die erste große Wendung, weil er jetzt schon hier mit,
wir können keinen Königsmord organisieren.
Ja, Königsmord. Ist es jetzt ein König eigentlich?
Stellt sich raus. Die Debatte war am Freitag. Am Montag drauf, 1.
Juli, kam dann dieses Supreme Court Urteil, von dem ich mal kurz durchgehe,
wie das in den deutschen Medien verhandelt wurde.
Die ARD fragt also in der Überschrift am Tage,
die ARD fragt oder schreibt, Trump erringt in Immunitätsfrage Teilsieg vor Supreme Court.
Kann man sagen, nee, das war, also den amerikanischen Journalisten,
wir hören es gleich, am Tage der Verkündung klar, hier geht es nicht um Trump,
der irgendwas erringt, hier geht es nicht um Teilsiege, sondern hier geht es
einfach all in um alles, was er bringt. und überhaupt.
Hier geht es um das Verfassungsgefüge von Amerika.
Zwei Tage später, kleine Besinnung, Urteil zur Immunität, Zitat,
Supreme Court hat Trump freie Hand gegeben.
In dem Fall hat es das Zitat eines Experten.
Man hat nämlich dann, so steht es in der Überzeile, nach zwei Tagen,
also zwei Tage nach dem Urteil des obersten US-Gerichts zur Immunität von Ex-Präsidenten,
ich würde sagen Präsidenten halt.
Meinen Beobachter, die Entscheidung wird die amerikanische Demokratie verändern.
Von einem Dammbruch spricht US-Experte Finch, der ist dann hier im Gespräch
und sagt in einer Antwort, in diesem Urteil kommt das Prinzip zum Einsatz,
dass der König nicht falsch handeln kann.
Das ist eine alte Diskussion aus dem englischen Verfassungsrecht,
dass der König wegen Handlung, die er begeht, nicht vor Gericht landen kann.
In der amerikanischen Revolution ist dieses Prinzip abgeschafft worden.
Der oberste Gerichtshof führt es jetzt durch die Hintertür wieder ein.
Also die Tagesschau hat dann eine Person irgendwo gehabt, die meinte,
wir sollten das nochmal thematisieren, denn wir haben es im Fernsehen irgendwie
ganz anders behandelt als unsere Leute, wenn ich amerikanisches Fernsehen schaue.
Könnt ihr nicht mal mit dem und dem reden.
Hintergrund ist natürlich dann nochmal Project 2025.
Da wurde übrigens jetzt der Chef rausgedrängt von Trump, weil er ihm irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, zu viele Widerworte oder was auch immer.
Aber der Heritage Foundation Chef Kevin Roberts, der das ja maßgeblich mitfinanziert
und trägt, von dem ist ja bekannt, dass er sagte, wir befinden uns im Prozess
der zweiten amerikanischen Revolution,
die unblutig bleiben wird, wenn die Linke es zulässt.
Also wir lernen jetzt hier Tagesschau und dann ZDF, okay, es gibt da so Zitate,
die stehen im Raum, die haben irgendwas zu tun mit schon wieder einer amerikanischen Revolution,
also es geht jetzt quasi um das Komplettgefüge, über 200 Jahre,
die älteste Demokratie der Welt und so weiter werden hier umrissen.
Erste Das CDF. Danach, am 2. Juli, in einem Leitartikel, der bis heute hinter
der Paywall ist, aber immerhin 700 Worte zum Thema, Urteil zur Immunität des
US-Präsidenten der Supreme Court hilft, die amerikanische Demokratie zu zerstören.
Ich frage mich, warum also diese Verzögerung von ein, zwei Tagen,
die da drin steckt, bis man dann so, ah ja, nee, doch, es geht doch um alles irgendwie.
Es ist jetzt neue amerikanische Revolution, es ist jetzt wieder Königreich und so.
Kein Niederschlag nirgendwo. In der eigenen Tagesthemenberichterstattung,
heute Journal, wird es denn nicht mehr aufgegriffen.
So als wäre gerade, nee, das Momentum für diese Nachricht ist vorbei oder sowas.
Wir hatten da diese Aufschlagnachricht, die ging ein bisschen schief,
deswegen haben wir nochmal einen Nachdreher gemacht, aber Aber muss das jetzt
irgendwo diskutiert werden?
Vielleicht sogar mal in einer Talkshow oder so?
Nein, fand überhaupt nicht statt. Also in der Hinsicht sehr schade.
Mich hat es auch gewundert. Ich habe aber dann eine Antwort,
glaube ich, darauf gefunden.
Nämlich diese ganzen Prozesse, die Trump ja seit Jahren hat,
werden alle unter sehr bulverdesken Gesichtspunkten gesehen. Nun...
Ist dies aber nichts Bulbadeskes, sondern etwas ganz Grundsätzliches.
Und da muss man auf eine völlig andere Ebene gehen. Dazu ist man aber nicht bereit.
Man will eigentlich nochmal wissen,
welche E-Mails hat Trump irgendeiner Pornote-Erstellerin geschrieben.
Hier geht es um was anderes und man kann es ja nachlesen, zum Beispiel in den
Blättern jetzt auch übersetzt, Adam Server hatte in The Atlantic schnell einen
Artikel dazu verfasst und er spricht davon,
dass es jetzt so umgebaut ist, dass man eigentlich beim obersten Gericht von
Trump-Gericht sprechen muss.
Und er sagt dann, mit dieser Entscheidung sagt das Trump-Gericht,
dass Trump Immunität für Verbrechen genießt, die er bereits begangen hat und
für Verbrechen, die er in der Zukunft zu begehen beabsichtigt.
Der ganze Zweck der Verfassung war es, eine Regierung zu begründen,
die nicht den Launen eines Königs unterworfen ist.
Die selbst erklärten Originalisten, wir hatten das ja mal mit Josh Hawley thematisiert,
des Gerichts haben in einer perversen Verdrehung der Geschichte und der Verfassung,
die sie angeblich verehren, entschieden,
eine Krone in Trumps Reichweite zu platzieren, in der Hoffnung,
dass er sie sich im November greift.
Ja, genau. Das ist genau der Tenor.
Und jetzt hören wir das mal in den amerikanischen großen journalistischen Häusern,
die das nämlich alle durchweg richtig gemacht haben. Ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Vorher noch kleiner Snippet. Ich hatte eine Mail bekommen vom Deutschlandfunk.
Sascha Wandhöfer macht irgendwie einen Podcast.
Der heißt Nachredaktionsschluss. Und ein Hörer, Hendrik, hat sich dort gemeldet
und gesagt, lieber Deutschlandfunk, ich habe irgendwie so im Aufwachen-Podcast einen Neue20er gehört.
Da steckt mehr dahinter, hinter diesem Urteil. Warum bei euch nicht?
Also haben sie eine Sendung gestaltet und mich dann auch angefragt,
ob ich dazukomme, zusammen mit zwei Korrespondenten. einer, der eine LA,
nee, Los Angeles Times Korrespondent in Deutschland, jahrelang und noch jemand,
Und dann läuft es ungefähr so ab. Man kriegt so eine Mail, erklärt sich bereit,
die so, naja, gut, wir haben alle Gäste in der Tasche, ist ja cool.
Es ist 15.40 Uhr, gestern 15.40 Uhr.
Ich gehe also 15.35 Uhr online, weil ich denke, ich bin ja höflich.
Ich kann ja schon mal mit dem Techniker gucken und so, ob hier und so weiter.
Stell dann fest, ah, es war ganz gut, pünktlich online zu gehen,
weil, ah ja, die machen das mit Sessionlink. Also erstmal Google Chrome runterladen.
Also wir reden jetzt darüber, ob wir die Demokratie retten, indem wir uns erstmal
Google-Software runterladen müssen, weil das Gespräch sonst nicht stattfinden kann.
Ich habe das schon heruntergeladen, war dann 15.40 Uhr online.
Hendrik, der Hörer auch.
Dingskirschbaum oder wie er heißt, auch. Aber niemand vom Deutschlandfunk.
15.42 Uhr meldet sich dann der Deutschlandfunk. Ja, da können wir ja losfahren
und so. Ich so, ja, okay. Dann der Techniker, ich höre noch irgendwo einen Hall.
Wir so, auf welcher Leitung denn? Leitung 3. Wer ist denn Leitung 3?
Keine Ahnung. dann sagt jeder mal was, damit man rausfindet, wer ist denn Leitung 3?
Stellt sich raus, ich war Leitung 3. Ich hatte natürlich alles schon auf 920er
umgebaut in der Podcast-Technik und habe gesagt, kein Problem.
Ich habe ja noch ein paar andere Computer und ein paar andere Mikrofone.
Ich baue einfach schnell um.
Stellt sich raus, dieses Session-Link-Ding einmal aufgerufen,
geht mit gleichem Namen irgendwie nicht unter einer anderen Session auf einem anderen Computer.
Also der Link geht dann einfach nicht oder irgendwas klappt mit dieser Verbindung nicht.
Ich habe einfach nur gesehen, ich bin jetzt verbunden mit dem Deutschlandfunk,
aber die haben mich nicht gesehen, wie auch immer.
So, ich also zu dem Techniker, ja, ich kann jetzt ein Bild checken,
hier steht, ich bin verbunden, ich sehe auch meine Ausschläge,
ich sehe auch Ihre, schalten Sie mich einfach in die Sendung.
Also, äh, keine Ahnung, oder so. Dann ruft der, äh,
Wandhöfer an, bei seiner Technik, der stellt das auf laut, sodass ich es dann
über Banden mithöre. Und er so, nee, wir müssen jetzt anfangen.
Und ich so, wie anfangen? Ich bin ja nicht in der Sendung. Ja,
wir müssen jetzt anfangen.
Und das war keine Live-Sendung?
Nein, das war eine Aufzeichnung für in drei Tagen oder so.
Ach so.
Völlig bescheuert. Kann ich auch meine Technik, also meine Aufnahme schicken
oder was auch immer. Können sie jetzt danach zusammenbauen.
Naja, jedenfalls war der dann so im Zeitstress plötzlich, nachdem er selber
zu spät in dieser Leitung war und nichts eingeplant hatte für,
wir machen ja nochmal kurz einen Technik-Check.
Ich habe schon gehört, dass der Köschbaum so per Telefon irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, wie er sich da eingeschaltet hatte. Naja.
Dann sage ich zu dem Techniker, ja, geben Sie bitte weiter, ich komme nicht
mittendrin in die Sendung.
Entweder wir warten, bis das hier hinklappt oder nicht.
Ich kann ja nicht in einer Sendung teilnehmen, die alle Hörer schon gehört haben,
bis Minute 17 und dann komme ich plötzlich rein und frage, worüber haben Sie
jetzt geredet die ganze Zeit? Ist ja totaler Quatsch.
So, woraufhin ich nur noch höre, dass der Redakteur dem Techniker sagt,
wir fangen jetzt an. Und der Techniker zu mir, haben Sie das jetzt gehört?
Und ich so, ja, die fangen jetzt an.
Und das war's. Da habe ich gedacht, hm, okay, dann fangt ihr mal an.
Und dann habe ich aufgelegt und habe weiter unseren Podcast vorbereitet.
Und es könnte auch sein. Nein.
So machen wir das hier.
Ja, es könnte auch sein, dass die deutschen Journalisten mit diesen Themen einfach
nicht richtig klarkommen, weil ihre Gesprächspartner von ihrer Technik nicht
ordentlich betreut werden oder weil man die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Google Silicon
Valley Technik runterladen muss, damit es überhaupt erstmal funktioniert.
Und ich halte das für nicht akzeptabel. Und ich reagiere jetzt auch,
also ich höre jetzt anders, wenn im Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast Stefan Däthien
dann sagt, ja, dann finden wir hier auch mal ein Ende, weil du,
Gundela, du musst ja jetzt noch schnell einen Beitrag machen und wie auch immer
und so. oder so. Nee, Leute.
Kommt mal alle runter, nehmt euch mal Zeit, ein Podcast kann auch mal über 30
Minuten gehen, verhandelt die Themen ordentlich, lest vielleicht nochmal eine
Zeitung, nehmt das mit der Technik nicht so ernst.
Wenn eure Deutschlandfunk-Technik richtig funktioniert, nehmt einfach Zoom,
da kann jeder Channel einzeln aufgenommen werden, das kriegt man danach als
Download, dann kann man den Podcast zusammenbauen, wie auch immer.
Aber dieser Stress, nee, wir müssen jetzt anfangen, wir müssen jetzt anfangen,
der Techniker macht das schon und also es war sehr augenöffnend, würde ich mal so sagen.
So kriegt man keine Inhalte auf die Spur. Selbst wenn das danach geklappt hätte,
hätten sich ja erstmal alle wieder fünf Minuten beruhigen müssen.
Du hast dann einen Hörer, der Deutschlandfunk sagt dann, ja hier,
dann kommen sie doch zu uns in die Sendung.
Diese Leute sind üblicherweise auch den ganzen Tag vorher aufgeregt,
bevor sie dann das erste Mal mit Deutschlandfunk und so und so weiter quatschen.
Und da ist es sich so von dieser Technik da irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Ne, also wenn das in dem Google Browser dann nicht läuft und so,
dann ist das irgendwie total bescheuert. Also wirklich super nervig.
Es ärgert mich ohne Ende.
Ich will nicht Objekt in so einer Medienarbeit sein.
Ich möchte gar nicht sagen, was ich sagen möchte. Ich möchte gar nicht,
dass wir die Zeit dafür haben.
Ja, ich dachte sonst immer, war es beim Radio ja unkompliziert.
Ja, wir haben jetzt hier drei Stunden dreißig schon aufgenommen und fangen jetzt
an, geruhsam über den amerikanischen Wahlkampf zu reden.
Und zwar, liebe deutsche Journalisten, nehmt euch ein Beispiel an den amerikanischen Kollegen.
Ja, also ich komme natürlich immer gerne ins Radio oder zu anderen Sachen.
Ich mache es nur noch per Telefon. Aber natürlich, du weißt,
was jetzt kommt, nur gegen Honorar.
Glaubst du, irgendwer hätte mir da ein Honorar angeboten?
Also ich frage nach.
Danke, dass Sie bereit sind. 15.40 Uhr geht es los. Ach so, es geht erst später
los. und es wird auch nicht klappen und Honorar, da haben wir nicht mehr drüber geredet.
Nein, nein, also ich bin natürlich immer nur gegen Honorar. Es ist absurd.
Ich arbeite nicht gratis.
Ja, ich arbeite absurd auch nicht mehr gratis.
Also ich muss ja nicht im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, sind ja Gelder vorhanden,
warum soll ich da gratis arbeiten?
Ja, ich fand es halt einfach so, die Gelegenheit war gut, weil ich bin ja jetzt
vorbereitet durch die Clips, die wir jetzt heute hören und wenn den Hörer,
und das finde ich ja wirklich, also Applaus dafür,
beim Deutschlandfunk anrufen, sagen, ich habe das im Podcast ein bisschen anders
gehört und die wirklich dazu bringen, Also wahrscheinlich so einen Hörerkommentar
zu schreiben, dass sie motiviert sind. Ja, dann sollten wir das mal aufgreifen.
Sehr gut. Also lieber Hendrik, es tut mir sehr leid, dass es dann doch nicht geklappt hat.
Gut, wir hat das Wall Street Journal, nicht unbedingt verdächtig,
irgendwie halbgare Handlanger Verschwörungstheorien und so zu produzieren.
Wir steigen sanft ein, danach hören wir The Daily.
Wir sind hier am Tag des Urteils. Leute haben sich vorbereitet.
Sie haben gelesen, um was es geht und reden dann so darüber.
Eine der Dinge, die mir in Justiz Sotomayors Entschuldigung gab,
ist, dass sie sagt, dass unter dem Regeln der Präsident jetzt die Navy's SEAL
Team 6 benutzen könnte, um einen politischen Rivalen zu töten und immer noch immun zu sein.
So, SEAL Team 6 is part of the armed forces. Ja, so ein kleiner Snippet.
Die diskutieren das so in diesem Maße aus, aber sie sprechen es halt an.
Das kann man immer noch, ich bin mir unsicher, aber ja, das klingt irgendwie,
also wenn man das zusammenbaut, die Puzzleteile, dann heißt das,
ja, da ist so ein Ziel Team 6 und das kennen wir ja, das hat ja,
oder sagen wir mal, Bin Laden getötet und das könnte man genauso beauftragen,
einen politischen Rivalen im Inland zu beseitigen, ja, das läuft jetzt unter
Official Conduct. Das ist Amtsführung.
Und damit ist das doch irgendwie...
Und wir haben auch gehört, ah ja, das Urteil besteht also aus,
sechs Richter entscheiden etwas, sind die Mehrheit, und dann gibt es aber noch
drei Richter, die haben was zur Einwände.
Und die schreiben die dann auch mit in den Urteilstext. Gehört also zu dem Dokument des Urteils.
Ist aber ein Minderheitenvotum. Also
lauter solche Sachen kann man ja dann durchaus mal erfahren und hören.
Hier die New York Times. Also ein Podcast, von dem ich einfach unterstelle,
alle deutschen Journalisten, die sich mit Politik befassen, hören den.
Aber irgendwie nicht so richtig zu. Also das war der Tenor, der erste Podcast,
der gemacht wurde. natürlich zu diesem Thema.
Um vielleicht die Erkrankung eines politischen Gegnern zu beurteilen und dann
zu sagen, das war ein offizieller Akt, weil als Präsident habe ich Macht über das Militär.
Sieht diese Regelung an, dass diese Immunität zu einer Aktion wie dieser verwendet wird?
Also die Mehrheit handelt nicht mit diesem präzisen Szenario.
Aber die Logik davon ist, dass wenn es Teil des Präsidenten der offiziellen
Dutys ist, er ist Kommandeur in Chief, er ist der Chef-Lau-Enforcement-Officer.
And if it's a plausible application of his official responsibilities,
then yes, he would be immune, even for things as wild as ordering an assassination.
So this immunity is entirely separate and apart from whatever the motivation
of the president is in taking an official act that might ordinarily be seen
as criminal and prosecutable.
So Michael, Chief Justice Roberts actually answers in so many words the question you just asked.
He says, in dividing official from unofficial conduct, courts may not inquire
into the president's motives.
Die Motive sind egal.
Sie sind höchstrichterlich geradezu ausgenommen aus juristischen Betrachtungen.
Die Juristen, die mit solchen Fällen künftig betraut sind, sind verpflichtet,
die Motive des Präsidenten nicht zu hinterfragen.
Und wenn ein Rivalenmord auf dem Felde einer demokratischen Auseinandersetzung
im Sinne von, es findet ja noch eine Wahl statt,
also erschießen wir einfach den
Kandidaten der gegnerischen Partei stattfindet, kommt es nur darauf an,
ob er da irgendeinen Handlanger privat bezahlt hat oder ob das ein offizieller
Akt der Amtsführung war, er also, soweit die Polizei ihm da untersteht,
oder das Militär beauftragt hat.
Und dass das so deutlich gesagt wird und nicht hier ankommt in Deutschland,
von dem ich immer noch denke, das ist doch eine wahnsinnig interessante,
selbst wenn man jetzt nicht mal ein paar Semester oder Seminare Geschichte in der Uni oder irgendwas,
allein so ein Interesse für einen Historienfilm oder so, rechtfertigt doch hier
zu sagen, Momentchen mal, ich weiß, da findet gerade ein Wahlkampf statt,
aber das scheint mir auch ein Thema zu sein.
Das finde ich wirklich haarsträubend, Also es ist wirklich unglaublich und ich
finde es crazy, wie weit das Wall Street Journal und die New York Times das
sofort aufgreifen und so thematisieren und in Deutschland einfach gar nichts dazu.
Ja, Sonja Sotomayor, die Richterin mit einem abweichenden Votum, sagt auch folgendes,
dass die von der Mehrheit definierte Trennlinie zwischen offiziellem und nicht
offiziellem Verhalten,
das als nicht offiziell betrachtete Verhalten fast so weit verengt,
dass nichts übrig bleibt.
Das heißt also, diese Trennlinie, die da gemacht wird, die gibt es in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht.
Amtszeit ist Amtszeit und damit ist alles, wie auch in Deutschland gesagt wurde
von Hebestreit, der Kanzler ist immer im Dienst.
Ja.
Gibt keinen privaten Kanzler. Der Kanzler ist im Dienst, er ist gewählt. Ja.
Aus diesen Minderheitenvoten wird dann hier auch vorgelesen, zum Beispiel bei PBS.
Das sind jetzt zugegebenermaßen keine Nachrichten, die jetzt ganz Amerika,
aber sie sind zumindest flächendeckend, weil das ja auf diese ganzen lokalen
Sender da gestreut wird.
Wenn er seine offiziellen Kräfte in irgendeiner Art und Weise unter der Mehrheit
der Meinung verwendet, wird er jetzt von einer kriminellen Verwaltung verhungert.
Er beurteilt die Navy SEAL Team 6, um einen politischen Rivalen zu töten.
Immun. Er organisiert einen militärischen Krieg, um auf die Macht zu halten.
Immun. Er nimmt eine Verleihung, um eine Verleihung zu bekommen.
Immun. Immun. Immun. Immun. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie mehr direkt als das sein könnte.
Vor allem schreibt sie genau die Fällereien, die ja Trump betreffen.
6. Januar, die ganzen Leute da aufstacheln. Irgendwelche Schweigegelder zahlen.
Kandidaten ausschalten. Immun, immun, immun, alles immun. Also wirklich,
deutlicher kann man es nicht machen.
Katie Kür, das ist dann MSNBC, diskutiert es hier auch mit Gästen.
Das sind alles so Sendungen, die ploppen dann alle so auf, man sieht die so,
man kriegt echt so ein bisschen Nervenkitzel, weil man hat ja wirklich noch so,
keine Ahnung, die letzten Seminare zum dunklen Mittelalter, dass es ja gar nicht
so dunkel war, sondern es war ja im Grunde politisches Geschehen,
nur halt ein bisschen anders und dann denken wir so,
sind wir echt da wieder angekommen, also wird wieder zu Hofe,
Intrigen geschmiedet und dann findet eine große Feier statt,
einfach nur um Leute da zu haben, um die dann abmurksen zu können,
während sie wieder abreißen. so. Also solche Sachen.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass du das hast. Du weißt ja eben etwas abwehrend gegenüber
diesen vielen Orban-Clips, die ich euch zugemutet habe.
Aber sehen wir nicht genau diese Bewegung dahin?
Ja.
Also ich will das ja auch nur konstatieren. Ich sage ja nicht,
Mensch, das ist aber schön, dass wir da wieder angekommen sind. Wir sind da wieder.
Wo wir schon mal waren. Also es ist tatsächlich.
Ja, in veränderter Form natürlich. Die Geschichte wiederholt sich dann nicht ganz. Aber ja.
Heute Atomwaffen.
Es ist ein Ein Interregnum gewesen der liberalen Demokratien und jetzt ist die
Frage, was ist noch zu retten und was muss man dann noch fahren lassen?
Also es geht drunter und drüber.
Which was SEAL Team 6. What if the president orders the assassination of Wir haben übrigens.
Ich erinnere mich noch dran, Clips davon gespielt.
Weil die New York Times hat das schon mal diskutiert, dass nämlich der Supreme
Court bei oder andere Gerichte, die sich damit befasst hatten,
schon mal bei Aussprachen, Informationssammelnd für die Richter,
das Szenario beschrieben bekamen von den Demokraten-Anwälten. Ja.
Dass dieses Szenario hier mitverhandelt wird. Und wir haben das noch gespielt
und haben gesagt, naja, die wollen die nur schocken.
Ja. Stellt sich raus, nee, die wollten die nicht nur schocken,
sondern das Gericht hat genau in diesem Sinne dann entschieden.
... Adversary. And Justice Sotomayor is saying, what about that?
Your test, how does it work?
The argument is going to be made that that is official conduct.
If it's a case-by-case basis, say that happens. Does that then just get litigated? Does it have to go?
Does there have to be an evidentiary hearing first before it's brought to a full trial?
Ich meine, was ist der Prozess, durch den eine Person, die Team 6 verwendet,
um einen politischen Rivalen zu töten, wie sind sie verantwortlich?
Darf ich dir noch ein Beispiel geben, das nicht eine Beratung sein wird?
Es ist jemand, der Präsident sagt dem Staatssekretär, ich möchte,
dass du eine boguse Verhandlung gegen meinen politischen Gegner bringst.
Also nicht Tod, sondern Verhandlung.
Diese Entscheidung sagt, Kommunikation
zwischen dem Präsidenten und dem Staatssekretär ist absolut immun.
Ja, das ist ja das Szenario. Trump ruft irgendwo in der Bundesstadt an und sagt,
findet mir 15.000 Votes.
Dann sagt der Typ, der da verantwortlich ist, nee, das widerspricht ja meiner lokalen Gesetzeslage.
Dann sagt der amerikanische Präsident zu seinem Justizminister,
finde mir Wege, diesen Typ zu verurteilen, egal was.
Denk dir was aus. Also es geht ja nicht nur bei dieser Immunitätsfrage darum,
ist er jetzt zum Mord ermächtigt, sondern alle möglichen Sachen.
Der amerikanische Präsident steht jetzt über der Verfassungsordnung, damit über dem Gesetz.
Und mit über ist halt nicht nur jenseits, sondern über gemeint.
Er hat Weisungsbefugnis für diese Apparate, die ihm dann unterstehen.
Und ich meine, wenn man sich ein bisschen die Geschichte der Republikanischen
Partei ansieht, dann gab es ja immer die Bestrebungen, die Machtfülle des Präsidenten zu erweitern.
Adam McKay hat ja in seinem Film über Dick Cheney das sehr deutlich gemacht,
wie Dick Cheney eigentlich diese Idee, diese Interpretation für Verfassung immer
ganz hoch gehalten hat und dann versucht hat, für George W.
Bush Junior dies auch immer weiter voranzubringen.
Und diese Ausweitung der präsidialen Macht hin, dann bis zu dem letzten Schritt,
dass man ihn eigentlich fast zum König krönt, hat also eine gewisse Geschichte,
woran es aber immer dann doch scheiterte war, dass man nicht so die Gerichte
besetzt hatte, wie man das jetzt geschafft hat.
Und war wahrscheinlich auch, das würde ich doch zumindest einigen Republikanern
unterstellen, gewisses Koppel der Art weit zu gehen.
Also das war ja jetzt nicht die reine Lehre aller Republikaner,
diese Machtfülle unendlich zu erweitern. Aber dennoch war es angelegt und nun
hat man dort einen ganz, ganz entscheidenden Schritt gemacht.
Genau, wir hören jetzt gleich nochmal aus Donald Trumps eigenem Munde,
wie er dieses Gefüge dann sieht, wer da auf wessen Seite steht.
Die Immunitätsfragen werden hier thematisch noch so ein bisschen eröffnet.
Es ist also nicht nur der Konkurrentenmord.
Ja, also hier werden die Richter zitiert vom obersten Gerichtshof,
die sagen, ja, das liegt jetzt irgendwie so eine geladene Waffe.
Das ist die Botschaft der Mehrheit heute.
Ja, das ist ja wirklich super interessant eigentlich, dass wir ja gar keine
Geschichte von juristisch behinderten Präsidenten haben.
Trump ist ja der Erste von über 40 in über 200 Jahren, an der mal irgendwas angeklagt wurde.
Und diese Diskussion wird hier auch geführt mit wirklich martialischen Worten.
Wir hören es erst noch ein bisschen sanfter in diesem Gespräch mit Katie Kuhr.
A president has to have immunity to be energetic and to make decisions that
he needs it in order to do the job of the presidency and that you can't question
it, even when he is trying to use that same power to violate the constitution.
As you read through this, as I said, it was hard to look toward the future and
it felt more like an opinion that was squared solely on the present and the
present case and the present candidate for the GOP nomination.
Also eine Lex Trump. Man hat sozusagen ganz gezielt auf.
Das würde dann auch erklären, warum man jetzt plötzlich 43 Präsidenten konnten
sich benehmen und dann einer nicht.
Das hat man von Ihnen jetzt dieses Dings geschrieben.
Spinnen wir das nochmal ein ganz klein bisschen weiter. Was heißt denn das eigentlich?
Es ist naheliegend, das mit einer Monarchie zu vergleichen, mit einem König,
der gekrönt wird und der dann diese unendliche Macht hat.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass wir es ja trotzdem mit jemandem zu tun haben,
der gewählt wird. Also Könige wurden in der Vergangenheit nie gewählt.
Das heißt, das Volk musste sie ertragen.
Nun wissen wir auch, dass Trump da durchaus flexibel ist Und darüber nachdenkt,
Amtszeiten zu verlängern.
Bei ihm wird wahrscheinlich das biologische Ende die Amtszeit dann beenden.
Er wird jetzt nicht 20 Jahre im Amt sein können, aber wir erleben ja doch in
der Welt immer mehr Staaten, in denen es zwar Wahlen gibt, aber die wir nicht
als demokratisch bezeichnen.
Wir können an Russland denken und Orban tut auch alles, um sich dem möglichst anzuklappen.
Oder hat er schon sehr weit getrieben, dass er in diese Nähe kommt.
Und das ist aber schon interessant, also es gibt noch so eine Rückbindung an einen Wähler.
Da muss mit allen Manipulationen dann versucht werden, diese Wählerstimmen wieder zu bekommen.
Aber es muss noch diese Art der Rückkopplung da sein, die ja auch Trump als
das ansieht, womit er immer wieder auftrumpfen kann, dass er die Stimme des Volkes spricht.
Das heißt, wir haben eine ganz interessante Konstellation eigentlich,
dass man jetzt durch die Urteile in eine Richtung geht, die nach Monarchie aussieht.
Und zugleich gibt es aber noch diese Illusion von Demokratie und Wahl.
Oder nicht mehr.
Oder nicht mehr?
Putin veranstaltet zumindest noch Wahlen, Manduro auch.
Ob Trump das noch macht, ist unklar.
Wir hören gleich Sing-Sang von ihm selbst, es gab ja einen Clip,
der die letzten Tage durch Twitter ging.
Ich will es mal so sagen, wenn ich autoritärer Führer wäre, würde ich auch Wahlen
veranstalten, weil es doch sehr gut ist, immer wieder Partizipation zumindest zu spielen.
Das sorgt für nicht allzu große Unruhen. Also sagen wir so, richtige Diktaturen,
in denen es gar keine Wahlen mehr gibt, sind sehr fragil.
Solange du immer noch so eine Partizipation spielst, funktioniert es eigentlich geschmeidiger.
Ich fand es auch witzig, dass sich nach der Geschichte, in der sich alle drüber
lustig machten, dass die sozialistischen Führer immer 99,8% bekommen und so,
Manduro sich jetzt 51% hat geben lassen von der Wahlkommission.
Also sieht man schon, okay, Zugeständnisse.
Ähm, ja, die autokratischen Führer veranstalten nicht ohne Grundwahlen.
Die Frage ist halt bei Donald Trump, wenn du 78 bist, dann 79,
dann mit 82, warum noch mal eine Wahl veranstalten? Dann doch lieber durchziehen.
Sollen doch die anderen das kommentieren. Die Frage in Amerika ist ja auch immer,
wer soll sie denn veranstalten?
Das ist ja nicht wie in Deutschland, dass du so alle drei Meter ein Wahllokal
hast und dann muss man einfach nur sagen, morgen ist Wahl und dann wird das
sozusagen aktiviert über die lokalen Behörden, sondern du kannst es ja wirklich abbauen.
Du kannst ja wirklich Infrastruktur zurückfahren und es ist eh alles schon ein
Wahlcomputer, also Personen stehen, musst du die Wahlcomputer nicht mehr aus
dem Lager holen und schon kannst du keine Wahl veranstalten.
Oder halt dir ein Bundesstaat raussuchen, wo es total strittig ist, was da passiert.
Und dann dauert es halt sieben Monate, bis das ausgezählt und geklärt und am
Ende sagt der Supreme Court,
Bush hat gewonnen. Also in der Hinsicht, da ist alles offen,
aber bevor wir uns dieser Frage nochmal nähern, zu dieser Geschichte,
die ich so interessant finde, warum jetzt dieses, wir brauchen einen energetischen
Präsidenten, der juristisch unbekümmert
bleibt, weil sie fragt ja schon, nee, aber Präsidenten haben doch das Justizministerium,
Anwälte on site, die können sich doch einfach beratschlagen lassen,
was geht denn jetzt hier nicht und was kann ich tun und da werden die ihnen sagen,
sie können ganz schön viel tun, eine Million Menschen im Irak töten oder was auch immer.
Warum jetzt dieser Shift?
About. And you had Justice Jackson, another is saying, that's not what I'm worried
about. We don't have a history of that.
What we do have is a former president who's under four indictments,
who's saying that when he retakes the presidency, he wants to go after people.
And you also do have a history of presidents who arguably have abused their powers.
Namely, let's just take Richard Nixon.
Man kann natürlich auf die Geschichte schauen und sagen, nee,
diese Sache mit Nixon, die hat uns ganz schön in Turbulenzen gebracht. Musste das sein?
Kann man das nicht einfach durchgehen lassen? Und auf der anderen Seite kann
man natürlich auch immer wieder diese Argumentation, ja mit diesen Politikern
stimmt halt irgendwas nicht.
Und jetzt, da sie sich so einem Medienterror bei Wahlen stellen müssen,
werden nochmal mehr diejenigen ausgesiebt, bei denen irgendwas stimmt.
Naja, nicht hinhaut. Die sind im sozialen Nahfeld schon intrigant hintertrieben
und was auch immer. Im Großen dann erst recht.
Wir brauchen also jetzt neuen Spielraum für diese neuen Präsidenten.
Trump war nur der Erste. Irgendwie so.
Und auch das finde ich aber irgendwie crazy. Joy Reid, deine Frage,
die du aufgeworfen hast, finden nochmal Wahlen statt, wird ja gerade vor allem
von Rachel Maddow behandelt.
Das ist ja nun wirklich die Queen aller Amerika-Korrespondenten für deutschen Journalisten.
Da verstehe ich insbesondere nicht, wie man das einfach da ignorieren kann.
Joy Reid hier bei MSNBC ist ja fast ähnliches Kaliber.
Und sie behandelt mal diese Frage, wie viel Freiheit hatten die Präsidenten eigentlich bisher?
This is from page 110 from the dissent.
This is from Katonji Brown Jackson's dissent, Justice Jackson.
With its adoption of a paradigm that sometimes exempts the president from the
dictates of the law when the court says so,
this court has effectively snatched from the legislature the authority to bind
the president or not to Congress's mandates.
And it has also thereby substantially augmented the power of both the office
of the presidency and itself.
Was John Roberts heute gesagt hat, ist, dass er und seine fünf Kollegen Leonard
Leo-Appointees entscheiden werden, wenn der Präsident erholt hat.
Sie entscheiden, wenn er über die Grenzen des offiziellen Aktes gesteckt hat.
Und nur sie können diese Entscheidung machen.
Ja, kurzer Stopp hier, was auch bedeutet, wenn Kamala Harris gewinnt und irgendein
Gericht befindet, da hat sie aber und so weiter, da steht ja keine Immunität
zu und dann wird der Supreme Court sagen,
ja genau, ihr nicht, weil die nämlich das letzte Wort darüber haben,
haben sie sich halt mit reingeschrieben.
Joe Reed hat dann auch so ein kleines Snippet. Ist ein Trump-Gerücht. Absolut.
Sie beschreibt es dann auch so in diesem Gespräch, wo sie sagt,
Sie haben ja alle Game of Thrones gesehen, da gibt es einen König und einen Hand of the King.
Und dieser stellt immer sicher, dass der König diesen Freiraum hat.
Und dieses Gericht hat nun Trump zum König deklariert und sich selber zum Hand of the King.
Das heißt, wenn Trump irgendwas gefährlich wird, wie eine demokratische Präsidentschaft
oder so, dann sagen die einfach, nö, hier ist gar nichts immun.
Wir befinden, Gerichte sollen schon mal vorsortieren, aber wir machen die letzte
Entscheidung und sagen dann einfach, was ist hier Amtshandlung und was nicht.
Dann wird das alles aussortiert. Bei Trump wird alles unter diesem neuen Diktum lauten.
Und jetzt beschreibt sie aber kurz, was konnten amerikanische Präsidenten bisher
zeigen an Amtshandlungen, ohne juristisch gefährdet zu sein?
Indigenous people to march, along with enslaved people across this country, mainly to their deaths.
How President Lincoln essentially deleted the human property,
10 billion dollars worth of human property, from every state in rebellion by fiat.
How presidents, let's talk about the presidents in the 20th century,
Harry Truman unleashed a nuclear holocaust on two parts of Japan.
He did that boldly and decisively without fear of prosecution.
Wie braucht ein nächster Präsident, ein zukünftiger Präsident,
so viel Stärke, um aus dem Fiat der Supreme Court zu kommen?
Nee, das ist zu wenig Immunität. Also hier muss mehr Bandbreite für energetisches
Handeln und mutige Schritte nach vorne möglich sein,
wo man sich echt fragt, wo ist die Maybrit Illner Sendung zu so einem Fall?
Also das ist doch wirklich unglaublich, was hier gerade vor uns abläuft.
So, jetzt zu dieser Frage, wird es nach der Präsidentschaftswahl 2024 nochmal Wahlen geben?
Rachel Maddow hat es in, also in ihren Sendungen sagt sie es,
betont sie immer wieder und ist dann auch da wirklich anklagend.
In einem Podcast mit K.S. Fisher on, sagt sie so einen ganz kurzen Satz,
also wenn 2024 Trump gewinnt und er 2028 noch gesund und am Leben ist,
wird es keine Präsidentschaftswahlen eingeben.
Und das finde ich für so eine Art Klaus-Kleber-Figur, die so über eine Bundestagswahl spricht.
Das sind einfach Marker in der Diskussion. Die muss man einfach aufgreifen.
Ich verstehe nicht, wo sind die Leitartikel und überhaupt. Gut.
Wird es also nochmal eine Wahl geben? Trump hat jetzt vor wenigen Tagen beim
The Believers Summit vor lauter Christen so Sprüche gemacht mit,
geht doch noch einmal wählen.
Danach haben wir das alles gefixt und dann ist es fein, ihr müsst nur noch einmal wählen.
Danach müsst ihr nicht mehr wählen, nur noch einmal. Mal.
Und dann gab es auf Twitter Diskussionen, auch von Nigel Mayer und so angeführt,
wie hat er das denn gemeint?
Denn ja, der Tenor und der Rede ist auch, liebe Christen, sagt dann Trump,
ihr geht immer nicht wählen.
Eure Wahlbeteiligung ist viel zu gering. Geht doch mal wählen.
Geht wenigstens dieses eine Mal wählen. Danach müsst ihr es auch nicht wieder.
So, das ist die, sagen wir mal, wohlwollende Auslegung dieser Worte.
Ja, das Versprechen wäre dann, diese Dinge, die für euch geregelt werden müssen,
werde ich dann regeln. und deshalb braucht ihr ein nächstes Mal nicht mehr zu wählen.
Genau. Und ich würde jetzt aber sagen, nachdem sich herausgestellt hatte,
dass die Justices des Supreme Court wirkliche Originalisten und Textualisten
sind, wir hatten das an Josh Hawley besprochen, also die,
den Text der Verfassung ernst nehmen, wie wir sagen heute wollen,
denn es steht da so nicht drin, eigentlich hat man den König damit abgeschafft und nicht ermächtigt,
aber solange originalisten und textualisten so mit der Verfassung und dem Text
umgehen, würde ich sagen, gehen wir mal ganz originalistisch und textualistisch
mit Donald Trump um und hören uns an, was er wirklich sagt.
Nicht im Kontext von einer wohlwollenden Auslegung oder so, sondern was sagt er?
Und in dieser Rede beim Believer Summit, ich habe jetzt vier Ausschnitte in
einen Ausschnitt gepackt.
Also diese vier Leuchttürme, um die es geht. Oder es sind drei Leuchttürme,
er sagt zweimal dieses, ihr müsst nur noch einmal wählen.
Er bindet jetzt hier das Supreme Court Urteil mit diesem Spruch,
ihr müsst nicht mehr wählen gehen danach, zusammen.
Und da würde ich mal sagen, das ist der Kontext. Der Kontext ist nicht,
dass die Christen immer wenig wählen gehen und Trump sagt, ihr geht doch noch
einmal wählen, sondern wir hören es jetzt hier eine Minute 40.
Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen das mal ernst.
Ronald Reagan hat das gefühlt, ich habe das gefühlt, viele Leute fühlen das.
Und wir haben wirklich etwas gemacht, was niemandem möglich gemacht hat.
Ich möchte die sechs Supreme Court Justiziarbeiten, Clarence Thomas,
Samuel Alito, John Roberts, Brett Kavanaugh, Neil Gorsuch und Amy Coney Barrett,
für die Wissens- und die Stärke, die sie auf diesem langfristigen und sehr,
sehr kontentionslosen Thema gezeigt haben.
You have to go out, at least this election.
Just give us in, get us into that beautiful White House.
Vote for your Congressmen and women. Vote for your Senators.
We will change this country for the better. This country will be great again
like never before. You gotta vote.
And again, Christians, get out and vote. Just this time.
You won't have to do it anymore. Four more years, you know what?
It will be fixed, it will be fine.
You won't have to vote anymore, my beautiful Christians. I love you,
Christians. I'm a Christian.
I love you. Get out. You gotta get out and vote. In four years you don't have
to vote again. We'll have it fixed so good you're not gonna have to vote.
We are all Americans and together we will show November 5th to be the most important
day in the history of America.
It will be the most important day in our history as a country.
Also.
Also für mich ist die Sache relativ klar oder sagen wir relativ unklar und das
ist ja sehr typisch für Trump.
Erstmal stellt sich ja, zunächst mal stellt sich ja wie bei Orban die Frage,
gut, die reden irgendwas, sie reden mit gespaltener Zunge, was soll gemeint sein?
Aber, dass Trump hier alle Richter noch einmal nennt, ihn gratuliert zu dieser
sehr weisen Entscheidung,
er sich mit ihnen aber schon in eins setzt, ist doch eine für ihn beachtlich
klare Aussage, worauf es hinaus will.
Dann haben wir den Bezug zu Ronald Reagan. Ronald Reagan war ja nicht nur Christ,
sondern auch ein sehr eigenartiger Ausleger der Verfassung.
Schon deshalb, weil er glaubte, dass die Gründerväter der USA diese Verfassung
ja auch gar nicht alleine geschrieben haben, sondern ihnen ein Engel begegnet ist.
Das hat er auch so gesagt.
Als die Fahne da oben über ihm so verschlungen war.
Das heißt… Wir haben es hier mit einem klaren Rückbezug dazu zu tun und damit
ist es sehr logisch, dass er zwar hier nicht explizit sagt, ich werde die Wahlen
abschaffen, dass er hier aber sehr deutlich macht,
naja, wenn ich der Präsident bin, dann bin ich wieder Heiland und so wird er
ja sowieso von vielen jetzt verehrt, seitdem er die Sattentat überlebt hat,
dass in diese Richtung geht die Argumentation.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass, man kann ja über Kontext reden,
aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, ich habe mir auch den längeren Ausdruck da
angesehen, ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass hier nur die Ansage an die Christen
ist, ihr habt da ein paar Probleme,
die erledige ich und dann braucht dem ich nicht mehr mit, was ja auch keinen Sinn ergibt.
Also wenn man ja zum Beispiel, wird er ja, wenn er die Christen adressieren
will, diese sehr religiösen Leute besonders damit abholen können,
dass man ein sehr verschärftes Abtreibungsrecht hat, beziehungsweise Abtreibungen
grundsätzlich untersagt sind.
Das kann er dann fixen in seiner Sicht,
nur muss ja dann der Christ wieder wählen, denn sollte dann ein demokratischer
Präsident kommen nach Trump, würde der ja vermutlich das Abtreibungsrecht wieder
stärker liberalisieren.
Das heißt, man kann ja nicht sagen, ich habe einmal gewählt und dann ist es
für immer gut, es sei denn, es gibt keine Wahlen mehr danach.
Ja, also für mich ist diese Gemengelage hier ziemlich deutlich inzwischen.
Wir müssen nicht auf die Wahl von 2028 warten. Schon 2024 wird ja eine Torpedierung
stattfinden, jedes einzelne.
Trump hat eine riesige Apparatur, es haben dann sogar Leute aus seinem Wahlkampfteam
gefragt, sollten wir die Ressourcen nicht lieber anders einsetzen und Trump,
nein, ich möchte, dass in jedem Wahllokal jemand von uns steht und diese Wahl begutachtet.
Und das ist schon mal eine ernsthafte Bedrohungslage, weil wir wissen ja nicht,
ob da jemand steht, der nur beobachtet oder der nochmal drei Freunde mitbringt
und der ganz genau guckt, wie die Leute da wählen, damit doch alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Außerdem, diese Heritage Foundation und das alles da im Hintergrund,
das hat jetzt Jahrzehnte Anlauf genommen.
Und sie wissen, dieses sakrale Bild ist jetzt nicht verkehrt, Trump ist ihr Heiland.
Niemand funktioniert vor dem Wählerpublikum so wie er. Man sieht ja schon,
dass nur eine Schulter weiter steht in J.D. Vance, der gar nicht funktioniert.
Weder in der Rede, noch im politischen Programm, noch sonst irgendwas.
Also Fail auf aller Linie.
Na, noch nicht. Ich halte das für durchaus möglich.
Okay, also du kannst noch Hoffnung haben, aber Trump ist, was seine mediale,
Rezeptionsfähigkeit angeht, also dass da noch was passiert.
Trump ist eine Jahrhundertfigur. Den hat man nicht nochmal.
Die müssen den jetzt ausbeuten. Und sie legen alles rein, was sie reinlegen können.
Nur sind diejenigen, die danach kommen, auch nicht auf der Seite von Wahlen.
Nein, sind sie nicht. Also wir haben das Buch von Peter Thiel gelesen und wir
können uns denken, dass das alles Leute sind aus diesem, ja wie nennen die sich,
Dark Enlightenment und wir hatten auch mal übrigens eine ausführliche Folge über diese ganzen,
die dort sich in New York versammeln.
Und die jetzt so diese dunkle Seite verkörpern.
Das sind auch alles Leute, die durchaus bereit werden, nochmal darüber nachzudenken,
ob die Demokratie eigentlich so eine tolle Sache ist.
Ja, aber wir können in diesem Falle, und ich nenne jetzt einen Namen,
weil ich wirklich möchte, dass die Dramatik und die Extremität darin verstanden wird.
Ja, sehr viele Leute halten öffentliche Reden. Sehr viele Leute sind durchgeknallt wie Donald Trump.
Man kann auch sagen, sehr viele Leute singen. Aber nur Taylor Swift schafft
es, 70.000 Leute für 1.000 Euro am Abend und dann nochmal 50.000,
die sich auf diesen Olympia-Berg stellen.
Trump ist eine Jahrhundertfigur, weil er die Wähler erreicht,
die alle anderen nicht. Man braucht aber, man muss die Wähler erreichen.
Was ich nur damit sagen wollte ist, wenn Trump jetzt wirklich keine Wahlen mehr
dann macht, erst seit nach seiner zweiten Amtszeit, dann sind die,
die nach ihm kommen aus der republikanischen Partei, also im Lager J.D.
Vance, Peter Thiel, durchaus auch bereit, diesen undemokratischen Kurs weiterzufahren.
Das sind keine Leute, die dann sagen, und jetzt erneuern wir hier unsere Demokratie.
Wenn Trump jetzt gewählt wird, ist das ein dynastisches Gefüge.
Nur mit dem ich werbe ja dafür, aus der Geburtenfolge auszubrechen.
Er wird dann aus der Geburtenfolge ausbrechen. Er wird dann ernennen.
Wer als nächstes dieses Amt? Vielleicht Barron.
Oder halt jenseits der Geburtenfolge. Oder dann einfach wirklich J.D. Vance oder so.
Nur dieses Diese Szenerie, dass man dann irgendwie so ein, nee,
aber die werden ja Widerstand haben, die Leute. Amerika ist ja ein großes,
das kann sich ja wehren und so.
Ja, klar kann sich das wehren, aber wenn die ganze Regierung von diesen Leuten
besetzt ist, kannst du anrufen, wo du willst.
Du erreichst nur Trump-Leute. Da ist niemand mehr, der dann aber da nochmal
und so das irgendwie wieder gerade biegt, sondern nein. Nein,
das ist, glaube ich, es ist immer wieder interessant, wenn man heute über vergangene Zeit spricht.
Alte Kaiser, Napoleon und so. Dann kommt die Frage.
Aber wieso sind die Leute dem so gefolgt? Und dann kann man sagen,
die sind dem nicht gefolgt. Das war einfach der Kaiser.
So wie heute der Kanzler. Da wurde gewählt, der hatte Leute hinter sich,
der hatte die Hoheit über dieses Militär und dann wurde er halt regiert.
Aber der Kaiser wurde ja nicht gewählt.
Sehr viele Kaiser, gerade hier in Frankfurt am Main, wir sind ja nun die Kaiserwahlstädte,
man hat einen kleinen Kreis von 200 Fürstenfamilien und die wählen sich halt einen König.
Okay, aber das ist eine sehr elitäre Wahl. Man hat nicht die Bürgerwählen lassen.
Jaja, genau, aber wir sehen das ja auch in China, dort finden auch aus dem Politbüro
heraus nicht nur Intrigen und Morde statt, sondern die sagen dann auch mal Hand
hoch, wer ist jetzt dafür und dann wählen die halt jemanden zu.
Also Wahl, nicht demokratische Wahl, sondern Wahl im kleinen Kreise.
Da wird erstmal der Hof abgeschottet und dann findet da halt irgendeine Zeremonie statt oder so.
Und es gibt gar keinen Grund zu glauben, dass wir heute durch irgendetwas geschützt
sind von diesen Zuständen.
Also man wird sich in 200 Jahren genauso fragen, wieso sind die alle den Trump
gefolgt damals und so. So wie wir uns fragen, wieso war Napoleon so erfolgreich?
Ja, weil das formale Gefüge war halt so.
Und dann zogen die halt in den Krieg und haben Länder erobert.
Und so ist Geschichtsschreibung. Wie wird das jetzt in Deutschland diskutiert?
Ja, aber es ist ja genau das, was ich eben auch demonstrieren wollte mit Orban.
Das ist Geschichtsschreibung, die stattfindet. Also wir können das alles kritisch
sehen und sollten es auch tun, aber das ist die Geschichtsschreibung, die stattfindet.
Fällt mir trotzdem schwer, Orban zuzuhören, wie er sagt, also die Philosophie
des Krieges sagt, da geht es um Leben und Tod und nicht um was weiß ich.
So, wir hören nur mal einen ganz kleinen Auszug, wie das hier so in Deutschland diskutiert wird.
Du willst eigentlich gar nicht, dass Orban das Wort Philosophie in den Mund nimmt.
Ja, es ist so.
Ja.
Apokalypse und Filterkaffee am 2. Juli.
Also die erste Sendung, nachdem das passierte. Wir hören Markus Feldenkirchen und Jasmin M. Barek.
Clip erschöpft sich relativ zügig.
Gott sei Dank.
Auch pikant in dem Kontext, bevor ich dich frage, wen du da so siehst.
Trump errang jetzt just gestern einen Teilsieg bei der Immunitätsfrage vor dem Supreme Court.
Das heißt, für offizielle Amtshandlungen gilt auch bei ihm Immunität.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Was glaubst du?
Anders gefragt, unser Experte Markus Feldenkirchen. wer sollte Kandidat werden
und die Demokraten im November retten?
Ja. Also da gab es so ein kleines Teilsieg-Ding und der hat jetzt auch Immunität.
Also wer soll denn jetzt Kandidat werden?
Ja, aber bei offiziellen Handlungen, sagst du, das ist ja auch eine Irrsinn.
Es ist. Und die Frage ist ja, wer soll denn jetzt Kandidat werden?
Die deutsche Debatte. Wir hören viel die News von Sascha Lobo und seiner Frau.
Es gäbe ja eine Figur, wo du gerade gesagt hast, dann sind alle zerstritten.
Und das ist wirklich ein Szenario. Es gäbe ja eine Figur, wenn man sie aufstellen
würde auf dem Parteitag der Demokraten, dann hätte sie eine Riesenchance.
Die einzige eigentlich. Die einzige, ja. Where should I start? Michelle Obama.
Ich habe den Podcast begonnen mit, ich sehe amerikanisches YouTube und freue mich darüber.
Ich freue mich damit, ich kriege da positive Emotionen.
Es ist geile Unterhaltung, da wird es mal auf der Augenhöhe gemacht,
wie das gemacht werden sollte. Heute, dann höre ich deutsche Podcasts,
in denen mir nochmal Michelle Obama als der große, das Land einigende Kandidat vorgestellt wird.
Ja und in den Tagesthemen das Lachen der Kamala Harris.
Also wirklich, dass es so jenseits von allem ist, das muss man gar nicht kommentieren.
Abgesehen davon, Michelle Obama wollte nicht mal, dass Barack Obama zu einer
zweiten Amtszeit antritt.
Wo kann der Glaube herkommen, dass sie das möchte, dass sie es mit Inbrunst
macht, dass das ganze Land dahinter steht?
Ich meine, wir haben seit 1978
nur Bushs, Clintons und Obamas auf diesem Zettel, den man wählen kann.
Und jetzt nochmal ein Obama, das ist die Hoffnungs-, also das ist wirklich jenseits
von allem. Aber gut. Gut.
Das Attentat, was soll man dazu sagen? Es ist irre.
Pass auf, ich habe was Lustiges.
Oh, du hast Inhalte zum Attentat. Also Lustiges habe ich auch.
Was habe ich als erstes gedacht, als ich das, ich kam, also ich kam von einem Abend wieder, der,
also wir haben eine Flaschen geleert und dann kam ich also zurück,
hatte noch den Laptop an, wollte ihn eigentlich ausmachen, sah aber dann gerade
bei Twitter, oh, was ist denn da passiert?
Und in diesem Moment, nicht ganz nüchtern, erinnerte ich mich,
dass Peter Sloterdijk doch mal so ein Szenario skizziert hat.
Und da habe ich gedacht, ah ja, da musst du morgen nochmal dran denken,
dann habe ich es rausgesucht.
November 2016 schreibt Peter Sloterdijk in der Zeit.
Mhm.
Die wirkliche Frage der kommenden Tage wird also nicht sein,
wie man den widerstehlichen Aufstieg eines politischen Ehrlichs verhindert,
sondern was man ab jetzt tun sollte, um die Zeit danach zu gestalten.
Seien wir realistisch. Die Chance von Donald Trump, die ersten zwei Jahre seiner
Amtszeit zu überleben, liegt vermutlich bei kaum mehr als 10%.
In einem Land mit einer so ausgeprägten Tradition des Schießens auf Präsidenten
wäre ein mehr als zweijähriges Durchhalten eine Anomalie.
Sofern der politische Mord eine Kategorie ist, die über das Gegebensein oder
Nicht-Gegebensein einer Demokratie entscheidet, So waren die USA nie mehr als
eine hypothetische Demokratie.
Das Schießen auf Präsidenten blieb in diesem Land immer eine aktive Option.
Wenn das Second Amendment von 1791 das Waffentragen zum Bürgerrecht erklärte,
aus europäischer Sicht ein Kapitalverbrechen gegen den Geist der Verfassung,
so konnte das überdehnte Notwehrrecht auch vor den Trägern der Staatsgewalt nicht Halt machen.
Es gibt kein Land in der Welt, in dem die Idee der Legal Defense so breit in
den kollektiven Empfindungen verankert ist.
Ja, J.D. Vance steht auf der Bühne und jubelt über seine Oma,
die 19 Waffen in ihrem Haus versteckt hatte, damit sie sich immer verteidigen kann.
Alle jubeln zu. Mir kommt es auch nicht in den Kopf, wie man hier einfach sagen
kann, ja, wir haben dieses Selbstverteidigungsrecht und Waffen,
aber wenn auf Trump geschossen wird, geht das nicht. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Weil das ist doch irgendwie, das liegt doch echt in der Natur der Sache irgendwie.
In gewisser Weise schon. Wir müssen jetzt hier deutlich unterstreichen,
dass wir nicht aufrufen zum Morde an Trump.
Wir sind ja hier nur Zuschauer.
Obwohl wir keinen RBB-Podcast haben, den wir verlieren könnten.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Aber das war ja dann die andere große El Hotzo-Debatte. Die machen wir aber
jetzt hier nicht auf, oder?
El Hotzo hat geschrieben, ich liebe es, wenn Faschisten sterben.
So wie ich das verstehe in diesem deutschen Diskurs die letzten 75 Jahre,
80, sagen das relativ viele Leute.
Niemand würde jetzt sagen, ach, dass der Hitler damals gestorben ist,
ist ja echt blöd, so ein guter Faschist.
Also diese Todeswünsche, gerade 20. April, nee, nicht 20. April,
sondern Stauffenberg-Attentat, das war damals auch kürzlich.
Genau.
So, da wird es hoch und runter diskutiert.
Entschuldigung mal, wir haben Inglourious Basterds, wo man sich daran ergötzt,
dass die die Nazis zur Strecke bringen.
Jetzt ist dann die Frage, also ich will mir das auch nicht zu eigen machen,
diese Argumentation, das ist auch nicht meine Art von Humor.
Nein, ich will nur sagen, Hotzo hat nicht geschrieben, Trump soll sterben,
sondern der Satz, der solitär für sich dann steht, ist einfach,
ich liebe es, wenn Faschisten sterben. Dass er vorher auch über Trump gesprochen hat.
All das bedeutet natürlich, also... fasse ich Trump als Faschisten auf. Das tun einige.
Ich glaube, dass der Begriff Faschismus da nicht so weit führt.
Also es gibt faschistoide Tendenzen. Ich glaube, der Begriff führt nicht so
weit. Was ich aber doch deutlich sagen will, ist, dass er nicht zum Mord aufgerufen hat.
Also dass es etwas völlig anderes
ist. Und was ich dann beobachtet habe in sehr vielen Podcasts und in,
Artikeln und Diskussionen darüber, ist, dass wir ganz interessante Verhältnisse
haben, wenn wir unterscheiden müssen zwischen zwischen subjektiver und objektiver
Gewalt. Ich will ein ganz simples Beispiel bringen.
Wenn Leute im Podcast sagen, die Ukrainer müssen jetzt weiterkämpfen,
impliziert das ja natürlich, dass ganz viele weitere Leute sterben.
Sie sollen ja weiterkämpfen im Sinne von andere Menschen töten.
Wenn man sagt, das Leiden in Gaza ist schlimm, aber es hilft nichts,
Israel muss weiter so vorgehen, keine Sanktionierung.
Ich gehe noch einen Schritt weiter. Wenn man als konservativer Politiker in
einer Talkshow sitzt und sagt, wir müssen Frontex stärker ausbauen und wir müssen
mit aller Härte gegen illegale Migration vorgehen.
Kein Problem.
Das bedeutet aber, es ersaufen Menschen im Meer oder werden dahin zurückgebracht, dass sie dort ersaufen.
Das ist aber alles nur objektive Gewalt. Wenn ich in einer Talkshow sitze und
sage, man müsste Politiker XY ohrfeigen.
Oh, Aufruf zur Gewalt. Da brauche ich noch gar nicht beim Mord zu sein.
Und das ist interessant, dass wir, also ich finde gut, dass wir jetzt nicht
Leute ständig animieren zum Morden oder was weiß ich.
Nur ich will sagen, es gibt eine interessante Differenz zwischen subjektiver
und objektiver Gewalt und so ist es mir aufgefallen im Podcast.
Die sagen, weiter muss der Krieg gegen die Ukraine, Gaza, ja ist halt so.
Aber jetzt mit höchster Sensibilität, mit wahnsinnig viel philosophischem Rüstzeug
wird darüber gesprochen, warum man jemandem nicht den Tod wünschen sollte etc.
Und das finde ich interessant, dass man jetzt plötzlich das heilige einzelne
Leben plötzlich da so sieht und ich finde diese moralische Debatte kann man auch durchaus führen.
Nur bei den anderen Sachen sagt man, naja ist halt Krieg.
Also ich finde es insbesondere verworren, weil wir gerade gelernt haben,
dass die schießende Auseinandersetzung in einem amerikanischen Wahlkampf jetzt
höchstrichterlich erlaubt wurde, dass selbst Beweise,
die diese Fälle dann betreffen würden, verboten sind vor Gericht einzusetzen.
Dass das Motiv des Schießenden nicht hinterfragt werden darf und dann darf man
keinen Witz darüber machen der auf den dieses Gesetz abzielt in einem Land in dem sich seine Partei,
seit Jahrhunderten dafür ausspricht dass wirklich jeder bewaffnet ist also.
Ich finde dass man immer.
Das ist doch genau die Humorgrundlage das will.
Ich auch nochmal hier ganz deutlich.
Machen dass.
Witze darüber erlaubt sind und dann ist es auch erlaubt die geschmacklos zu finden oder nicht.
Ich will ganz deutlich sagen.
Das ist ja gerade das Verrückte, dass jemand wie Elon Musk permanent auf Twitter
menschenfeindliche Positionen teilt, in ganz aggressiver Weise,
dann aber im Falle von El Hotzo, getriggert dadurch von irgendeiner rechten
Influencerin, den Bundeskanzler anschreibt öffentlich auf Twitter,
was ist denn hier eigentlich los?
Bloß finanziert ihr mit Steuern, Geldern jemanden, der zum Mord an Trump aufruft
und dann der RBB auch noch einknickt und sagt, den entlassen wir jetzt und dann
gab es ja noch ein anderes Gespräch im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
das durfte auch nicht mit Al-Hod so geführt werden, dass man so weit geht,
da muss ich sagen, das ist ja Cancel Culture in reinster Form und zeigt ja auch,
dass diese ganzen anderen,
die immer von der Woken Cancel Culture waren, hier absolut dabei sind,
wenn jemand irgendwie seinen Job verliert. könnte.
Finde ich auch, finde ich auch. Das einzige, was man machen kann,
ist Humorkritik, denn es gibt halt bessere Witze zum Thema J.D.
Vance hat Sex mit einem Sofa und so.
Darauf sollte man sich dann beziehen. Apropos Elon Musk.
Pete Sousa, also Obamas Haus- und Hoffotograf, der ihn acht Jahre lang im Weißen
Haus minütlich begleitet hat.
Immer. Er war immer dabei, egal wo, im Ausland, überall.
Der kennt sich sehr gut aus mit Fotos.
Deswegen hat ihn ja Obama ausgewählt. Und er weiß, ohne Erschrocken,
man muss hier einfach alles und man kann alle Fotos hinterfragen.
Er fragte also auf Twitter, schaut euch mal dieses AP-Foto an und dann schaut
euch genau sein Ohr an, dass Hit in Anführungszeichen getroffen wurde.
Ach, schreibt er, ja?
Ja, woraufhin er gesperrt wurde. Denn Mr.
Free Speech Arena, Elon Musk, deswegen hat er Twitter gekauft,
damit dort endlich wieder alles gesagt werden darf, möchte solche Diskussionen
nicht haben. Selbst die Bild hat jetzt diese Fotos aufgegriffen.
Trumps Ohr sieht gut aus. Seine Umfragewerte nicht.
Also selbst die umschiffen das Thema nicht so ganz. Ich finde dieses,
auch die Überschrift, alles wieder in Ordnung.
Die Frage mit dem Ohr wird bleiben. Und liebe Hörer, keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien.
Diese Republikaner, die jetzt wissen, dass Trump ihre Jahrhundertfigur ist und
damit ihr Vehikel in diese Machtposition, die sie sich jetzt schon bereitet
haben über das Supreme Court Urteil, sind zu allem bereit.
Damit meine ich nicht, dass auf Trump nicht geschossen wurde.
Aber zumindest bei diesen Inszenierungsfragen, die stattfanden,
bei dem Ausmaß des Schadens, das wir sehen und so weiter, gibt es durchaus ein
paar Fragen, die darf man auch stellen.
Die Anlaufstelle dafür ist die New York Times. Die kümmert sich rührend um diesen Fall.
Sie ist mit Drohnen darüber geflogen, hat alles in 3D nachgebaut.
Also die Die kümmern sich wirklich darum, was da passiert ist.
Die Frage ist dann auch organisational, warum ist 100 Meter jenseits des Präsidenten
schon Region der lokalen Polizei und nicht mehr der Secret Service?
Also da gibt es durchaus ein paar Fragen, die merkwürdig sind.
Sehr witzig fand ich Mark Zuckerberg zum Attentat, denn das müssen wir danach auch nochmal.
Ich will diese Szenerie mal anders beschreiben. Donald Trump kriegt diesen Schuss,
merkt, irgendwas ist mit mir, ich geh mal in Deckung.
Dann weiß er, es stürzen sich Leute auf ihn, die ihn beschützen.
Die warten auf den Zuruf. Täter ist ausgeschaltet, wir können Trump evakuieren.
Dieses kleine Szenerieding hat ungefähr 40 Sekunden gedauert.
Trump weiß also, ah, der Zuruf kam gerade, keine Gefahr mehr,
es geht jetzt nur noch um einen Abtransport. Ich stehe auf und inszeniere mich.
Ja, was er immer tut.
So, genau. Zum einen würde ich sagen, es ist jetzt mal ganz wichtig zu verstehen,
diese, also ob man jetzt auf die Rede drei Tage nach dem Attentat oder auf die
Geste 40 Sekunden danach wartet, ist egal.
Nee. Er ist so durchtrieben.
Nein, aber das ist ja, also ich würde schon sagen, unter reinen performativen
Gesichtspunkten ist Trump,
und du hast ihn ja als Jahrhunderttalent beschrieben, derjenige,
der in genau einer solchen Situation bereit ist, alles für die Show zu geben.
Aber jetzt gilt die Frage für deutsche Journalisten. Jemand,
der das kann, der dazu bereit ist, das zu machen, zu was ist er noch allem bereit?
Und die Antwort lautet, zu allem.
Wir können uns nicht vorstellen, was Donald Trump bereit ist und seine Hinterleute,
um diese Präsidentschaft zu erringen.
Umso mehr werbe ich dafür, ja, es ist ein bisschen verdruckst,
dass wir das so auf irgendwelche Personen zuschneiden, dieses ganze Ding.
Diese großen Schicksalsfragen und uns dann die ganze Zeit fragen,
ja ist er dann inhaltlich richtig aufgestellt? Nein, Inhalte spielen jetzt keine Rolle mehr.
Auch im Vorgriff auf Unhaltbarkeit, im Rückgriff auf Selk.
Ja, es gab mal Theorien zur Demokratie. Und diese Demokratien waren durchseucht
mit Moral hier, Inhalte da, Programm da, was auch immer.
Demokratie ist das Ringen um Macht. Alles andere ist sekundär.
Das Sekundäre heißt sekundär, weil es austauschbar ist. Eins ist nicht austauschbar.
Es ist ein Wettkampf um die Macht.
Alles, was Macht vergrößert...
Ist hier in den Blick zu nehmen. Alles, was Macht verringert,
ist auch in den Blick zu nehmen, weil es dann sozusagen aufs Minuskonto,
kann er die Wahl gewinnen oder nicht, im Horse Race einzahlt.
Aber bei der Frage, wie kann der Weg zur Macht aussehen?
Ich weiß, wir haben die letzten Jahrzehnte politische Diskussionen,
Debatten, Diskussionen, alles vorbei.
Diese Machtfrage, wie Niklas Luhmann sie beschrieben hat, ist jetzt wirklich ernst zu nehmen.
Wir können jetzt sagen, diese Soziologie hatte Recht.
Die Machtfrage, dieser Code, ist primär. Alles andere findet auf der Programmebene statt.
Die einen versuchen es mit Debatte und Argument, die anderen versuchen es mit,
was weiß ich für Inszenierung.
Und so muss man das jetzt auch betrachten. Man muss jetzt auf der Augenhöhe
mit dem Moment, mit dem Augenblick sein.
Diese nächsten Monate bis zum November werden, ich will es nicht zu dramatisch
sagen, Aber das Stauffenberg-Attentat hatten wir schon, das Ermächtigungsgesetz
hatten wir schon, was noch fehlt ist der Reichstagsbrand.
Hier gibt es noch große Aktionen. Oktober-Surprise hieß das immer,
als es noch die üblichen Zeiten waren.
Jetzt muss man sich auf alles einstellen. Es wird hier wirklich sehr,
sehr, sehr gefährlich die nächsten vier Monate.
Und ja, man wird sich jetzt noch bis 7. August mit der Frage beschäftigen,
ist ein Astronaut der richtige Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat und so.
Aber hier, finde ich, sollte man die Sachen ernst nehmen.
Das heißt, du plädierst für Show, für die beste Performance.
Darauf muss man sich konzentrieren, um die Macht zu erhalten.
Ja, Peter Kümmel hieß er, glaube ich, der ehemalige Zeit-Theaterkritiker und so weiter.
Der hat damals den Wahlkampf von Schröder gegen Stoiber nach seinen Kriterien ausgewertet.
Theater. Arte.
Harald Schmidt, genau, hat das gelesen in der Sendung, weil er es herausragend
fand und ich würde sagen, da steckt auch eine Logik drin.
Klar brauchen wir jetzt Theaterkritiken für das, was da stattfindet und kein
politischer Journalismus im alter Gebrachten.
Nein, Moment. Also ich glaube, man muss nochmal unterscheiden zwischen einem
analytischen Journalismus, den man braucht und wir lesen ja dann hier gern die
Journalisten, die uns aufklären darüber,
was meint eigentlich dieses Urteil in Bezug auf Trumps Machtfülle.
Das heißt, das braucht es ja weiterhin.
Was nur jetzt strategisch zu tun ist von Seiten der Demokraten oder generell,
wenn wir über Parteien reden, wir haben ja schon mal über die Linke und deren
Kleidungsstil gesprochen,
da muss man glaube ich diese Performance-Strategien beherzigen und kann nicht
sagen, ja wir wünschen uns aber irgendwas,
es wäre doch besser, wenn da so und so jemand wäre.
Man muss sich schon die Frage stellen, wer funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Kamala Harris am Ende funktioniert. Das wird sich dann zeigen.
Ich glaube aber schon, dass es, wenn man einen Konkurrenten wie Trump hat,
die richtige Frage ist, die man sich zu stellen hat.
Hat im Prinzip ja auch in Bezug zum Beispiel auf die AfD, wenn man da jemanden
hat wie Maximilian Krah, dann kommt man da nicht weiter, indem man einfach nur
sagt, wir haben mal einen Bürgerrat zum bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen gemacht.
Absolut. Zu diesem Trump-Foto will ich außerdem noch eine Anmerkung von Vincent Heiges machen.
World Press Photo Award Winner 2024.
Er hat im Deutschlandfunk, im Medias Res, in der Sendung Folgendes gesagt.
Ich meine, wer ist Donald Trump? Wer hat in all den letzten Jahren viel,
viel Gewalt verherrlicht?
Den Sturm aufs Kapitol, Charlottes Wille, ich meine, das könnte jetzt ewig gehen.
Und jetzt schafft er es auf einmal, sich als Opfer dieser Gewalt,
die er eigentlich seiner Rhetorik erst sehr, sehr stark angefacht hat, darzustellen.
Und deswegen finde ich die Entscheidung vom Time Magazine sehr,
sehr schwierig, ich als Cover zu nehmen.
Es gibt von diesem Moment auch noch andere Bilder, zum Beispiel ein Bild von
einem Reuters-Kollegen, Brandon McDamitt.
Ganz kurz nachdem die Schüsse gefallen sind, entstanden sind.
Und dort sieht man Trump zusammengesunken, verbrechlich am Rednerpult und der
Secret Service ihn stützend.
Ja, das erzeugt eine ganz andere Wirkung. Da sieht man, wohin Gewalt führt und
was eigentlich die Folgen davon sind.
Und mit diesem Bild inszeniert man Trump eigentlich als Widerstandskämpfer.
Und vor allem, wenn man dann sich überlegt, wie Biden gerade dargestellt wird
in der Öffentlichkeit, ist natürlich das für Trump jetzt einfach ein perfekter
Pool, sich so darzustellen.
Es ist schon so hilfreich und so weiterführend, wenn jetzt Texten der Journalisten,
in dem Fall im Radio, sagen, wir
fragen jemanden, der sich mit Bildern auskennt, was der jetzt dazu sagt.
Der klar diesen Moment zwischen Ereignis und die ersten inszenatorischen Nachwehen markiert.
Der nicht darauf reinfällt, dass sich da schon jemand inszeniert und das Bild
deswegen natürlich attraktiver aussieht, sondern der sich fragt,
was zeigt eigentlich das Bild? Und es gibt Bilder, wie Trump da zusammengesackt
und blutend und was auch immer.
Und die hätte man genauso zeigen können, sofern man sagt, und das ist ja auch
noch eine Frage, die man zu hinterfragen ist,
klar haben wir einen Chefredakteur, aber wenn jemand auf den Präsidenten schießt,
übernimmt der die Rolle des Chefredakteurs und diktiert uns,
was wir berichterstatten, nämlich, dass es da einen Schützen gab und so weiter und so fort.
Das sind ja auch alles Fragen, die man mal, braucht man überhaupt Bilder von
solchen Ereignissen? Kann man nicht einfach sozusagen, klar,
das wirkt total irrational, wie ich das sage, in diesem Zeitalter 2024,
aber können die Journalisten manchmal auf Bilder auch verzichten?
Beziehungsweise kann man nicht auch ein aufgeklärtes Publikum sich heranzüchten, das bereit ist,
dieses Bild als Komposition zu würdigen, dann aber nicht alles andere noch damit zu verbinden.
Also ich würde ja sagen, es ist schon ein ikonisches, geniales Bild und man
kann jetzt sagen, diese Genialität an sich beeindruckt mich,
ohne dass ich daraus Schlussfolgere und deshalb wähle ich Donald Trump.
Ich empfehle sehr nochmal diesen Film Civil War, der wurde ja sehr verrissen
von der Kritik, völlig zu Unrecht, das ist ja eigentlich eine Philosophie über
Fotografie, den perfekten Moment, Kriegsfotografie, welche Verantwortung hat der Fotograf?
Und inwieweit ist der Fotograf immer Komplize?
Ich empfehle wirklich, dass Seher sich jetzt mal unter genau diesem,
oder sagen wir so, man muss eigentlich sich diesen Film ansehen und erst einmal
weggehen davon, dass das irgendwas mit dem heutigen Amerika zu tun hat.
Weil sonst kommt man in so einen direkten, ach ja, und das ist schon die Vision,
wie das unter Trump werden wird. Das glaube ich jetzt eher nicht.
Das ist auch nicht die Intention des Films, sondern es geht wirklich darum,
zu zeigen, wie Bilder funktionieren, wie die Macht von Bildern funktioniert.
Es zeigt aber auch, wie ein Bürgerkrieg aussehen könnte. Ja.
Also unser Kumpel Olli ist ja auch Fotograf, Bürgermeisterfotograf,
Land des Ministerpräsidentinnen, Kandidatenfotograf.
Der kennt sich wirklich aus mit Bildern. Und dieses Bild taucht auf.
Und Olli meint auch, nee, das ist irgendwie, das ist ein zu perfektes,
also es ist einfach ein perfektes Bild.
Sagen wir mal so. Nicht zu perfekt, sondern es ist einfach ein perfektes Bild.
Und wenn die Fotografen sagen, das ist ein wirklich wahnsinnig perfektes Bild,
heißt das, dann ist jetzt besonders intellektuelle Arbeit gefragt.
Was es bedeutet, wie es passieren kann und wie man damit umgeht.
Was man dann sieht, ist ja selbst so ein großes, spontanes, zufälliges Ereignis
wie ein Attentatsversuch.
Kann innerhalb von wenigen Tagen schon wieder hinausgespielt wurden,
obwohl doch die Dramaturgie Attentat, zwei Tage sieht man ihn nicht und der
erste öffentliche Auftritt ist die Nominierungsrede beim Parteitag. Ist ja erstaunlich, ne?
So, bei diesem Parteitag, den wir jetzt nicht groß thematisieren,
außer dass wir vielleicht kurz 15 Sekunden Ezra Klein hören,
wie er einem New York Times Kollegen nacherzählt, wie das da war.
Auf das Transkript dieses Textes kommen wir im Salon zurück.
Nun hat Trump sich dort für J.D. Vance entschieden, von dem wir inzwischen alle
wissen. Er hat Trump schon mal als Hitler bezeichnet.
Naja, er hat sich die Frage gestellt, ob er der nächste Hitler sein könnte.
Das ist nämlich, von all diesen Zitaten ist dieses frühe, was wir dann relativ
zügig bekommen haben und der wird ja nun wirklich kreuz und quer in Schuss genommen
von seinen ehemaligen Freunden.
Die New York Times wirklich Aufmacher-Texte, wie das da mit seiner damaligen
Kommilitonin war und so.
Gut, er hat also in dieser Facebook-Nachricht an einen Bekannten damals geschrieben.
Ich schwanke zwischen der Ansicht, dass Trump ein zynisches Arschloch wie Nixon
ist, das nicht so schlimm wäre, und vielleicht sogar nützlich.
Oder, dass er Amerikas Hitler ist.
Nun wissen wir, Amerikas Hitler ist er nicht. Es gibt nur einen Hitler,
also diese Singularität wollen wir mal nicht infrage stellen.
Kann natürlich immer noch irgendwas Krasses passieren, aber Trump ist ja auch alt und so.
Dieser Halbsatz in Klammern,
Es könnte sein, dass er ein zynisches Arschloch und so weiter.
Vielleicht aber nützlich.
Das ist ja der Gedankengang hinter Peter Thiel. Ich brauche hier nützliche Leute.
Und in diesem Text von Jeffkin über Peter Thiel, das wir gelesen haben im Januar
21 oder Januar 22, eine Januar-Ausgabe, war es ja so, dass da einige Namen genannt
wurden, die Peter Thiel hofiert.
Josh Hawley, Cruz aus Texas, das waren aber nur Protégés.
Ja.
J.D. Vance wird als Erweiterung von Thiel beschrieben in diesem Text.
Also es ist wirklich eine 1 zu 1 Vererbung von Peter Thiels Denken in praktisches
politisches Handeln über die Person J.D. Vance.
Berufliches. Venture Capitalist. Er ist jemand, der ganz eng in dieser Welt
drin ist. dieser Art der CEOs, also das sind ja auch nochmal andere Leute als jetzt Tim Cook.
Und er ist ein sehr guter Freund aus dem Sohne-Kreis Trumps.
Wir wissen von Trump, dass er sich auch auf große Sachen nicht unbedingt vorbereitet.
Er lässt sich halt einen Teleprompter hinstellen und weicht darüber mal ab und
dann schliert er sich wieder ein.
Meine Arbeitshypothese ist, Trump hat Vance selber erst da kennengelernt.
Als man ihm eine Woche vorher gesagt hat, es wäre noch cool,
den und guck mal hier und auch der Peter ist dafür und so.
Aber dafür ist J.D. Vance schon wirklich zu populär. Also der ist ja.
Ja, aber die Auswahl als Vizep Kandidat hat man Trump glaube ich angedient,
bevor Trump das selbst durchdacht hat und dann hat er ihn einfach da so hingestellt.
Ich bin mir da unsicher.
Ich glaube J.D.
Vance ist aber ein unglaublich berühmter Mann in den USA, dank seiner Hillbilly-Elegie.
Auch Scholz hat geweint, als er das Buch las. Alles, ich weiß.
Aber das heißt noch Die mischen da schon sehr lange mit. Du hast vielleicht
auch diesen Artikel in der Vanity Fair gelesen.
Den bringe ich im Salon. Aber als Zusammenfassung, weil da nämlich programmatisch
drinsteht, was das ist. Genau, diesen Vanity Fair Text habe ich dann dabei.
Nun gut, also egal wie, meine Apotheke ist, Trump ärgert sich gerade sehr,
dass er da nicht vorher ein bisschen mehr IQ draufgelegt hat.
Also eigenen IQ, nicht Berater IQ.
Denn ich glaube, er fühlt sich da ein bisschen ausgeliefert. Und J.D.
Vance funktioniert vor allem nicht auf der Ebene, auf der Trump weiß,
dass man da funktionieren muss.
Was bedeutet, dass sich gerade so Enttäuschung aufstaut bei der Frage,
warum läuft es in der Kampagne nicht so richtig?
Und dann wird Trump, er will niemanden unter den Bus werfen,
das ihn mitbeschädigt, aber er will auch nicht, dass er als der Loser dasteht.
Also muss er einen Loser auserkören und es wird dann J.D.
Vance sein. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wann das passiert. Aber.
Noch bevor Parteitag, Attentat, J.D.
Vance und so weiter sitzt Kevin McCarthy bei Fox News und beschreibt dort im
Grunde das Drehbuch, das heute den Demokraten unterstellt wird.
President, that he had problems. Die Wall Street Journal hat eine in-depth-Story
gemacht und sie haben uns auf das Thema geäußert, basierend auf meinen Reaktionen
und Erfahrungen mit ihm.
Jetzt sehen Sie, dass Präsident Biden die nächsten fünf Tage braucht.
Er muss die nächsten fünf Tage überleben, wenn er weitergehen wird.
Es ist immer noch schwer, ihn zu entfernen, wenn er nicht bereit ist, es zu tun.
Aber sie runden die Wagen hoch, um sie zu umdrehen, und es wird täglich schwieriger.
So, es ist genau so gekommen. Er hat sich für J.D. Vance entschieden.
Weil er sich selber, aber dann der Diversity-Pick jünger ausgesucht hat.
Damit ist dieses Ticket klar. Also es kann genauso wenig verändert werden,
wie dass man jetzt, ja geht Joe Biden, da muss wirklich eine Nahtoderfahrung
her, damit das passiert.
So und jetzt steht aber eine Frau, die ihrerseits als Running Mate nun wirklich
all in einen weißen Mann höheren Alters nehmen kann.
Und was ja in Sachen von, ja, dem vertrauen wir in der Wählerschaft immer noch am meisten.
Und wenn sie jetzt irgendwie Mark Kelly oder sowas nimmt, der ehemalige Astronaut
und der ganze Kram, dann stehen die beiden wirklich ein bisschen im luftleeren
Raum. Also die ganze Debatte wie bisher geplant.
Wir argumentieren hier nicht zu direkt, aber zum Thema Alter,
wir gehen hier so auf und so.
Also die Vorschläge, wie Ezra Klein jetzt diese Chance nutzen möchte,
die finde ich wirklich krass klug und gut geschrieben.
Das lesen wir dann im Salon. ich will jetzt sozusagen, wenn wir schon bei Kevin
McCarthy waren, bevor das passierte, er hat sozusagen das Playbook schon mal hingelegt.
Ja, die lassen die da auflaufen, sich in Sicherheit wiegen. Wer den Parteitag
gesehen hat, weiß auch, also das war siegestrunken.
Die konnten sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass da nochmal was passiert.
Und nun, nach Parteitag, nach J.D. Vance, nach Attentatsversuch, hören wir Piers Morgan.
Wir kennen ihn alle noch, er ist damals aus England rausgeflogen,
weil er mit diesem Abhörskandal, illegales Telefonabhören der königlichen Familie
und so weiter, dann ist er in Amerika bei CNN angelandet, dort auch wieder rausgeflogen.
Inzwischen arbeitet er für Murdoch bei irgendeinem dieser Sky News Australia
irgendwas, aber es ist natürlich in Amerika, kommentiert dort die Wahl.
Wir hören jetzt mal 2 Minuten 40, was mittlerweile im republikanisch Murdoch
getriebenen Mainstream mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die da zugeschaltet werden
und zwar Gästen, die man auch davor und danach immer wieder sieht.
Also disqualifiziert sich jetzt niemand über das, was wir hören.
Wie man so über die Sachen jetzt redet, aus der anderen Richtung.
Also nicht aus der euphorischen Richtung, wie dass ich jetzt sage,
oh krass, endlich haben die mal einen Wahlkampf, wie es sein muss,
sondern aus dieser, oh Gott, wir befürchten eine Niederlage-Wahlkampf.
Lying. None of them believe it was staged, but they are happy to feel like Conspiracy
Theory, even if it makes them like two-faced hypocrites.
Ja, also das hat Piers Morgan Wir wurden hier verraten, die haben uns angelogen,
Biden ist viel älter, das war von langer Hand geplant, dass sie den austauschen
und dann Kamala Harris, wenn wir nichts mehr dagegen tun können und so.
Und jetzt kommt hier so ein Typ, der hat ein Angry Patriot T-Shirt an und redet
jetzt zu diesem Millionenpublikum, das ja dann Piers Morgan immer noch von Murdoch organisiert bekommt.
Piers, Not surprised when it comes to the Democrats. Let's be honest,
Piers, at least we're not living in a boring time.
In the past two weeks, we've lived through an attempted coup by the killing
of Donald Trump. They tried.
And now an actual coup of Joe Biden. Let's not get it twisted, Piers.
The night of the debate, the last presidential debate, when they saw,
the world saw Joe Biden for what he really was. A plan was put in motion.
And that plan was get rid of Donald Trump. We have to kill him.
Plain and simple. This isn't a conspiracy, okay? Kim Cheadle just came out in
front of Congress, before I got in here, and she said in front of Congress, and I quote.
The assassination attempt of former President Donald Trump on July 13th is the
most significant operational failure of the Secret Service in decades.
She's claiming incompetence. Piers, I'm leaning towards orchestrated negligence, okay?
You want us to believe that some 20-year-old kid, no social media presence,
no camouflage, climbed on a roof with cameras everywhere, laid there and got
shots off on the President?
Give me a break. They know, Piers, they've been trying to destroy this guy from
the beginning. The last attempt was murder him. That didn't work.
And now guess what they said. Now, since Joe Biden, because if you think about
it, Piers, if Trump, God forbid, is dead, they don't move on from Joe Biden.
Joe Biden, they just do what they did for COVID.
Keep him in the basement, show him five, six seconds here and there,
and that's it. Their plan failed.
Now they got to move on. And I'm telling you, Piers, ready for this?
Come August, if Kamala's polls are trash at the DNC convention.
Her pass is gonna come out at 29 years Ich weiß nicht, was ich Sie hat keine Kredibilität.
Sie lacht und kackt. Sie ist der Bordersar. Sie ist nie an der Borders. Es ist ein Scheiß-Show.
Und Donald Trump, Gott, Gott schaut Donald Trumps Rück.
Soll. Das ist die Heilige Intervention. Gott hat seinen Kopf gesetzt und gesagt,
nein, nicht heute. Das ist es.
Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn.
Wie Piers Morgan so Wahnsinn da mitmacht. Und ich meine, der war ja immer schon ein Suspekt.
Ein bisschen eigen, aber das war so.
Ich kenne aber diese, das ist Sky Australia oder irgendwas.
Genau.
Und die haben ja nur noch solche Nur noch solche Videos, also die haben ja auch
einfach 50 Videos gleich mal angefertigt von Kamala Harris Cackles,
so nennen die das ja immer, also Gackern, nicht Lachen, sondern Gackern.
Ich möchte eine Empfehlung aussprechen für eine Sendung von Piers Morgan.
Ich werde sie nicht verlinken, man muss sie selber so raussuchen,
aber das ist nicht so schwer. Ich nenne die Person, die dort im Gespräch teilnimmt.
Also Piers Morgan selbst, George Santos und Anthony Wiener.
Also Piers Morgan, George Santos, Anthony Wiener diskutieren die amerikanische Wahl.
Es wird noch lange aktuell bleiben, glaube ich. Ich will nur kurz vorstellen,
wer das so ist. George Santos.
2022 für New York angetreten, um im Repräsentantenhaus Congressman zu werden. Erfolgreiche Wahl.
Der Wahlkampf war sehr erfolgreich. Er hat nämlich Abschlüsse des Barros College
und der New York University vorgewiesen.
Außerdem Arbeitgeber Goldman Sachs und Citigroup. Was kann man da dagegen haben?
750.000 Euro Jahresgehalt plus Dividenden bis 10 Millionen pro Jahr.
Seine Familie Holocaust-Überlebende. Seine Mutter am 11. September 2001 im World
Trade Center gestorben oder dort mitverletzt und später an den Verletzungen gestorben.
Außerdem hat er eine Friends of Pets United Organisation gegründet,
die sich um kleine Haustiere kümmert.
Er ist Mitproduzent des Spider-Man Broadway Musicals, selber Attentatsüberlebender
und er hat auch schon mal einen Gehirntumor.
Sehr interessante Liste, ist natürlich alles gelogen, weshalb er dann selbst
von den Republikanern wieder aus dem Repräsentantenhaus rausgeschmissen wurde.
Und heute 23 Anklagepunkte auf sich vereint.
Diebstahl öffentlicher Gelder, Betrug, Geldwäsche, die Abgabe falscher Erklärung
gegenüber der Wahlkommission, Fälschung von Unterlagen, Behinderung der Wahlkommission,
Verschwörung gegen die USA und schwerer Identitätsdiebstahl.
Das ist der eine. Er ist gerade frei, weil sein Onkel ihm 500.000 Dollar,
die er nicht hat, trotzdem beim Gericht geltend gemacht hat,
im Sinne von ich bürge dafür.
Also wenn er flüchtet, bin ich tot, so ungefähr.
George Santos findet das natürlich alles in der Witschhand und hofft,
dass er freigesprochen wird. Anthony Wiener.
Auch Congressman für New York, aber schon früher, 1999 bis 2011.
Die Wikipedia schreibt, Anfang Juni 2011 wurde bekannt, dass Wiener über seinen
Twitter-Account Links zu freizügigen
Bildern von sich an mehrere Frauen verschickt hatte, darunter am 27.
Mai 2011 versehentlich ein Link zu einem Bild an seine 56.000 Follower.
Hat natürlich für einige Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt, weshalb in der Wikipedia steht,
US-Präsident Barack Obama erklärte am 14.
Juni 2011 in einem Interview, er würde an Wieners Stelle zurück. tritt.
Für den Fall geht es weiter. Dass Donald Trump Jr.
Seine Überlegung umsetzen sollte, als Bürgermeister New York City zu kandidieren,
erklärte Wiener im Juli 2016, als der Präsidentschaftswahlkampf schon lief,
möglicherweise gegen ihn anzutreten.
Dazu kam es dann nicht, weil Donald Trump ist ja Präsident geworden.
Wie ist Donald Trump Präsident geworden? Ah ja, muss man nur weiterlesen.
Im Endspurt des Präsidentschaftswahlkampfs im Herbst 2016 geriet ein Laptop
Anthony Wieners in die Hände des FBI.
Weil dieser auch von seiner Frau benutzt wurde und sich dort auch E-Mails mit
Bezug zu Hillary Clinton befand, kündigte FBI-Chef James Corny überraschend
an, die Untersuchung in der E-Mail-Affäre wieder zu beleben.
Er war also damals verantwortlich dafür, dass dieses ganze Ding wieder hochgekocht ist.
Seine Frau ist Huma Abedin. Damals, Leute leben natürlich getrennt.
Abedin war stellvertretende des Stabschefigen und persönliche Assistentin Clintons
als US-Außenministerin bis 2013 und saß anschließend dem Übergangsteam bei,
also dieser Transition raus aus dem Amt, dann rein in die Kandidatur.
Also es ist wirklich haarsträubend, aber in diesen kleinen Kammerspielartigen
Gesprächen mit Anthony wieder, George Santos und Pierce Morgan kann man jetzt
diesen Wahlkampf verfolgen.
Ich würde sagen, ein bisschen weniger Tagesschau und so, bisschen mehr Piers
Morgan, weil das ist wirklich Du willst Action.
Es ist Action. Es ist wirklich ganz, ganz große Action und macht auch viel, viel Spaß.
Dann sind wir eigentlich schon fast am Ende, beziehungsweise könnten wir noch
ganz kurz etwas, ja, lass uns noch einen letzten Clip spielen, ja? Und zwar?
Ja, also meine Emotionen und KI. Super wichtiges Thema. Ich werde übermorgen in den Urlaub fahren.
Ich werde nichts vorbereiten. Im August darf nichts passieren in der Weltgeschichte.
Ich werde Ende August über dieses KI-Thema reden.
Ich werde es nicht weiter verschieben, egal was kommt. Ich hoffe,
es kommt einfach nichts.
Ich will es nur schon mal ansagen, damit ich es dann nicht wieder verschiebe.
Dieses KI- und Emotionsthema ist wirklich wichtig.
Ja, dann bleiben wir doch mal bei dem Thema noch.
Hören wir Gesine Lötzsch. Wir wissen, es gab jetzt eine Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht,
inwieweit diese Wahlrechtsreform gültig ist.
Und Gesine Lötzsch von der Linken freut sich, dass nun diese Grundmandatsregel
erst einmal bestehen bleibt.
Als Sie heute Morgen wach geworden sind und die Meldungen gelesen haben,
dass das wohl in Ihrem Sinne ausgeht, wie groß war der Stein,
der Ihnen vom Herzen gefallen ist?
Also das ist natürlich ein Teilerfolg für uns und für Die Linke und die anderen klagenden Parteien.
Aber man muss natürlich jetzt von der Ampel ganz deutliche Worte der Selbstkritik hören.
Denn es wird immer gefordert, wir sollen die Demokratie verteidigen.
Und dann wurde ein Gesetz durchgedrückt, was genau das Gegenteil als Ergebnis
gehabt hätte. Und zwar, dass zwei Parteien, das war ja auch das erklärte Ziel,
nämlich die CSU und die Linke, dem Bundestag nicht mehr angehören.
Und das ist natürlich etwas, das wir nicht mehr tun können.
Demokratisch überhaupt nicht akzeptabel ist. Die Linke ist 2021 mit 2,3 Millionen
Stimmen gewählt worden und die wären umsonst gewesen, hätte es die Grundmandatsregel nicht gegeben.
Nun ist es sicherlich übertrieben zu sagen, dass es das erklärte Ziel der Ampel
gewesen sei. Also war das vielleicht das Ziel.
Aber nicht das erklärte.
Linke, nicht das erklärte, Linke aus dem Bundestag rausfangen.
Aber wir sehen natürlich bei der Problematik, die sich ergibt,
wenn man sagt, wir müssen den Bundestag verkleinern.
Wenn man dann eine solche Regelung da vornehmen will, dass es also nicht mehr
mit Direktmandaten geht,
dass man also zum Beispiel dann zwar nicht auf der Bundesebene die 5%-Hürde
schafft, Aber direkte Wahlkreise gewinnt, dass man dann trotzdem im Parlament vertreten ist.
Davon profitieren die Linken und noch viel mehr die CSU.
Also 5% Hürde oder drei Mandate. Ja, oder drei Mandate.
Drei Mandate, dann geht die Liste. Und damit wäre möglicherweise auch die CSU rausgefallen.
Also sonst hätte die CSU quasi in allen Bundesländern antreten müssen,
hätte da versuchen müssen, dann entsprechend die Stimmen zu bekommen.
Und dass das eine problematische Regelung war, ist klar.
Das wurde jetzt kassiert von Karlsruhe.
Man kann viel darüber reden, was man aber festhalten kann ist,
dass hier so eine Politisierung stattfindet, die eigentlich ja,
aber eine Politisierung der Wahlordnung in einer Weise, wie wir das eigentlich aus den USA kennen.
Weil sie ja jetzt hier sich äußert und ganz ähnlich hat sich auch die CSU geäußert,
indem sie sagt, ja das war eine Strategie der Ampelregierung uns zu verhindern und so weiter.
Und da würde ich sagen, ist es schon problematisch, wenn man diese Politisierung
vorantreibt, weil wir uns dann natürlich US-amerikanischen Verhältnissen annähern.
Wir hören jetzt noch aus dem Heinrich Böll Podcast Märkte, Mächte,
Emissionen Adam Tooze, der über die USA spricht.
Es gibt eine Krise der Verfassung in Amerika.
Institutionen werden zunehmend, genau wie du es aufgezählt hast,
die Gerichte, die Beamtenschaft sowieso, die wissenschaftliche Apparatur,
also die Wissenschaft wird zunehmend von den Republikanern in Frage gestellt.
Aber das als Krise der Demokratie aufzufassen, ist für mich etwas irreführend
in dem Sinne, dass ich das als Effekt einer populistischen Demokratie lesen
würde. Die amerikanische Politik ist ja nicht gewisserweise ein Verrat einer
sonst gesunden Gesellschaft.
Es ist ja nicht eine Situation, sagen wir mal, von einer korrupten Elite.
Ich meine, die amerikanische Elite bereichert sich aber nicht in dieser simplen
Form über die Politik, sondern die Politik, die wir und dieser Erosionsprozess, den wir beobachten,
ist Ausdruck einer gesellschaftlichen Veränderung und geht sehr,
sehr tief auf beiden Seiten.
Und er sagt auch?
Es ist also nicht so, dass es eine heile amerikanische Demokratie gäbe,
die dann irgendwie von Trump unterwandert wird,
sondern die amerikanische Politik und die Erosion der Institutionen ist legitimer,
wahrhafter Ausdruck eines zunehmend polarisierten,
dysfunktionalen, zynischen,
instrumentellen Ansatzes der amerikanischen Bevölkerung an sich in ihrer Welt und in ihrem Umgang.
Ich meine, nehmen wir das klimapolitische Beispiel.
Ich habe es ja eben angeführt, man kann mit dem Kongress ganz schlecht Klimapolitik machen.
Obama ist im ersten Anlauf gescheitert. Was haben sie in der zweiten Amtszeit gemacht?
Sie machen über die Administration Klimapolitik. Das heißt, sie stellen alle
administrativen Schrauben auf Grün, ohne Mehrheit zu haben.
Also ohne sich demokratische Legitimation zu schaffen, verwenden sie die Staatsapparatur,
um gezielt eine hochpolitische, in Amerika extrem kontroverse Politik durchzusetzen.
Was ist die einzige Antwort darauf, die den Republikanern offen steht?
Du kannst nicht über den Kongress arbeiten, da wird das Thema nicht besprochen,
sondern du gehst an die Gerichte.
Du verwendest die Gerichte, um gegen eine administrative, nicht durch Mehrheiten
gedeckte Politik Widerstand zu leisten.
Und dann nimmt das Ganze seinen Lauf.
Das ist das große Dilemma. Ich meine, Szenario-Planung im Sinne von nicht Planung,
sondern was könnte man als Szenario planen?
Das Einfallstor, um 250 Jahre amerikanische Demokratiegeschichte zu revidieren,
ist, sechs Leute zu überzeugen, einen Text zu schreiben.
Und wir wissen, dass die da wirklich korrupt sind. Das ist ja eines der großen
Themen, weshalb Joe Biden jetzt auch sagt, wir müssen das mal reformieren.
Erstens Amtszeitbegrenzung auf 18 Jahre, was ich schon mal lächerlich finde,
also in Deutschland sind es 12 und das ist schon lang, plus einen Ethikkode,
den man auch wirklich durchsetzen kann.
Das sind ja wirklich vormoderne Prinzipien, die da jetzt gerade gelten,
in der Hinsicht für eine Organisation, die mit 10.000 Mann stärker und einem
Budget von vielleicht 3 oder 4 Milliarden Dollar das amerikanische,
Politiksystem übernehmen möchte, für die ist doch das Einfallstor Supreme Court
wirklich die einfachste Hürde. Würde ich jetzt mal so sagen.
Aber es ist ein generelles Spiel, das gespielt wird, sagt Toos.
Und was geschieht als nächstes? Die Ernennung von Richterinnen wird politisiert,
weil auf einmal alles davon abhängt, wer die Richterinnen ernennt.
Und mittlerweile ist Amerika ein Flickenteppich an Federal Court Circuits,
die jeweils von verschiedenen Präsidenten ernannt worden sind.
Und danach bestimmt Es bestimmt sich, in welchem Teil Amerika welches Recht du bekommst.
Der Prozess fängt an mit dem Versuch der Demokraten, progressive Politik unter
Umgehung des Kongresses zu machen, weil sie dort keine Mehrheit haben.
Ich sage das nicht als Kritik, ich will nur beschreiben, wie dieser Prozess
auf beiden Seiten läuft.
Umso wichtiger ist es, jetzt wirklich ernst zu nehmen und die Texte auch nochmal neu zu lesen.
In der Politik geht es um Macht.
Ja. Ja, ja, aber wir sehen auch hier, dass damit, also man kann ja sagen,
und TuS tut es ja, die Demokratie lebt.
Es geht nicht darum, demokratisch mächtige Positionen zu erringen,
sondern es geht um Macht. Nochmal eine Stufe genereller.
Ja, ja. Aber hören wir nochmal weiter.
Das heißt, der gesamte amerikanische Staatsapparat ist im Spiel und nur ein
Teil davon wird über Wahlen ablaufen.
Und ein sehr großer Teil über einen inneren Kampf innerhalb der Staatsapparatur.
Und das ist, um es klar zu sagen, ist auch in Deutschland der Fall.
Wir begeben uns immer mehr in diese Richtung. Er sagt dann noch zu den Republikanern.
Demokratie, in gewisser Weise lebt sie in brutaler und populistischer Form auf.
Aber was daran zu brüchen geht, ist die Verfassung. Was daran zu brüchen geht,
sind die Institutionen.
Die Rechtsberater von Trump reden buchstäblich über Post-Constitutional Times. Ja.
Auch das ist interessant und wir haben in Deutschland ja parallel.
Wenn die Verfassung im Wege zur Macht steht, musst du sie beseitigen.
Ja.
Sobald du Mehrheiten dafür hast und wenn du keine Mehrheiten dafür hast, machst du es trotzdem.
Du musst halt unrevidierbare oder erstmal schwer revidierbare Zustände erwirken.
Dieses Supreme Court Urteil ist zum Beispiel eins, das ist nicht revidierbar.
Also wie lange sollen die Prozesse jetzt bis drei Richter gestorben sind und
dann hoffentlich ein Demokrat die nächsten ernennt, hast du in 100 Jahren vielleicht
eine Mehrheit für den Gegenentwurf. Ja.
Lass uns noch fünf Minuten machen, damit wir noch einmal gerade die Klammer
bekommen für Deutschland.
Bundespressekonferenz, Marco Buschmann mit vielen anderen aus anderen Fraktionen.
Thema. Und worum ging es?
Nun, um das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Du hast schon gesagt, das ist doch so,
dass es da eine Amtszeit für die Richter von zwölf Jahren gibt.
Ja, aber wo steht das? Wo ist das festgeschrieben? Könnte man nicht auch sagen,
wir verringern die Amtszeit oder wir setzen die Pensionsgrenze runter,
wie das in Polen geschehen ist?
Also die Frage ist, was ist eigentlich im Grundgesetz festgelegt?
Und Marco Buschmann führt aus.
Heute ist ein guter Tag für die Verfassungsordnung und die demokratische Kultur in unserem Land.
Denn eine ganz breite Allianz seriöser Demokraten, eine ganz breite Allianz
von Parlamentariern zusammen mit dem Bundesminister der Justiz,
stellt eine Initiative vor, um das Bundesverfassungsgericht weiter zu stärken.
Alle Fraktionen außer AfD haben sich getroffen und beratschlagt.
Nämlich als vor 75 Jahren das Grundgesetz in Kraft trat, war das Bundesverfassungsgericht
ein Experiment, das war etwas Neues.
Ein solches Gericht mit einer solchen Machtfülle, nämlich der Machtfülle auch
Gesetze des demokratisch legitimierten Gesetzgebers zu kassieren,
also aus der Welt zu schaffen, das gab es in Europa nicht.
Dieses Experiment war die Lektion aus der bitteren Erfahrung der Weimarer Republik,
dass nämlich das Mehrheitsprinzip alleine nicht sicherstellen kann.
Dass jede Mehrheit unter allen Umständen immer die Verfassung wahrt und insbesondere
auch die Grundrechte der Menschen respektiert.
Ja, das haben wir ja in dem Verhalten der FDP gesehen. Die Mehrheiten waren
da und dann gab es doch wieder E-Fuels.
Tja.
Deshalb war man zu der Überzeugung gelangt, ein solches Gericht zu benötigen.
Und dass es ein Experiment war, merkte man daran, dass in der Verfassung,
wenn man es mal vergleicht mit den Regelungen über den Bundestag oder den Bundesrat
relativ wenig festgelegt war.
Die meisten Regelungen hat man dem einfachen Gesetzgeber überlassen,
weil man erst mal schauen wollte, wie sich das Experiment entwickelt.
Das Experiment ist aber gelungen. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat in richterlicher
Unabhängigkeit von seinen Kompetenzen Gebrauch gemacht.
Es hat zum Gelingen unserer Verfassungsordnung unschätzbare Beiträge geleistet.
Es ist ein Eckpfeiler unserer liberalen Demokratie geworden.
Sehr gute Performance. Ich will es trotzdem mal ein bisschen kritisch,
dadurch, dass es der FDP-Mann ist, wenn er jetzt sagt,
ja, damals hat man gesagt, der einfache Gesetzgeber im Sinne von der Bundestag
und darüber gibt es aber den nicht einfachen, besseren, was auch immer,
Verankerungen im Grundgesetz.
Das Grundgesetz ist, wie Norbert Lammert immer so schön sagt jetzt,
aufs Doppelte gewachsen, aber es ist nicht doppelt so gut geworden.
Weil das Grundgesetz hat man ganz schön oft angefasst und die Frage hier muss
man sich jetzt stellen, warum denn bei so einer zentralen Frage nicht?
Also da kommt eine Handschelle für den einfachen Gesetzgeber im Sinne von Schuldenbremse
rein, kommen 100 Milliarden, Trump wünscht sich aber zwei Prozent rein,
aber das kommt dann nicht rein bis hierhin.
Um das klar zu machen...
Artikel 94 Grundgesetz lautet, das Bundesverfassungsgericht besteht aus Bundesrichtern
und anderen Mitgliedern.
Die Mitglieder des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes werden je zur Hälfte vom Bundestag
und vom Bundesrat gewählt.
Sie dürfen weder dem Bundestag, dem Bundesrat, der Bundesregierung noch entsprechenden
Organen eines Landes angehören. Schön noch alles mit Dativ E.
Nun ist aber nicht hier zu lesen
etwas zur Amtszeit oder zum Beispiel zur erforderlichen Wahlmehrheit.
Und das heißt, man könnte das also anders kontrollieren.
Allerdings, das regeln andere Bundesgesetze, die nun auch nicht unter Ferner liefen, sondern halt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also die kann, das kann man ändern mit entsprechenden
Mehrheiten und darum haben die sich ja getroffen.
Also es soll jetzt ins Grundgesetz rein, damit das nicht mehr irgendwo in der Schwebe hängt.
Ja, aber ich….
Also die machen ja ein konkretes Szenario aus. Es könnte jetzt so eine Regierung
wie in Polen sein und die sagt.
Amtszeit runter. Ich finde, so in der Schwebe, es ist nicht in der Schwebe,
sondern der Bundestag entscheidet mit einfacher Mehrheit darüber.
50 statt 66 Prozent. Das heißt noch nicht Schwebe und es ist auch nicht der
einfache Gesetzgeber, finde ich, auch wenn es vielleicht eine juristische Formulierung
ist, sondern trotzdem man jetzt Ansinnen hat,
das hier etwas besser abzusichern, ist der Bundestag immer noch die zentrale
Einrichtung für politische Entscheidungen und nicht einfach der einfache Gesetzgeber
oder oh, da wird es aber gefährlich, wenn wir das null dem Bundestag überlassen.
Naja, man macht das ja schon aus Gründen, also führen das mal noch weiter aus.
Und zu diesem gelungenen Experiment gehörte zweitens, dass die unterschiedlichsten
Mehrheiten in unserem Land,
die es ja gab, eines immer respektiert haben, nämlich auch dann,
wenn einem eine Entscheidung nicht gefällt, nutzt man die Möglichkeiten des
einfachen Gesetzgebers nicht dafür, um das Gericht dafür irgendwie zu sanktionieren
oder um es an die kurze Leine zu nehmen.
Dieses Erfolgsmodell Bundesverfassungsgericht war übrigens auch ein Exportschlager.
Es ist eine wichtige Rechtsquelle für viele andere Verfassungsgerichte und viele
andere Verfassungsgesetzgeber haben diese Institution auch übernommen.
Insbesondere unsere Nachbarstaaten in Mittel- und Osteuropa.
Hier verweise ich nochmal auf den Salon, in dem ich das Buch von Philipp Manow
vorgestellt habe, der nochmal zeigt, woher kommt eigentlich dieser Begriff der liberalen Demokratie.
Das kommt daher, dass da Verfassungsgerichte etabliert werden in den Ländern,
dann spricht man von der liberalen Demokratie.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass ohne Verfassungsgericht keine Demokratie wäre.
Das hat ja auch gesagt, in gewisser Weise ist es ein demokratischer Akt,
wenn die das jetzt da kurz und klein schlagen, wenn sie die Stimmen dafür haben.
Warum macht man das denn jetzt eigentlich, dass man jetzt sagt,
wir müssen da mal dringend etwas erweitern im Grundgesetz?
Was passiert in dem theoretischen Fall, der in Deutschland, Gott sei Dank,
Auf Bundesebene ein theoretischer Fall ist in anderen Ländern,
aber passiert ist, dass es obstruktive Minderheiten oder gar Mehrheiten gibt,
die nicht wollen, dass das Verfassungsgericht gut funktioniert.
Möglicherweise auch eine Richterwahl blockieren oder verweigern.
Dort wollen wir einen Ersatzwahlmechanismus etablieren, der es,
Sie wissen, der Bundestag und der Bundesrat wählen die Richter,
dass das jeweils andere Organ als Ersatzwahlorgan eintreten kann,
wenn eine solche Blockade auftreten soll.
Das heißt, wenn die AfD blockiert, also die Mehrheit dafür hätte zu blockieren,
im Bundesrat aber nicht die Mehrheit hat, dann kann man über den Bundesrat trotzdem
dann Richter ernennen und man legt damit das Gericht nicht lahm.
Konstantin von Notz von den Grünen wird ein bisschen deutlicher.
Höchste Gerichte drohen eben zu einem politischen Instrument zu verkommen,
wie man das gerade in anderen Demokratien sieht.
Und der Konsens, Deutschland vor solchen Diskussionen und solchen Bewegungen
zu bewahren, hat uns zusammengebracht.
Jetzt ist es auch so, dass man zum Beispiel eine Reihenfolge festlegen will
für die Fallbearbeitung.
Wir wissen ja, man kann Fälle liegen lassen endlos, dass das dann auch nicht möglich ist.
Auch Johannes Fechner von der SPD blickt nach Osteuropa.
Wir haben in Osteuropa leider sehen müssen, wie schnell der Rechtsstaat abgebaut werden konnte.
Und oft war der erste Schritt, dass die nationalen Verfassungsgerichte lahmgelegt wurden.
Da gab es die verschiedensten Tricksereien, dass zum Beispiel neue Senate geschaffen
wurden oder dass die Altersgrenze runtergesetzt wurde, sodass Verfassungsrichterstellen
frei geworden sind, die man dann mit eigenen, genehmen Personen besetzen konnte.
Das werden wir verhindern.
Und was hier also geschieht, ist auch eine Machtabsicherung.
Also man kann ja sagen, naja, wenn die, ja, also eine Machtabsicherung im Sinne
von, hier wird es natürlich verkauft, als wir müssen die Verfassung schützen.
Aber man kann ja auch sagen…,
Und es ist ja, wenn die AfD demokratisch gewählt ist, dann hat die halt den
Zugriff. Vorher war das ja für euch auch kein Problem.
Ich mache mir diese Position nicht zu eigen, nur ich will deutlich machen,
es beginnt also jetzt auch hier ein ganz klares Spiel damit,
wie kann man nicht nur diese Institutionen resilient machen,
sondern es geht jetzt auch schon darum, dass man ein bisschen politisch da eingreift.
Denn wir werden jetzt gleich sehen, dass manche Sachen nicht reinkamen und da
ist dann die CDU wieder in einer bemerkenswerten Position.
Erstmal wollen wir uns sagen, was getan wird. Nochmal Fechner.
Wir haben in der Tat sehr intensiv diskutiert und beraten und wollen im Grundgesetz absichern,
dass eben nur mit Zweidrittelmehrheit diese Grundlagen des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes
abgeändert werden können.
Also ein hoher Schutzmechanismus.
Zum Beispiel regeln wir, dass es nur zwei Senate geben wird.
Wir regeln, dass es acht Richter pro Senat geben wird.
Und der Minister hat es auch schon gesagt, wir regeln einen Mechanismus,
der eingreift, dass eine Richterstelle schnell wieder besetzt werden kann,
dass es also keine Hängepartie gibt.
Ja, also er sagt ja schon, es ist eine sehr hohe Hürde, 66 Prozent.
In Amerika gilt ja für diese weitreichenden Folgen 60-40. Das hätte man hier
auch mal überlegen können, grundsätzlich.
Weil 66% ist auf der einen Seite eine recht hohe Hürde auf der anderen Seite
aber auch eine leicht zu erreichbare Hürde weil 33% ist ja dann,
Minderheitenvotum das was hier verhandelt wird gilt ja ebenso dann auch für
die Länder soweit ich weiß und wenn du dann aber Thüringer Ministerpräsidenten
hast, die selber vielleicht keine Regierungsmeld haben,
aber irgendwas geduldetes wie auch immer eine 33%,
Veto gegen verfassungsgebende Mehrheiten, dann wäre man vielleicht bei 40 auch
ein bisschen besser aufgestellt.
Man hat sich ja hier noch nicht mal so zu allem durchgerungen.
Wir hören jetzt erstmal Andrea Lindholz von der CDU mit einem eigenartigen Argument.
Die Debatte, ob man das Bundesverfassungsgericht im Grundgesetz verankert in
Teilen und es damit auch stärkt, die gibt es lange, die gibt es seit den 90er
Jahren und einem Argument haben wir uns auch nicht verschlossen, Wenn nicht jetzt im 75.
Jahr unseres Grundgesetzes, denn wann dann, soll man diese Diskussionen führen?
Also war jetzt der Geburtshoch der Anlass oder eher eine aufsteigende AfD?
Naja, ich sag mal, der Buschmann ist ja ganz klug eingestiegen mit so einem
Experiment und wir sagen jetzt mal, es ist geglückt.
Aber Konstantin von Notz ist, glaube ich, hier der Ehrlichste,
der schon genau weiß, warum sie das jetzt da machen.
Wir hören Ansgar Heveling von der CDU.
Das ist...
Erfordernis, Richterinnen und Richter mit zwei Dritteln im Bundestag zu wählen,
steht im Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz.
Das ist uns wichtig.
Und es kann natürlich Situationen geben, theoretisch, in denen es eben eine
destruktive Minderheit gibt, die die Zwei-Drittel-Wahl verhindern könnte.
Das war uns Anlass, auch zu überlegen, muss man dafür einen Mechanismus finden,
Das Grundgesetz gab bisher nicht die Möglichkeit dazu.
Durch eine Öffnungsklausel soll das in Zukunft geändert werden,
sodass es im Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz auch die Möglichkeit gibt,
einen Ersatzwahlmechanismus vorzusehen, dass also ein anderes Wahlorgan,
nämlich dann der Bundesrat, wenn der Bundestag keine Wahl vornehmen kann,
die Wahl stattdessen vornehmen kann.
Diese Öffnungsklausel hat man jetzt im Grundgesetz verziert,
nicht die Zweidrittelmehrheit, denn die Journalistin Claudia Kornmeier von der
ARD stellt die entscheidende Frage.
Was Sie jetzt nicht aufgenommen haben, ist die Zweidrittelmehrheit für die Wahl
der Richter ins Grundgesetz.
An die, die das nicht wollten, warum nicht? Welche Befürchtungen waren damit verbunden?
Und an die, die sich das vielleicht gewünscht hätten, wie groß finden Sie das
Problem, dass das jetzt so bleibt, also dass das in einem einfachen Gesetz bleibt?
Also man hat das interessanterweise nicht aufgenommen. Es geht dann so hin und
her und Buschmann sagt auch, es muss sich jetzt nicht jeder hier bekennen.
Wir haben das ja auch so gemeinsam ausgemacht.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass das sehr auch mit CDU zusammenhängt.
Ich finde eine Argumentation, zumindest um den Gedankengang nachzuvollziehen,
sinnvoll von Stefan Thome von der FDP.
Neben all dem, was gesagt worden ist, was auch zeigt, wie die Diskussion ernsthaft
verlaufen ist und man Argumente und Gegenargumente auch abgewogen hat, ist eben klar,
ein hohes Quorum, zunächst mal natürlich sympathisch und nach hoher Sicherheit
klingt, hat als Gegenspielgemeinde eine niedrige Sperrminorität.
Und das ist eben das, was man gegen einen abwägen muss.
Und deswegen gab es auch gute Gründe, neben all dem, was vielleicht dafür gesprochen
hätte, abzuwägen, ob man eine solche Sperrmitte dann auch zu sehr gleich in Stein meißeln möchte.
Es gab gute Gründe, sich dagegen auszusprechen. Das war der Grund für das Ergebnis.
Ja, das verstehe ich gut, weil...
Du kannst deinen Richter blockieren, wenn du zwei Drittel Mehrheiten brauchst,
dann kann ein Drittel im Parlament einfach sagen, oh, jetzt müsst ihr schon
euren nächsten Paragraf ziehen, der Bundesrat macht das oder sowas.
Ja, und der Bundesrat, also wenn man jetzt mal von dieser, ich glaube ja,
dass das sehr stark jetzt gemacht wurde, dass man resilient ist gegenüber der AfD.
Das ist, glaube ich, sehr deutlich geworden.
Das sollte man da auch nicht verstecken.
Ich meine, die verweigern der Partei seit Jahren mehrere Legislaturperioden Bundestagsrat.
Wir sind ja auch komischerweise nicht mit da auf dem Podium, das hat ja Gründe.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass natürlich die anderen Parteien hier im Einklang erscheinen,
aber du weißt ja, wie das so ist und du weißt auch, dass Friedrich Merz erst
gar nicht davon überzeugt war, das überhaupt zu machen. Der wollte das erst gar nicht.
Das heißt, man sagt sich jetzt, naja, bevor wir uns da in merkwürdige Abhängigkeiten
reinbegeben und können dann nicht mehr so ordentlich taktieren,
wie wir das vorher konnten, lassen wir das lieber mal sein.
Als CDU weißt du ja auch, dass du relativ locker nur noch kleine Partner brauchst,
um auf 50 Prozent zu kommen.
Für eine 15 Prozent SPD, weißt du, egal.
50 oder 66, ist eh nicht unsere Entscheidung dann.
Aber wir haben jetzt, ist ganz klar mit dieser Richtung zu tun,
dass Liberale an der Demokratie, insofern liberal ist, man versucht hat alles festzuschreiben.
Was wir bei der Schuldenbremse kritisieren, sind wir jetzt durchaus mit Blick
auf die AfD bereit zu gutieren.
Konstantin von Notz macht nochmal diese Opposition auf.
Wir leben in einer systemischen Auseinandersetzung zwischen den Demokratien
und autokratischen, diktatorischen Systemen.
Und wir müssen unsere Demokratie wehrhaft und resilient aufstellen,
damit wir eben diesen Angriffen begegnen können.
Das heißt aber, dass man einen technokratischen Weg geht und diesen technokratischen Weg… Na.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Ja, das ist ein technokratischer Weg, sonst würde man ja sagen,
brauchen wir nicht, wir kriegen das ja politisch gelöst.
Wenn man sich jetzt von außen sozusagen nähert, würde man sagen,
die Regeln sind jetzt ein bisschen anders als vorher.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass sie jetzt mehr ausgedacht sind oder artifizieller oder so.
Sind immer artifizierter.
Die waren vorher auch, genau. So, die Frage ist dann, warum hat man das nicht
früher gemacht, sondern jetzt? Na klar, dann kommt so der Empiriedruck.
Man sagt dann irgendwie, das ist es.
Nur, das wird natürlich, gerade wenn der Empiriedruck da ist,
also der AfD und so weiter wird thematisiert, dann hast du ja eine Diskussion.
Also solche Sachen werden jetzt diskutiert in den sozusagen Special Interest
Fachjournalen. Irgendwie Juristen machen sich jetzt Gedanken dazu.
Und ich glaube, die werden relativ zügig. zur Frage 1 kommen.
Wie weit kann man eigentlich einen parlamentarischen Betrieb gegen Bevölkerungswillen absichern?
Also wie groß kann die Spannung da werden?
Und zweitens, wenn man ein Einfallstor schließt, welches andere öffnet man denn dann?
Wenn wir von Toos gehört, naja, über die Richter ist man ja nur gegangen, weil das so einfach war.
In Amerika noch mehr, wo ja jeder Richterspruch immer gleich Gesetzeskraft hat.
Deutschland noch nicht ganz so sehr. Jetzt versucht sucht man trotzdem ein Einfallstor,
das man im Ausland beobachtet hat, hier zu schließen.
Ich würde sagen, schaut euch lieber nochmal die lokalen Staatsverträge für die
Medien an, sind die Medienhäuser eigentlich abgesichert, so wie wir uns das
wünschten in dem Experiment,
als wir sagten, kein Volksempfänger mehr, wir machen das jetzt mit Haushaltsbeiträgen
und so, was ist eigentlich ein Haushalt, denn da befürchte ich ja,
dass wir nur ein komisches Urteil und vielleicht kann man sogar komisch streichen,
nur ein sehr gut begründetes Urteil davon entfernt sind, Dass hier irgendwo
wirkliche Sendeanstalten von heute auf morgen sozusagen sich juristisch neu aufstellen müssen.
Oder halt wirklich Mehrheiten über die Parlamente da kommen und sagen,
und das ist ja zum Beispiel, hier sagt man jetzt, okay, das ist der einfache Gesetzgeber.
Also diese Medienstaatsverträge, soweit ich das verstehe,
sind in den Staatskanzleien nicht mal Ministerpräsidenten angelegten,
also eines Wahlamtes, sondern der berufte Staatssekretär, also ein Leiter seines
Büros und der kümmert sich um die Verträge zu den Medienhäusern.
Das ist ja noch weiter weg von einfachen Gesetzgeber.
Das ist ja dann wirklich Verwaltungsaktebene. Also da würde ich so sagen,
ich glaube jedenfalls derzeit in Deutschland ist, wie wir Diskussionen führen,
sehr viel wichtiger zu beobachten, als wie im parlamentarischen Prozess die Abläufe sind.
Ob jetzt 50-50 oder 66-33 Mehrheiten.
Ich finde es trotzdem gut, dass sie das mal so gemacht haben,
dass sie auch zeigen, dass das geht, dass man darüber nachdenkt,
dass die CDU nochmal sich entblößt und wir sagen, oh Gott, ihr Blöden,
ja, macht wieder euren eigenen Soße draus.
Trotzdem glaube ich, ein Einfallstor so ein bisschen zugemacht und dann sitzen
die Heritage-Foundation-Strategen gleich da und suchen sich die anderen Dinge.
Ganz richtig und da ist Marco Buschmann zuzustimmen, wenn er auf die Grenzen
dieser technokratischen Schritte verweist und das ist jetzt der letzte Clip dann.
Weil jetzt ja vielleicht auch so ein bisschen spielerische Energie losgetreten
wird, kann es eigentlich die perfekte Verfassungsordnung geben,
die jedes auch nur irgendwie denkbare Risiko ausschließt.
Und da möchte ich sagen...
Auch wirklich als begeisterter Verfassungsjurist, das wird man nie finden können,
sondern kluges Verfassungsrecht kann Dinge in Bahn lenken, sie kann Missbrauch
erschweren, sie kann Korruption erschweren, sie kann Destruktivität schwerer
machen, sie kann die Institutionen über eine gewisse Zeit stärken.
Aber zu glauben, dass wenn wir dauerhaft antidemokratische Mehrheiten im Deutschen
Bundestag hätten, das Verfassungsrecht allein alle Probleme lösen können, das ist eine Illusion.
Und deshalb bleibt neben dem, was wir hier tun, eine andere Sache,
mindestens genauso bedeutend, vielleicht noch viel bedeutender.
Nämlich, dass seriöse Demokraten dafür sorgen, dass sie so viele Menschen überzeugen,
dass es möglichst niemals im Deutschen Bundestag eine antidemokratische Mehrheit
oder eine antidemokratische qualifizierte Minderheit gibt.
So ist es.
Ein begeisterter Verfassungsjurist. Ja, er kann sich wünschen,
dass es seriöse Demokraten gibt.
Aber die haben keinen direkten Zugang zur Wählerschaft. Das läuft über Twitter,
Tagesthemen, Bild, News.
Naja, das sind immense Probleme. Wir sprechen ja über Blühdorn dann im Salon.
Wir wollen nochmal darauf hinweisen, also im Salon sprechen wir über das Buch
Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne von Ingolfur Blühdorn.
Welche Texte hast du sonst noch mit dabei?
Wir lesen ein Diskussionspapier, angesprochen, ich will nochmal die Namen,
es ist ja nicht nur Malafalani, Malfalani, also Aladin L.
Malfalani, sondern auch Baro, Vicenta, Ra, Gabbert, Nikolas, Karanikolas,
Nadja Rückert, Melissa Sedej, Marie Borst und Daniela Broder.
Oder, also ein sehr divers zusammengestelltes, meinen Aussprachegewohnheiten
nicht entsprechendes Gremium, aber beauftragt von der Bundesregierung,
sich die Jugend anzuschauen.
Dazu passend, also zu dem, was wir eben sagten, diesen riesigen Vanity Fair Text 22,
der immer noch aktuell ist, weil er uns ungetrübt von der Aktualität,
programmatisch, ich habe in dem Fall auch ein bisschen Claude zur Hilfe genommen,
liste mir mal wirklich auf, was steht da inhaltlich, wer hat da was und wie
kann man das als Programm deuten und so.
Außerdem dieser wahnsinnig wirklich, also Isra Klein ist so ein wahnsinnig kluger Typ.
Er hat diesen Text gemacht, wie sollte man jetzt mit der Harris-Kandidatur umgehen
unter der Maßgabe, dass man jetzt nicht ewig lange und Michelle Obama und so.
Also da sind wir mal sehr gespannt. Und außerdem, was habe ich noch?
Vanity Fair, was ist das hier? Also ich habe da noch was.
Eventuell zu den Wohnpreisen diese JLL irgendwas, Anwaltsdings oder was,
keine Ahnung, die haben so ein paar Zahlen zusammengestellt.
Ich werde ein Buch vorstellen, das sich mit dem Opfernationalismus auseinandersetzt.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das ist eine sehr interessante Perspektive, die da eingenommen wird.
Ist es gut?
Ich finde es sehr inspirierend, sagen wir so. Ich finde es ist ein Buch,
der sicherlich auch zum Widerspruch einlädt.
Aber es ist in der Tat eine interessante Überlegung, die hier getroffen wird.
Also inwieweit jetzt ein neuer Nationalismus dadurch entsteht,
dass man sich als Opfer sieht oder auch tatsächlich Opfer war.
Das ist etwas, was wir besprechen sollten. Dann habe ich noch einen sehr merkwürdigen
japanischen Roman gelesen, den ich vorstellen werde.
Und den Rest halte ich noch offen. Ich habe da mehrere Texte.
Dazu entscheide ich mich noch.
Okay, sehr gut.
Dann kann man uns also im Salon hören. Dort werden wir ausführlich dann erstmal
über Blühdorn diskutieren. Man wird dort dann auch im August unseren Live-Sommersalon hören können.
Das ist also auch dann möglich und man kann natürlich alle alten Salons hören
und wir haben es schon gesagt, es gibt dann diese moderate Preissteigerung von
Steady dringend erwünscht oder erbeten. Das ist ja nicht schön.
Jedenfalls kann man uns also BuySteady für, wenn man ein Jahresabo abschließt,
für drei Euro im Monat hören.
Und für die Einzelmonate ist es dann etwas teurer.
Bei Apple und Patreon haben wir dann auch diese Preisanpassung vorgenommen.
Aber bis zum 24. August, wie gesagt, kann man noch zum alten Preis,
also ab 2,50 Euro im Monat, den Salon abonnieren. Ja, nur dieser Preis bleibt dann auch.
Es gibt dann keine Preiserhöhung ab dem Preisanstieg, sondern man kann sich
jetzt nochmal das günstige Abo sichern und so auch unseren Podcast unterstützen,
worüber wir uns natürlich sehr freuen.
Und dann sehen wir uns wieder im Salon.
So ist es, bis dahin.